Yeah.
Jamie Tak,
tak,
who is fat Hashtag.
Did you tweet it?
Yeah,
Das was,
we're live.
We're live in front of three.
Tony knows pizzas a,
if you're in woodland hills,
California,
I highly recommend to Nino's get a smell
off of that bitch.
Get a smell off.
I smelled it when I came in.
They're legit as fuck.
Um,
no affiliation,
no sponsorship to just good pizza.
All right folks,
this,
today's Day two,
if you didn't tune into day one,
Thompson Guerra and Bert Kreischer made
a bet.
The bet is whoever can lose the most
weight,
uh,
over it was going to be over a three day
challenge.
It's been reduced to a two day
Fucking God.
Yeah.
And uh,
Tom got down from to 67 to two 19,
which is fucking staggering.
So how about a nice round of applause
for Tom Yesterday.
And how about a round applause?
We're Berg to 21 pretty fucking close
and staggering as well.
Both of you guys.
Amazing job.
So today's Day two,
I know you're burnt out.
You're dehydrated.
So let's just cut the shit and get right
to the way we go.
Right to the fucking way I should weigh
in first cause I have a feeling that
don't be scared.
Okay folks,
Jesus.
Oh,
by the way,
we did the height tests,
uh,
because Ari Shaffir who was supposed to
pay if they got below two 27,
are we supposed to pay for their trip?
The loser has to shave their beard and
the loser has to pay for the winners
trip of their choice ix.
Unless they can get down to two 27 and
which are,
should fear agreed that he was going to
pay.
But now our is balking and he's saying
that they have to be there.
Their height has to be measured because
the body mass index would indicate that
they have to be a certain height or
they're obese.
It was really weird.
So we,
we tested the heights.
Okay.
Um,
uh,
tom is just under six feet tall.
If all you assholes that say I'm five
foot two,
we tested me too.
I'm five,
eight and a cunt hair.
Um,
and burt is taller than Tom,
so burts good.
You're about six one.
So the body mass index.
I think you dropped dude.
You look good.
Get on here.
All right,
so bear was at two 21 yesterday.
You look significantly thinner today.
Hurting.
He's hurting.
Let's see,
he's getting on the scale.
Two 2120 for burt for one pound.
One pound less.
One fucking pound.
I think Tommy's got it here.
Let's say here.
Fuck.
Say Goodbye to my beard.
Say Goodbye to Hollywood on me.
He's going to Paris for a soccer game.
Please have gained weight.
Okay,
you fucking do 16 tom gets it running
away.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we have a winner in that Hashtag.
Who is fat contest?
The winner is Thompson girl down to 216
fucking pounds.
Outrageous,
outrageous coconut waters.
C Two oh coconut waters must be consumed
now,
get those electrolytes in your system,
boys.
Well done,
well done.
Amazing effort.
It's not easy to lose weight.
It's really not easy to lose it the way
you guys did it.
Two days in a row,
man.
Crazy shit.
That was the today was the hardest
workout I've ever had.
A rent eight miles last one fucking
pounds.
That's crazy.
I think my body was like in shock.
That's what happens.
That's what happens to fighters.
It,
it shuts down.
So have a seat,
guys pulled it off.
I've been thinking about that.
Drink this entire fucking day.
Beard,
you've got a beard trimmer over there
and charge it up.
Should probably a shave your beard after
you have some pizza.
I mean have a live a little,
I mean I have a hard time eating pizza
with his fat fucking face.
It's not going to look good.
How do you flow?
Wait man.
Got So fat.
Yeah.
You look pretty fucking skinny today
man.
You did.
You do look significantly skinner
Youtube skinnier today.
I don't know man.
I think you a little distended
yesterday.
Would that pulled pork and your stomach
from the night before?
The night before the weigh ins.
Collard Greens,
pulled pork.
I wanted though.
Seriously?
What is that long strand DNA strand DNA.
That Mickey Mantle James,
you got that Mickey Mantle.
Geez.
I gotta be honest with you.
Derek jeter.
You showed a little mickey mantle today.
How did you get down to two 16?
What did you do different?
You want to,
it's so funny.
You lost three.
He said something in passing and that's
what I did.
What?
But I just didn't acknowledge it.
He goes,
uh,
she go to Burke Williams and just sweat
it out in the spa.
That's what I've been doing for two
days.
I put abilene all over my body.
That's good.
And then I just sat in the steam room
yesterday and today.
Good move.
Yup.
Run in fucking 10 miles.
So you didn't,
uh,
you didn't drink any water?
Nothing.
No.
I did hot bath last night.
I did a two and a half mile track last
night.
Then I did what I'm saying,
like that's what I built up a sweat
doing that.
Then I recovered no water then hot bath,
abilene everywhere.
No water at all.
Not even a little sick.
I took a sip before bed.
I said after the hot bath,
Jesus Christ.
But I've also had nothing but distilled
water for about six days.
What's the benefits of the distilled
water?
Because minerals,
it goes right through your body.
It's easier to sweat out it that your
body doesn't like to retain it.
Apparently a lot of fighters do that
before they still cut weight to laugh my
ass off at seeing burt walk into the
spot this morning.
I was,
I was waiting for it to,
he said it.
I was like,
I reserved spot time at Burke Williams
at in Sherman oaks both days.
I was like,
you know what is better for me to work
it out?
Like I was like,
I'll be healthy.
I'll work it out and I'll sweat it out
and then like mile five I stopped
sweating.
Well,
was the thing about this whole working
it out stuff?
You're not losing any fat over the next
day.
You know,
like it's,
it's really just dehydration and you
might be,
might've been better off just sweating
it out then running and I hit my
baseline.
I mean,
I wasn't doing this week leading up to
it.
I just did right night before wanes.
So or morning before,
you know.
Yeah.
That's the way to do it.
What'd you get?
What'd you,
did you weigh yourself when you got
before when you got to Burke Williams?
No,
they didn't have a scale there.
Oh Fuck No.
But I weighed myself.
When I think about scale at a spa,
I dunno.
I would've definitely weighed myself
there and then I knew what I knew,
what I knew,
what I weighed when I woke up yesterday.
And then I knew what I weighed here and
I knew that what I had done to cut that
way.
Wow.
I just kind of repeat it.
There was no way.
Well,
I'll tell you right now,
there's,
I,
I feel,
I feel like I was bested all around
because there's no way I could've gotten
to two.
I would have had gotten two to 14 to
win.
Yeah,
I couldn't,
I couldn't have done that.
He would have to go below that because
you would add to lose by more than two
pounds.
You had to lose more than two pounds
because he beat you.
But two pounds yesterday.
So it would have to be like more than
that.
Well,
it's clear now cause you won both.
There's no mercy.
I feel embarrassed.
I feel like a chat.
I want to give a shout out to God
without him and nothing's,
none of this is possible.
And then,
uh,
Jake Smith.
Thank you.
Jake was jake,
uh,
he's a fighter who gave me all this
insight on ah,
oh cool.
Jake's
go fuck.
[inaudible]
shout out to its anybody.
Oh my God.
Can you do this?
Do you want your whole one Roni or do
you want Pepperoni and mushrooms?
All right,
get in there boys.
Get in there.
Jesus Christ.
Tomi think you'd hadn't eaten in two
days.
I'll see you guys hadn't eaten well.
Tommy
has been eating clean for a long ass
fucking time.
Not just two days.
Fucking get us some a,
yeah,
there you go.
You know Jamie on the paper towels.
This is some legit pizza to bundling.
Oh fuck.
Hmm.
Hmm hmm.
There's one of the rare times I think
it's okay to eat peach into the
microphone because
people need to appreciate the sacrifice
that you two went through as I eat pizza
there.
The,
the last few hours were really the
fucking worst.
Ma'Am.
Really?
Look,
I mean from waking up,
I got up at,
first of all,
I woke up with cramps at three 30 bad
leg behind the knee here on the outside
and then it will calf cramp.
That kept me up for like 40 minutes.
I considered like,
you know,
you start thinking about maybe I should
drink some water and dehydration clamp.
Yeah.
You think,
you know you could drag a whole one of
these and you still would've won by
three pounds.
Well I didn't even,
you probably good,
right?
Four of them and still one.
I was just like,
fuck.
And then you go.
And then I was just counting down the
hours.
So I spent the,
you know,
I get my son with Christina,
we spend time with them,
do a breakfast.
I'd look at,
it'd be like seven 30 and I was like,
Oh fuck eight 39 30 just counting it
down man.
And then in that,
in that spa,
sweating out,
doing like 10 minutes in,
five minutes out of 10 minutes in,
five minutes out every time.
And then I'm in there alone and the
attendant comes in with a big classical,
he,
I thought you might want a glass of
water,
and he handed me a cold glass of water.
Motherfucker,
you look like a psycho pouring it out.
Oh well I waited from leaving and I
threw it away.
Like angrily threw it away.
Just pissed that I can't drink it.
Yeah,
it was fucking livid.
And you really get to the place.
Like today on the treadmill,
I was literally chewing ice and spitting
it out into a shirt and I thought,
I know what those people feel like when
they dive deeper in the ocean.
They go,
there's fresh water 10 feet below.
You know?
There's people that lose their minds out
to see.
You ever heard of those?
People know what they think.
There's freshwater people have people
who are stranded at sea.
There's,
you always hear the guy that's like,
he's like jumps in and he's like,
guys,
there's freshwater 10 people lo and they
dive down below and drink seawater and
die or go crazy.
I know that feeling like I know I don't
know what to that extent,
but man I can,
I could empathize with it on that
treadmill.
The day I was like,
I was like,
I just want,
I just want to cheat.
I want water,
I want water so fucking bad.
Can you imagine the mind fuck of being
surrounded by water as far as the eye
can see and you're dying of thirst.
I remember,
remember I survived that,
that series.
Yeah man,
it was phenomenals if people haven't
seen it,
they did a series where people who are
in like extreme life threatening near
death situations and made it like
sometimes they were kidnapped,
assaulted,
sometimes they're an accident,
sometimes they're stranded at sea.
And there was one where this guy,
they were stranded off some somewhere in
the coast,
some Gulf of Mexico and boat overturns.
And it's just this guy and his buddy.
And he said like,
you know,
he's telling the story and as it
progresses he's seeing his friend kind
of slip away and the friend eventually
drinks ocean water and he's telling him
not to do it,
but he's so far gone.
And then it just accelerates the
friend's death and the friend died.
What happens when you drink ocean water?
You go crazy.
Your body craves more water.
It,
you've just,
I think call.
I think it makes you actually go crazy.
Whoa.
I've seen it.
Well,
I think growing up in Florida,
there's,
you always hear stories of the opposite
effect.
You,
you,
it doesn't hydrate you.
So I'm crazy that just anybody want more
pizza,
you know,
you do bitch,
get in there.
It's going to Tom,
you already won.
It's one day,
but I'm
fat.
You're not.
You lost a lot of weight bird.
He should.
Yeah.
Plus you're an inch taller.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
You're stupid tall picks buddy.
Sure.
It really is phenomenal.
So how do we shame Ari if he decides to
Welch out on this bet he will.
He's going,
he's going to,
I think so,
mom.
I'm just going to stay right now that
I'm paying for it.
Whatever.
Um,
whatever the cost is for the trip.
Come on,
man.
I will take care of it.
Well,
you guys were on my podcast,
I feel like,
uh Oh.
And Ari,
he doesn't owe me anything.
Fuck it.
Who gave me some weed?
Dude called me yesterday after the
podcast and an Ra rage.
You're bringing in a ruler tomorrow.
Well we did.
We measured them.
We already did.
We filmed it.
We measured it,
will upload them later.
He's just under six feet.
You're still,
you're still blow overweight.
Yeah.
Ours crazy.
I gotta be honest with when we started
this,
I was concerned about height cause I was
like,
I dunno if we're like I don't know what
I am.
At the end of the day,
I don't know when we're going to measure
me.
I know that I'm six one when I go to the
doctor,
but like I don't know what,
you know,
you just get scared and then,
and then that difference and overweight
versus obese has like six pounds from
six one to six foot.
It's two 27 to two 20
hmm.
And I was nervous.
That's a big difference.
But either way our,
he's wrong either way.
Even at a just under six feet.
Tom Has a little bit over at five,
five,
11 and three quarters,
right?
Yeah.
So it was just under six feet.
Yeah,
just under six feet.
That's a,
I think your body,
I think you'd have to be like two 20 to
be considered over,
right,
isn't it?
No more than that,
but is the,
uh,
find out young Jamie?
The thing is if you put in five 11,
that's as leaning the other way.
You know what I mean?
Yeah.
It doesn't do it.
It's not fair.
Okay.
Here it goes.
Does it do it
two 16 and that way you are right.
That's right.
Yeah.
You were to 16 so 29.3 is overweight.
Um,
but five 11 it'll say be so,
yeah,
I'm five.
Oh,
why?
Oh 11.
Oh five 11
obese.
Wow.
Well you're like on the cusp.
Yeah.
Wait,
if you were five 11,
you'd still be obese.
Yeah,
two 16 but it's all bullshit,
right?
Because I'm obese.
The,
my point is don't get,
or if you,
if he was being a stickler about this,
you'd have to find out what it is at
five 11.8 to be fair.
Can you type in five 11.8 now,
can you pause?
Can you point in?
Can you put in?
So what do you at what do you at six
feet or you're not obese,
six feet and that's crazy.
That one inch your be ob some one five
11 your normal at six 11 you'd be normal
Tom.
So there you go.
Whatever man.
But obviously that body mass index
doesn't count you.
You do have a lot of muscle and you do
do a lot of weight lifting and
insurance.
I watched a little bit of a podcast
yesterday.
Um,
that's where I'm going.
And Muscle.
Yeah,
I'm losing toenails running shit.
Well if you put muscle on,
the other thing is you lose fat,
your body starts burning it off.
Your body has more calorie requirements.
You have,
you have more body mass of more muscle
mass.
Um,
so if you actually put more muscle on,
you'll burn off more than you can eat
more.
I think I'm going to start doing
crossfit pretty aggressively.
I'm really looking for this,
a fresh face look to inspire me to work
out too.
Do you ever watch his face look with no
beard,
no beard.
Yeah.
Okay.
Here we go.
For the information you entered,
five feet,
11.5 inches.
Weight,
216 pounds.
Your body mass is 29.7 indicating you're
overweight.
So even with an extra one quarter of an
inch against you,
so you're a quarter inch taller than
that.
You win.
So Ari's wrong again.
So Ari,
if you want to be a cheap fuck,
I'm paying for the trip.
You fucking Twat so no it,
they'll pay for it.
I'm gonna let him pay for it now.
He's not gonna.
Let's terrible.
Ari and I are different humans then.
Joe.
Exactly comes.
I can't,
why not too busy?
Come on.
I'm not going to fucking Paris
48 hours.
Yeah,
especially for soccer.
Fuck off.
I wouldn't go to Paris for a UFC fight.
I forget fucking soccer.
What do you get a croissant?
I get that at starbucks right here in
good old man.
Come on,
we'll go sit at a cafe and write like
Henry Rollins.
You mock those world traveler people
travel so much.
But I like traveling to,
he was just so dead inside about travel.
He's like,
it's like putting gas in your car.
To him.
It's like,
oh great.
Burma.
I had a month where I went to Italy
three times back and forth,
back and forth,
back and forth.
I was like,
fuck,
I used to,
you still doing tv,
you're still doing any TV shows like
that.
Are you done?
I'm not,
I've never done,
I've never done it.
I've,
I mean my relationship with is always
open.
I liked them,
I dig them,
they're cool to me.
They've always been cool to me and
always work for them.
If it's a project that we both
collaborate on and one and we're into,
what I'm done doing right now is,
um,
is the kind of stuff where they call it
and they're like,
we need you in Hawaii tomorrow.
Cause I was like,
cause that was really messed up my
touring and I couldn't really commit to
any dates cause they'd be like,
cause you didn't want to turn it down
and you'd be in New Zealand and they'd
be like,
Hey,
would you go to Fiji for the,
for this weekend to party with the chef?
And you'd be like,
yeah,
because I was into that.
And they're like,
but Hartford,
they're expecting Hartford.
Come on.
Jackie's got locked.
Press lined up in Hartford.
Hartford too,
by the way.
Oh Jesus Christ.
Here's some places that I just don't go.
Don't go to Hartford.
By the way,
that's the one thing I should have
listened to.
Thompson Uhura Thompson,
garth variables when Tom,
tom and I like it.
I said,
we're at the level in our career.
Probably Tom was a,
Tom had told me there's a bunch of
places use it should say to go fuck
themselves and he would name them and
I'd be like,
oh,
come on man,
that's not a bad place.
And he'd be like,
no,
fuck that place.
They suck their GM socks,
their manager socks,
they're staff socks,
the co the crowd sock,
the press socks.
And I go and I was this company man,
like I remember talking to your wife
about it.
I was such a company man.
Yeah,
man,
I should've listened.
Yeah.
I'm not a big fan of going to
Connecticut.
I like people in Connecticut,
but I just feel like Connecticut has a
feeling and I'm so sorry if you listen
from Connecticut and my,
one of my best friends,
Tommy Junior lives in Connecticut.
I Love Connecticut people.
Yeah.
Pool player friend.
But the bottom line is Connecticut is
filled with despair.
It's not a real state.
It's a highway between New York and
Boston.
You know,
it's a highway.
You guys put houses on a highway.
This is what it is.
It's a highway.
And then along the highway it's a bunch
of fucking tax sheltering cunts that uh,
that live in Manhattan and then have
these palatial estates in Greenwich,
Kenneth Young,
Jamie digging in on that pizza can't
help themselves.
They'll get it.
It's so good.
We only cracked the top pizza too.
We've got two more below that age.
And one of them is mushrooms.
Oh yeah,
baby.
What are you trying to stick to?
Oh,
start drinking then.
Well let's do that.
Yeah,
there's ice.
We got glasses.
Yeah,
we got the whole deal and I bring out
the Jack Daniels to young Jamie.
We got that.
That's that type of vodka.
What is it that you liked?
Tote.
What does it to dose Tito's
do you have?
Why are you,
what is it about you that is so
confident to tell people to go fuck
themselves?
Well,
I don't think I tell people to go fuck
themselves to me.
And you like,
you know me,
you know,
you know the conversation we've had a
million times.
What is it about you that makes you go
fuck them?
Like,
do you remember,
uh,
that one place in Ohio that you went to
and you're just like,
fuck him.
I'll never go there again.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I'm not that guy.
I'm so the guy that you can step all
over and then I go,
I go,
Oh,
you know what?
Why don't you think that is though about
me?
Yeah.
Because I've sat,
I've talked shit about people like that
and it always comes back to bite me in
the ass.
It always comes back.
Like I see them next time and they're
like,
hey man,
it's so good to see you.
And I'm like,
fuck,
wait.
So that's,
that's why,
that's why I stopped having firm views
about things,
about,
especially about clubs.
Cause I was like,
it was a bad weekend,
but maybe it was me,
Ma,
you know,
like I always take the blame on me.
I don't,
I don't ever go like,
like you're,
you've always been accurate at doing
that too.
Going fuck that club.
Fuck that guy.
Fuck him.
I'll never work with them.
Nimble.
So I,
I feel like,
you know,
if I,
if I give like,
uh,
if I feel like something sucks,
I feel like I have a pretty good take on
it.
So in the same way,
you know,
I'm not going to be theirs.
We know in comedy there's a lot of
irrational people and there's a lot of,
you know,
comedians that are,
that,
you know,
bullshit about everything,
including how the show went.
And so I feel I'm a realist and I have a
pretty good,
no,
you can't do trust my cell phone.
You always tell me like you,
you have bad sets.
Yeah.
Like what was that thing in Canada?
The thing that went down to Canada.
That's so good.
My winnepeg bombing.
And you played that video,
right?
Or the audio on your podcast?
Yes.
Line was the,
what did the owners say to you when you
got done?
Ah,
fuck,
I don't know.
I got off stage and he goes,
oh,
are you gonna sell shorts?
Yeah.
Fucking merge.
How's that Solera this show?
Yeah,
saving buddy.
They booed me off stage.
I think you or your take on it was
accurate though,
that it's,
you're a very reasonable person.
So if you like,
that's,
I would say that too,
that if I don't like you,
you're most likely a con deck.
Cause I'm really nice.
I'm really nice and I give people a
chance and I get along with almost
everybody.
Almost everybody.
Do we have any coke,
Jamie or diet coke rather?
Either way.
I'll take regular coke.
I mean,
yeah,
if you're,
if I'm like,
fuck that guy.
There's no way he's pretty cool.
And the club,
like if I go fuck that club,
I'm telling you,
man,
I don't do that lightly.
That there's gotta be some real
agregious shit on their part to,
to earn that.
Maybe that's it.
Maybe that I'm a little bit of a
internal Dick.
No.
You know what it is your more of like
between the three of us.
Yeah,
you're definitely more of a people
pleaser and mean and,
and,
and that's just like a,
a thing about you and,
and it's why people like of the three of
us,
you know,
more people would say like what a fun
time it was hanging with you.
Yeah.
Retards.
Awesome.
I don't even know where that came.
So close to [inaudible] guys got a
purple bracelet on.
He's got a wristband damage.
Someone who leaves the house and ties up
Bandana on risks.
What are those ones that people put on
their dog?
Fucking me.
Burt.
Let me
flip flops on.
Let's do it.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
you're a real nice guy,
Bert.
You know,
and that's why,
I mean you and I've had some
conversations before where you've called
me up and told me that someone was a
dick to you or something that went
wrong.
And I get angry because I know what a
nice guy you are.
So when that happens,
I know that guy's a piece of shit.
You know,
we know the one that we were talking
about recently,
I was like,
well fuck that guy,
cut that guy off.
And I haven't talked to that guy since
that conversation too.
I'm like,
Hey,
this is just,
if you're a mean person for no reasons.
One thing,
if you fucked up something or you did
something bad,
but there's a lot of people in this,
in this business and in comedy in
particular that
you don't get,
you don't get the true wire from them.
You don't get the,
it's hard to figure out what exactly
went on.
They'll tell you something and then
you've got to throw it through a filter.
That's the worst,
right?
Like this guy,
this guy was a piece of shit and the
show was going great.
And then,
and then he talked to the guy like,
no,
no.
He was bombing and he was drunk.
Yeah.
He Shit on the stage is nothing like
the,
the fibbing that goes on in stand up.
I mean there's to get an accurate thing
that you have to know that you have to
trust the source.
Yes.
It's very,
that's why I always been like,
how this your show go.
Okay.
Yeah.
I'm never telling you when it killed.
I don't think I've told anyone I
murdered,
but you've told me it went great.
It went great.
You know,
there's nothing wrong with saying you
had a great show and actually it wasn't
great.
It was great.
Yeah.
But for me,
but my,
my,
I usually say their officers gentleman.
Cheers.
Hey,
cheers brother.
Hang on one second.
The end of the day.
Yeah.
Thank you.
Listen,
you got,
you hadn't started fat shaming me.
I wouldn't be healthier today.
Tears and if I wasn't scared that it was
going to backfire horribly,
I wouldn't have done some work too.
That's true.
Sometimes talking shit makes you work
harder.
You really were forced into a position
where have buddy,
I love you bro.
I love you too,
Tommy.
I love both of you guys.
Love you Joe.
I love you too buddy.
All right.
Now I feel the same way though.
Anyone if I feel like if anyone is,
is it Dick Hubbard particularly special
cont because he is such a nice guy and I
know people are like,
wait,
didn't you just fat shame him like an
asshole.
But I love him and that was as well in
on it.
That's the best of thing.
Kind of what we talked about yesterday
where so many people who are like,
yeah,
fuck bird.
I'm like,
no,
no.
You're missing the whole thing.
Everything is by the way,
silliness.
Some particularly mean comments that I
came across don't over the last 24 hours
to run long shore man.
I'm sure I don't even read instagram
anymore.
Really?
Yeah,
because the comments are seems so much
more active than anywhere else.
Well if you go to Instagram,
you'll see so many people was blocked
accounts.
It's one thing that histogram does that
I think.
I really firmly believe that if you have
a blocked account,
you shouldn't be able to comment on
other people's accounts because all
these people have blocked accounts and
then they talk mad shit,
other people's accounts and it's just an
anonymity thing because you can't lash
back at them so they can to leave.
How many chickens there are just
pussies.
Someone told me to do that very early
on.
They're like,
hey baker account private.
That way people,
you'll get more people wanting to follow
you.
I was like,
ah,
that's a dummy's idea.
The a,
the whole thing.
What they're doing is there's,
look,
there's a lot of people that don't want
you looking at pictures of them,
which is fine,
but if those same people will go on
other people's accounts and start
shitting on them,
which is what you get a lot.
Yeah.
You get a lot of fake accounts where you
going?
They have no posts,
no pictures,
but they're commenting left and right
and all these other people and how many
like borderline and even obviously fat
guys comments about like,
they're like you're fat fuck.
And you go to like their profile.
Like you're sadder than shit man.
Oh and so is your mother that's in the
photo with you?
Like you're both fat Brennan Schaub was
talking about the other day that he had
some guy just post some really nasty
shit about him and he,
and he went to the guy's page and the
guy has a kid and the guy's like holding
his baby up and he's like,
hey dude,
like you're a dad.
Like yeah baby.
Like what are you doing?
Like what kind of example is shedding
what kind of vibes you putting out there
in the universe?
It might eventually bounce back down
onto your daughter.
I've always wondered what comics and I
mean like I could probably guess them
have set up troll accounts to fuck with
other comics.
Oh,
did you know that John Walsh has?
I said,
oh,
but that's Drennan waltzes whole thing.
It's a half,
it's fun.
But um,
there was a comic that got busted
recently commenting on his own stuff
about saying,
yeah,
saying how funny he was and you know,
and checkout as homer.
Yeah.
He fucked up on facebook and he forgot
he logged in under the his right account
instead of his troll account.
That's beautiful.
Jamie was talking about a of of espn guy
that got busted or Fox sports guy that
got busted that got busted doing it.
Bayless.
Yeah.
Oh,
guy's a dummy.
Anyway,
because I saw him,
he was commenting about fighting some
MMA thing.
I'm just like,
is it something about when guys comment
on MNA MMA and they don't know what
they're talking about.
It's like me commenting on hockey.
I can't even,
ice skate is a weird thing because it
specifically the UFC is that I feel like
I can say certifiably,
I was in the Zeit geist when it blew up.
I was,
I was there when it started blowing up.
And even more importantly,
I was doing your podcast when it started
blowing up.
Look at this.
Skip,
you are the man,
exclamation point,
exclamation point.
I love the new show on fs.
One,
three exclamation points.
And then the first comment is w a t what
is,
it counts that people,
right?
What like that?
Yeah,
I love that.
What mean maybe I've seen that.
What mean with the,
no,
no.
The lady that looks like you don't,
I'm talking about and it just says,
I think this is t or Wuut ut use.
I use you to,
that one is my,
this is my,
like one of my favorite Internet for
what?
Oh,
by the way,
I can't watch hunting shows anymore
because you cause glass,
glass glass on this ridge and I just
started laughing.
I'm alone in my house,
my wife.
What are you laughing at?
I'm like,
do you know what?
Do you know what his podcast is done?
This is very specific,
but do you ever have,
like
when you're made into a meme,
that girl is
just look up w h a t or Wu t and it,
it's like a woman,
I think.
A kind of vague.
Yeah.
Huh.
Wow.
That's my favorite one.
Oh my God.
Horrible ones who are doing Ronda Rousey
in 10 years.
Does,
have you seen the Ronda Rousey 10 years
ones?
Is that where she's getting hit?
No.
There's a bunch of like really obese,
trashy women and one of them was
screaming at,
so some kid to get her a lemonade
lemonade,
which is juicy.
The Ronda Rousey radiohead cover.
No,
here.
Here she is right here.
Is that real?
No,
no.
That sounds fake,
right?
Yeah,
it's face.
Seems fake.
There's a picture of Ronda rousey
getting knocked out and then the radio
head cover and they look identical.
Can you pull it up to me?
Rough Times.
Rough Times in the house of browsing.
I've never been that down in my life.
I don't know how down that she feels by,
I didn't down salad days,
man.
Well,
it's a thing when you're fighting is a
different thing,
like losing a basketball game.
Oh Wow.
Wow.
But that seems like she's winning there.
That sort of laughing.
That's the radio head one.
That's her winning.
There's one of her getting knocked out
at the same,
there's one right there.
The head kick one.
Oh God,
what's really crazy is how just a year
and a couple of months ago,
she was on top of the world.
It's that kind of an adjustment that's
almost impossible for a regular person
to comprehend other than death or a loss
like that.
It was a very few events in your life or
your life will completely shift upside
down.
But even in death,
like if you,
if someone you close,
you're close to that you care about
dies,
other people are sympathetic and they
care about you and they don't treat you
like you're a piece of shit because
someone died,
right?
So in a lot of ways,
fighting is its own completely unique
kind of,
excuse me,
kind of loss because it's,
it's the only time where people openly
mock you for your loss.
Never seen people though openly mock
someone as much as they seem like
they're mocking Rhonda
in their defense,
in the people that are mocking.
First of all,
she had,
she did a lot of things that invited
this,
like the,
uh,
if you ever watch the ultimate fighter
with her and Misha Tate,
like,
you know,
she was ridiculous and like sticking the
finger at me should take it.
And after the fight she wouldn't shake
me should tate's hand.
And there was like a lot of non sport
anti sportsmanship,
like she do that on the home fight.
Also not touch gloves.
Wasn't that hurt,
didn't it?
Yes,
at the center.
Yes.
She touched gloves in this fight.
Oh,
she touched gloves at the beginning and
the,
but she didn't touch gloves before the
fight actually started.
She touched gloves at the stare down,
which I thought was like,
wow,
that's interesting.
And maybe her head's in a good place.
And then,
uh,
she didn't touch gloves afterwards.
But um,
do think that the world will turn on the
conor mcgregor when he loses for the,
they did.
The world turned on him when he did,
but,
but the world respected him in a massive
way because he jumped right back into
the fray and then he won.
And he also was fighting that way,
way different weight,
right.
He was,
he was fighting in a different way,
but everybody keeps chiming in on this,
including the UFC.
Or they say that,
you know,
nate's a one 70 bull shit.
Nate Diaz fought one 70 twice in the UFC
against dumb young Kim and against a Roy
McDonald and both times he was too small
and got ragdolled.
He's not a one 70 the reason why he's
not a one 70 is he's been fighting at
one 55 successfully his whole career and
it's fight before the conor mcgregor
fight,
he fought.
Michael Johnson had one 55 it looked
fantastic.
Nate is a 155 pound fighter.
That's what he,
that's those weight class connors.
Right now the champion won 55 but
they're different in size in that connor
can make one 45 nate eight can't make
one 45 so connor can dehydrate himself
down another 10 pounds.
Nate camp,
it's insane.
He probably can't anymore cause is put
on a little bit of bulk and now he's
fighting at one 55 I'm sure he feels
much more comfortable and healthy there.
He doesn't want to go down to one 45
again,
but nate is almost physically incapable.
I mean he would have to look like he's
on death's door.
Brutal by the way.
And I can't emphasize how horrible the
last couple of days have been and I mean
this is obviously a modified version,
like we're not pros but don't really
know
way better.
Both of you do then a lot of guys do
when they weigh in.
So whatever you drained out of your body
that was so hard is nothing.
That's what I'm saying.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
I peed in the shower and it was like
motor oil.
Yeah.
Oh really?
It was dude,
it was orange.
It was orange and there was just like,
like it's like my dick spit chewing
tobacco.
It was,
I was like a meme right there,
this supporting this morning and I went,
I cannot wait to get fluid in my body
and my,
my dick go fantasize about it.
To your mind really starts playing
tricks on you.
It's the fucking crazy thing.
That cris cyborg weight loss thing
again.
Yeah,
that was a horrible one.
And that one,
um,
espn covered pretty extensively by the
way.
Outside the lines,
back to the skip bayless nonsense about,
that's one of the things I think about.
Like one time I asked you like,
how do you fucking know so much about
this mma stuff and you go see only thing
occupying that space.
In my head it's the only sport I follow.
Right.
That's I think the great flaw of being
the all sport comment or oh you guys
are,
is that they're trying to keep up with
experts,
experts in all the sports and they just
don't have the,
like he might have a great take on maybe
in the NBA or something,
but then it starts to dilute somewhere.
You're not also going to be the best at
commenting on horse racing,
baseball,
football,
college football,
college basketball,
tennis,
got like people.
So then you're going to,
something's going to get lazy about the
way you comment on just
even something's going to get lazy.
There's no room.
Like here,
here's a perfect example.
I'm an expert in mma,
but in mma I defer to other people about
certain aspects of them.
Like if I want to talk about Jujitsu,
I talked to Eddie,
I talked to Eddie Bravo.
I say,
okay,
well like we had a conversation the
other day about a,
the Anderson Silva chell Sunday fight
and I incorrectly remembered it and
Eddie corrected me and we watched the
submission.
I'm like,
you're right,
you're right.
I remembered it wrong.
Yeah,
I mean I understand setups and I
understand technique and I'm a black
belt in Jujitsu under him and under John
Jacques Machado,
Geeky and Nogi and still my knowledge is
nothing compared to Eddie Bradley and
his,
his is like almost just like a gift to,
right.
No,
I mean he said,
well,
he's studied it his whole fucking life.
He's a wizard at it.
Eddie's a true jujitsu genius.
He's not just really good at techniques.
He's invented a bunch of setups and a
bunch of different pathways to
techniques that worldclass professionals
use and when he,
I mean when he watches it,
he definitely sees something.
They might see a hair or two past what I
see,
which is gigantic in fighting and so
then when it comes to Moitai,
I,
I know a lot about Moitai,
but I defer to like guys like mark tele
grata or Duke roufus.
I'll,
I'll ask them and they'll give me a
certain take on things that maybe is
different than than,
than my perspective.
This is like,
there's no way one person can understand
everything better than anybody else.
There's too much to know.
There's too much.
Even if you've got a guy who's an
overall like mighty mouse,
Demetrius Johnson,
who I think is the best fighter ever.
I mean,
I think if you look at his technique,
I think he's the best fighter ever.
There's guys that are better at Moy Thai
than him.
There's guys that are better Jiu Jitsu
than,
yeah,
he's just the best at putting it
together in his weight class and
dominating his,
his division.
But still there's gay,
there's,
it's too big of an ocean.
Well,
that's what I was saying that verbally,
very beginning of this conversation was,
I feel like both of us were probably
here in this podcast during this podcast
when,
when you have see signed the deal with
Fox,
which was I think the big blow up where
it was like,
now all of a sudden Fox was going to
brand it with,
with sports talent hosts.
And it was not just you and Goldberg.
It was,
it was,
uh,
it was like,
I remember hearing about big fucking Fox
events where they had it all there.
Jim Rome was going to comment on it or
no,
I'm not,
I'm just saying.
Right.
And that's what kind of socks because I
was like,
I was like,
I feel like,
you know,
I feel like the mainstream media was so
against it for so long that finally when
it pushed through to watch the
mainstream media do this,
like almost like fucking arms wide open
like that.
We've always been lucky.
Skip,
give us your insight about,
yeah,
it's,
it's just UFC.
It's gift.
Give us your insight.
It's such a complex,
it's not just putting a ball through a
hoop.
It's so lame when a Gig that is though,
cause the Gig that he has is this thing.
That's where it's like what's your hot
take on this?
And then those guys have to say
something almost that is somewhat
controversial
for a tribe.
Yeah.
It's very contrived.
It's like,
it's like,
you know what Joe,
I disagree.
Nate is a better one 70 I've seen it and
that,
that's just what I think.
And then that's like the take is that he
disagrees with you.
It seems like that's everyone.
Like,
I'm not like I'm not,
I'm obviously,
I'm not putting Amy Schumer on blast,
but I feel like these days,
Amy Schumer and Lena Dunham,
I don't even know if they have anything
to say other than the most aggressive
thing that everyone will react to and
then that keeps them famous.
Interesting.
It's almost like blowing air under a
feather.
It's hot air.
It's like,
it's like,
uh,
kicking the guy out of her show for,
for buying tickets and liking trump,
you know,
and then you go,
well,
she didn't kick him out of the show.
She just told him to get off the stage.
No,
she told him I'll leave.
Oh,
she's going to be the guy on stage.
I didn't watch the whole thing.
I don't know.
Yeah,
she brought the guy on stage,
but it,
she said,
if you're not voting for Hillary,
lead my show.
I think she was saying if you,
bu people were booing her because she
was talking shit about trump,
but I'm not,
I'm not trying to put amy on blast.
I'm just saying like Lena Dunham,
I wish I had been had had an abortion.
She said that she goes,
I wish I had had an abortion so I could
be with all the girls that I'd had
abortions.
I could be on your side,
whatever.
Well,
you know,
but she's overweight.
It's probably affecting our brain.
People say things when they're not
healthy.
That's how it,
that's how I used to feel.
That's how I used to feel too,
but like it feels like that's,
that's a way to the business.
It's a,
it's like that's the world she's in and
whether or not it's conscious or not,
you're,
you're sort of playing to those people
and I understand what she's saying,
like if she's trying,
look,
if they're trying to take away the right
for a woman to have an abortion and
she's trying to align herself with those
people and she hasn't had an abortion,
that's a reasonable thing to say.
I'm not crazy.
I'm not disagreeing with what she's
saying.
I'm,
I'm just pointing out that it seems to
me that the way I was just coupling on
what he said,
the way to be in the media these days is
to say the most outrageous things to get
the most activity on social media so
that you're still in the public eye.
I think these guys are scrubs.
That's what I think it is.
I think that guy's a mental scrub and I
think this kind of way of talking about
sports,
I think it's antiquated and I think it's
going to go away.
And I think that people just,
they gravitate towards it because it's
like a,
you know,
it's just gossip news bullshit.
So awesome that he wrote to himself like
such a dummy way to go.
Animation Point,
exclamation point.
I should start doing that every day.
Good job,
Joe.
Joe,
wait,
here I should,
do you know what I should do?
I should do like,
like really subtle insults,
you know,
backhanded compliments.
Yeah.
It's just the,
I,
that's that same mentality though.
The mentality that makes you write a
tweet and like that to yourself.
It's the same mentality.
The backhanded compliment you got from
an exact,
we were talking.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
Oh,
it was like,
we want guys that are like not like
really good looking and not super,
super funny but like kind of like middle
of the road.
Like we want to talk to you man.
We want to be a talent to be
threatening.
Then they offered no show.
We want,
we want you to be the guide that I feel
like me,
whatever regular guy I am at a regular
job,
I'm better than you stars.
We don't want stars.
We want guys that are accessible.
Not too good looking.
Yeah we don't,
we didn't want to host host.
We want a guy that it seems like
watching a TV go,
oh I could do that.
And they could like a guy that's not a
lot of talent,
a lot of talent all over the place.
Not that good looking overweight.
And I'm like okay,
is this a compliment?
And then like,
do you know what I mean?
Like glossy,
nothing shiny.
And I was like focus,
discipline,
easily replaceable.
She just takes off during contract
negotiations.
So we can just kick you out and then
they'll notice.
It's like,
remember when they are placed the
fucking husband?
I'll be,
which nobody gave a shit.
Yeah,
that's right.
And they both had the name Darren,
right?
No,
no,
no.
They both had the name.
They're both,
their names were very similar in real
life or placed.
It was different with that dude got
cocky and they fucking out at him.
Remember when they did that on Roseanne?
There were placed at one of the kids are
placed,
the kid,
the older daughter got replaced.
They just got a new daughter and they
made it like little subtle jokes about
her looking different really.
And then they switched her back again.
What were the two dads,
dads names and Roseanne Barr doesn't
give him a few blocks.
Okay,
here we go.
Well,
Bay,
which which debuted did the summer of
1964 was a rating smashed in the word
go.
The very attractive Elizabeth Montgomery
was a cast was cast in the lead.
Samantha the witch and a skiddish young
actress named Dick York was cast as her
mild mannered but hapless husband
Darren.
Okay.
So where's the Dick?
Sergeant,
sergeant and the sergeant.
So they had the same name?
Yeah.
So what is the difference?
Dick,
New York and Dick Sargent,
whether they look like,
let's go be wished husband's Dick
Sargent,
you know what a gay awesome steam room
name Dick Sergeant.
Hey Dick Sargent.
There you go.
Oh yeah,
the second guy was like a week or
chinned version of the first guy.
Couldn't stand up for himself.
When did we do this shave?
We'll do it afterwards.
We'll do at the end of the show and take
photos.
What about aunt Viv?
It wasn't that traumatizing to you.
Who's on Viv?
Fresh Prince.
I never watched that show.
There was two of them,
man.
I'm talking about bewitched and not know
aunt Viv by the way.
I had a surreal moment with will smith
when I first moved out to la.
We were in his car and an uncle Phil was
in the car in front of them and we were
and whose uncle?
Phil,
who was the dad and the younger guy that
he lived with his uncle
and he's a fan and please we'll through
his car in park and was like,
I'm gonna scare the shit out.
Uncle Phil or he said his real name and
he got out and ran up and then la and
then you watch this big man in this
fucking range over going like in the
front seat and then they got out and
they hugged and they talked for like
five minutes.
Super cool celebrity.
That is so fucking weird.
Very weird.
Apparently that guy travels everywhere
he flies.
Will Smith brings like a giant box of
books where there's a veracious reader
apparently.
What do you,
what do you want to give the skeptical?
Hippo.
Look,
I know you don't believe it.
No.
Why don't believe anything?
Why?
Because I believe everyone fucking
concocted own fucking horseshit reality
so that they sell it to the fans.
Never even been to Russia.
Why do you,
why do you say no?
No,
I mean like it feeling cynical because
you lost today.
No,
no,
that's not why I'm feeling cynical.
Dehydration so bad.
Let's have more coconut water.
Hey,
tell you that you wanted to win
so badly.
Yeah.
It really did.
I really want it to be to beat you in
this.
I mean,
like more so than,
than,
than uh,
I think,
you know,
it reminded me of,
I was never super competitive.
Like,
you know,
like I,
I played on sports teams my whole
adolescence and through high school and
I would,
you know,
play and compete and everything,
but I was more competitive with family,
you know,
and stupid shit,
right?
Like there's a new video game,
me and my sisters are playing it.
Then I was like fucking laser focused.
And this kind of reminded me of that,
of being like,
I think it's because we're close that it
reminded me of like a sibling thing
where like,
I gotta beat fucking Bert at this.
What's our next competition?
Oh my God.
Burt wants a rematch.
Yeah.
Does it hurt?
It doesn't involve fucking water.
I'll tell you that right now.
But you are the water champ.
He's a weird to not have water while
you're the water.
Cham man.
Like my hydration.
There's no explanation.
There's no explanation for my hydration
explanation for my hydration.
And
it's like cutting the water was like a
vacation.
Are you Muhammad Ali?
Frustration with my hesitation on my
hydration.
All that Shit,
man.
Yeah,
I mean it really was all about a
vacation
and I did.
I followed that.
What I was told pretty much to a t j
Smith.
What a Dick.
Where's jake fight?
Let me look it up.
Yeah,
look,
Jacob [inaudible]
how important was it to you,
Bert?
It seems like you were kind of like
throwing in the towel this morning when
you came here.
You're in pain.
Fucking,
well,
you did it differently than him.
He did.
He did the long haul.
You do.
You did the longs tramp.
But did the sprint,
the long strand.
I did.
Long Strand DNA march.
Do you look back on like the last few
months?
Fucking I could have tightened this
bitch up.
There's a couple of mistakes.
I made.
Five and one.
Jake Smith,
no photo of him.
Uh,
he fights and pri prime fighting eight.
And uh,
so he's fighting it some smaller,
but
it looks like he's got a good record.
Holla,
Holla Jake.
But there's a lot of guys out there that
are good at cutting weight,
man.
I've seen some dudes eliminate
ridiculous amounts of their body weight.
There's nobody better than this guy
named glace and t bow who got popped by
Usada.
He got caught with a gang of shit.
You system.
Yeah.
I think at two or three different banned
substances to get a bunch of tweets
yesterday that we should,
uh,
we should be helping,
some big name guy to do it.
They're like,
why don't you help fucking,
what's his name?
Do it.
He must've not cut weight recently.
Which guy?
Oh by the way,
I can totally see that training for the
fight and not cutting weight and be
like,
ah,
my bad guys.
Well it does happen,
but you lose a shitload of money.
We got,
we got a bunch of them yesterday.
I can't remember.
Isn't that great board last 30,
perceive one this weekend he was 30% of
his purse cause he was more than three
pounds over.
So he has to give 30% of his purse to
his opponent,
which is crazy.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
When it,
which is crazy.
And he looked fantastic.
Ray Borg is a super talented guy,
but that's a a,
that's a big amount of money to give to
your opponent.
But three pounds at flyweight in
particular,
it's a lot.
We'll heat,
they're fighting at one 25 and Ray Wade
one 28 point something.
There's a lot of missteps.
I made 29 actually cause they gave him a
pound over.
They give you a pound to fuck with
because it's not a championship fight.
During a championship fight you have to
wait on the nugget.
Like if it's one seven you have to wait
one seven you can't wait wants once.
It's actually exactly,
exactly.
But um,
in a non championship fight you get a
pound play with how often does it,
cause I've been at a number of ways with
you that um,
they have to just lose the underwear to
make weight.
Cause that I've seen that happens.
So that's wet underwear on can two or
something.
It could weigh very little,
but that's enough.
It's the tipping amount because a lot of
it is one of those balance scales and
just it's just a hair,
an ounce,
whatever it is.
And then sometimes if they,
if they're still over what you have been
an hour,
you have it depends on the commission.
It depends on how you mean.
It really depends.
It depends on where you're at.
They do different weigh now.
They do early Wayans the Wayans take
place early in the morning now.
The day of the fight.
Yeah.
The day before the fight day to recoup
after you have to die.
They started doing that after Duk Koo,
Kim [inaudible] and duck,
who kim had this crazy fight.
They changed a few things after that
fight.
One thing they changed is they stopped
doing 15 round fights and they brought
them down to 12 rounds and another thing
is they started,
I think that's when they started doing
Wayne's the day before.
But I could be mistaken.
Dehydration fucks with your brain.
Yeah.
It fucks with your brain pretty
hardcore.
Yeah.
It fucks with your ability to move.
It fucks with the w literally the way
your nervous system,
like your body works sort of.
I mean obviously I'm going to fuck this
up,
but there was a electrical current
through your body that relies
on water to function at its best.
I felt stumbling today.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Like I definitely felt stumbling on the
treadmill.
I was off for sure.
Your body is not functioning correctly.
You don't,
you boys need some marijuana in your
system.
Oh my God.
I don't know about that.
Definitely
going through this drinking.
Not enough marijuana.
You haven't even had pizza already.
Visions go and this'll be good.
Well,
it's a good anti-inflammatory frogs.
Oh,
okay.
Plus it's legal.
Oh yeah.
Very true.
It is legal.
It's a nice,
yeah,
that's writing sound.
Connor.
Yo,
I go for the green.
I'm Tin Cup.
What's Tin Cup?
He went for the green,
like he just couldn't stop going for the
green.
Today's the first day in a four days
where I haven't felt like I have to shit
myself.
Some super psyched about that.
I had a stomach bug for the last four,
four or five since Thursday.
I got it.
I noticed it on Thursday.
Really?
Yeah.
Yeah,
that Tommy,
can you think of drag?
You're going to get another drag?
I don't think so.
I sound James High for fucking eight
hours after I had to drag.
That is a crazy,
there's 24 hours in a day,
bro.
What are you worried about?
What does that sound?
Probably UFO reports here.
He'll pass it to me.
Do you guys see the stealth bomber
yesterday?
No.
Flying over the valley?
Yeah,
it was [inaudible] 52 stealth bomber
flying over the valley.
Really?
And I'm probably losing bad at something
like trump's in office.
I got into,
I got into a b 52 into the Turret
gunner.
Is that right?
Be 11 I don't know which one it is.
You know the one that had the little
ball underneath that you had thought of
that and not,
I'm not sure I got into one of those one
time.
Holy Shit.
You want to talk about panic?
Yeah.
Do you ever fly in one of those?
No.
I flew in an FAA 18 once with the blue
angels.
I had a bit about it.
I did in my act.
It's fucking amazing.
So crate.
Yeah,
we went seven and a half gs.
Oh by God.
Seven and a half saying,
yeah,
there was some actor before me did five
g's and I'm like,
fuck that pussy.
I going to beat that guy.
Let's ramp it up.
And so we went,
we went pretty deep.
What did that feel like?
Insane.
Like a,
an elevator door is closing in on your
brain.
Like you see the darkness coming in from
the left and the right.
Like literally you can see it.
You could see your consciousness closing
really?
Yeah.
And you,
you do a thing called the hooking.
We hold on to,
there's straps,
like you're all strapped in and you hold
onto your straps or the pilot would hold
onto the handle and you go like this.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And you are literally forcing blood into
your brain to stay conscious and just
the pilot through that too.
He has to,
yeah.
Yeah.
That's crazy that there's something that
the pilot could do that could pass them
out.
No.
That's one of the things that I'd have
to go hook,
hook,
Hook.
If I did another one,
we were,
we were fucking,
we were flying maybe,
I dunno
how,
how far off the ground but pretty low in
this canyon range.
That somewhere between San Diego and
Arizona.
Is that what it is?
San Diego in Nevada.
What's their Arizona right.
Nevada's up.
Um,
so it's this really crazy area where
it's all this blue angel test flight.
It's like where they,
they practice is this air force base out
there and it's where they do their test
Ron's and they drop things like if the
tests like where they would like drop
bombs I guess.
And you're flying through this like
small mountain range fucking nuts,
man.
And while we're doing it my,
I see the darkness on the left and the
right closing in and I'm trying to stay
awake.
I'm going
and I hear the guy in front of me doing
it.
Oh,
is this a guy?
No,
definitely not.
Yeah.
What is this champion?
A bunch of people just,
it's like hilarious g force training,
but oh yeah.
This is Eliza.
Eliza.
In 50 years.
This is a g force hill training though.
This is not a actually being in a plane,
being in the play.
She forced train.
That's Bobby Kelly,
chief voice training.
It's Ilan gold.
G4S training is cool.
Cool.
Bobby.
Yeah.
The thing about the g force training
though is,
you know you're in a simulator,
you know,
I mean it might be crazy and spinning,
but you're not flying like you're not,
you can't look down and a hundred yards
below use a mountain range.
It was nuts,
man.
This guy was a bad mother fucker.
This pilot,
he took me through this wild ride
through these canyons and I heard him
doing it too.
He's going to,
so I'm like,
he's experiencing it too.
Fuck man.
Dude.
When when they hit turns,
that's when it's nuts,
man.
It's like,
there's like,
there's banking turns that they make
where there's so much panic just
watching it.
The fact that they find spun around in a
circle,
they fly in tandem.
How fucking he fucking fly in war.
Like,
look how much you're moving still.
Yeah.
So these guys fly in war like this and
they go,
yeah,
he's hooking right now.
That guy's doing that shit right now.
It's nuts bro.
I'm telling you it is like nothing I've
ever experienced physically and it just
makes you understand like the weird
demands that you've got these holes,
your body has like a very narrow window
that it can operate in as far as like
atmosphere,
as far as temperature,
as far as pressure,
all those things are very narrow.
Like you're very,
we're very vulnerable.
It's one of the reasons why fighting is
so interesting.
Like you take apart like this Ronda
Rousey fight for example,
you take a person that's obviously very
physically strong,
right?
Like of a female cage fighting champion
and she,
you see her muscles and you see what she
can do,
throwing people around,
but you realize even a person it looks
like that is super vulnerable.
All you have to do is get hit.
Bang.
Somebody hits you badly,
hit you again.
All of a sudden you're in trouble.
Bang,
they hit you again.
You can't respond and then you get
knocked out.
Like,
as tough as a person might think they
are is like in shape as a person might
think they are.
If you get in one of those Goddamn jets
and you fly at seven and a half g's,
you'd take one some crazy turns and your
body's literally like giving you got,
you're going to go unconscious from the
pressure.
It's a makes you realize like,
wow,
I'm so frail
are so frail.
Dude.
I was,
uh,
I think I may have told someone about
this.
I'm sure.
I don't know.
My Body's starting to recoup back to old
burt right now with all this once more
coconut water.
No,
no,
no.
I even vodka and that was perfect.
I feel really good right now guys.
I'm skinny and big.
Uh,
when I,
when I went hell of skiing in
Switzerland,
we went up to,
I think we went up to like 10,000 feet,
maybe 7,000 feet.
And it was,
uh,
in the mountains.
They took us up.
Helis game drops us off of my dad was
like,
you're going to,
you can get really hurt,
but you're so confident.
Like you live in this bubble.
Where nothing happens to you,
but up there I couldn't even navigate.
Like I couldn't even traverse the
mountain a little bit to get within the
line that we need to do to ski down.
Like I couldn't even walk through it.
So was like four foot powder.
So you're literally like,
like,
I mean it's up to your waist,
like you're stepping and it's up to your
waist and you're like,
Holy Shit.
Then I,
I couldn't even get my board on.
Finally,
they helped me get my board on.
We start snowboarding and they're
telling us there's crevasses to the
right.
It's like,
okay,
stay within five feet from me to the
right to the left and then,
uh,
I don't,
I'm not good with accent.
Oh my God,
he's hilarious.
He's like,
what countries is Switzerland?
Pretty good.
It sounded pretty good.
You got to stay around me by lab.
Did the bride to the Lens Cajun.
I got to put this a beacon on you and
then when you got there begging
on you,
you're all good.
Okay,
here we go.
And so we start going and I,
for some reason I can't turn left.
Like I can still work perfectly fine,
but I can't turn it off.
There's so much powder.
And I noticed that I'm just floating to
the right away from his little fucking
marks towards where there could be
avalanches are crevasses.
And I'm like shit.
And I'm thinking to myself,
this is like real vulnerability,
like going like I can't,
I can't go lie,
I can't count for some reason it's too
much pattern for me to turn left.
So finally I just fucking cut it and I
start cutting hardcore left.
I go,
okay,
time to go back right now I can't turn
right and I fucking,
I'm facing face forward down the
mountain,
cutting left.
And I see them in front of me am I,
I catch a nose and I fucking land face
first into the snow,
four feet and I'm under the snow.
I'm gone.
And so I go to push up and as I put my
arms forward,
they just disappeared.
They just,
nothing,
they don't touch anything.
They just go into the snow and the no.
And I'm like,
and I immediately realized my
vulnerability.
I'm like,
oh my God,
man,
this is it.
I'm on it.
I'm 10 down.
I'm guessing.
I don't remember the exact type,
900,
9,000 feet up a mountain and I'm the
last one on this line.
No one saw me fall.
When will they start looking for me?
When,
what will happen to me within that time.
Like,
and I start fucking panicking like
hardest shit and I'm trying to move and
flip myself at least open to my back and
I can't,
I can't get,
I can't move at all.
And I hear my dad in my head go told you
you're going to fucking die.
And I was just like,
I know.
And I was like freaked out.
And then,
and then this I was on,
I felt this hand on the backs we all had
like these harnesses on with a beacon.
This hand pull my harness up and he's
like,
you should see or sound guy.
And my sound guy is upside down skis.
Literally.
Like he's doing a handstand in the snow
gear everywhere.
And when they pull him up,
he's like,
fuck this mountain.
Let's get off this fucking mountain
right now.
It was fucking,
but you think,
oh,
I'm a great skier.
I could do this.
And then you forget,
you forget
you though.
You,
you don't realize your vulnerability
every time you do an adventure thing.
Yeah.
Anything that's like an adventurous and
they're like,
especially like when you,
you realize how much,
like nonchalantly you put your life in
people's hands and that thing is when
it's,
you know what I mean?
Like you go like,
oh,
I'm going to pair a sale or something.
And they're like,
oh,
this place does it.
And then you realize it's just some guy,
you know who fucking hangs out at that
peer.
He is managing,
you know,
he's managing your life there.
If you get on like a fucking
rollercoaster.
I even think about it in cars sometimes.
I know like a couple of comics that go,
uh,
I won't let somebody drive me anywhere.
Like I know a couple of guys that are
like,
no one's allowed to drive me.
And I'm like,
why?
And they're like,
I'm not letting just some fucking guy to
drive me.
I won't take,
what if he's a horrible driver and they
just,
they're like almost panicked about it.
But then sometimes you feel that
vulnerable.
Like you realize it when you have a fuck
off guide driving you,
you know,
like he's like what's that?
And like talking to you and you're like,
that's the worst when they're looking up
in the rear view at you,
you're like,
please don't.
And if you're going 80 please don't.
That's Uber X,
right?
Yeah.
Uber X.
I got a new box to go to a podcast and
they were like,
we'll send you an uber.
And I was like,
oh,
I'm just so used to taking the black car
cause that's what I take.
So I'm used to that.
I don't mind having a black hard
driving,
cause I feel like the guy,
he's got a show for license on the side
somewhere,
but like the uber x,
it was just this fucking Chinese guy who
was like 60 years old in a fucking
civic.
Perfect.
And I was like,
oh,
this is great.
And he was horrible.
I was like,
I don't think he learned how to drive in
his country,
let alone this one.
And he is literally,
and I was like,
how?
How recently had be,
hey,
been in America.
Uh,
he was not speaking very good English or
like horrific English.
This is what he sounded like.
Okay.
I'm going to take you up on it.
Four or five
swaying to the left swinging too there.
It sounds like Yaakov.
Yaakov.
Yeah.
I did an interview with the alcove on my
podcast.
Good Dude.
He's a great dude.
He's a good dude.
He's at the comedy store.
Okay.
All the
time.
It's a very friendly,
he's like his own right?
Isn't that the thing
he has sold in Branson,
Missouri,
right?
I think he got rid of it.
Did he?
I,
when I interviewed him,
it was probably a year ago by the way.
Brands and music is pretty fucking bad
ass and he was getting worse.
It from Kansas City.
I have no clue.
He's in,
he's a really nice guy and he's a smart
guy and he's a good joke writer.
Yeah,
just the jokes are funny man.
He's just a guy that,
uh,
you know,
came up during a really strange time,
you know.
All right.
Just texted me.
What'd he say?
You said you were six.
One,
you're actually under six feet.
He's mad.
Yeah.
I wish we had a phone line to patch him
in.
Let's not do it.
He'll get mad.
We did it yesterday and it was a
disaster.
He's angry
a lot.
He's such an interesting friend to have
on the spectrum of friends to have one
of those.
Yeah.
It's just so I feel like,
uh,
I'm going to step in as his friend and
pay for this whole thing because you
guys did it on my podcast,
so I want to,
why do you keep saying that?
Yeah,
just let it go.
All right,
so I'm going to take care of it.
So Ari,
a,
you're off the hook,
dude.
Sorry.
Just,
I don't want to seem upset.
It just gives you a minute.
Well also like it was,
it might've been his idea,
but honestly I benefited from it more
than anybody cause you guys did it on my
podcast.
It's been good.
Podcasting and fine.
It's your first time ever.
We've never done two in a row like this.
Yeah,
I've never done something along these
lines.
Tom was like called me when he was like,
we're doing two in a row or you don't
have to carry this.
I'm not that funny.
And I was like,
I like doing two permeable podcasts.
Let me ask you this before I forget.
Well what,
what could you have done to get yourself
out of that snow?
Oh,
nothing.
But a lot of people get trapped in the
snow like that.
Is there a thing you're supposed to do?
He's supposed to move the snow away from
your face and you have air.
I'm sure there is.
I'm sure you probably should start
packing snow down and around you.
I don't know.
My camera man,
Kendall is a professional snowboarder
and he um,
he had a very similar experience.
We talked about it that night at a bar
and Switzerland and uh,
he was telling me,
he was like one time he was flying
through the,
he was going through the tree lines.
He went in for me to do an accent.
He was going through the tree lines and
he hit a tree and all the snow that was
in the tree buried him.
Oh my God.
And he was here and he was upside down,
upside down.
And he was in,
I guess it's called like a tree wells,
people who ski no more,
no more about this than I would,
but apparently what happens is no snow
falls around the tree at all.
And then it's very,
very light packed snow so you can get
buried in it.
And he was like,
he said he,
it was,
his back was fucked up but he was trying
to get out and he couldn't get out and
he was like,
Oh shit,
this is how you die.
I've had,
I've had three friends dice a
snowboarding,
like three friends,
three friends die,
snowboarding,
hitting trees and shit.
One hit a tree,
one skied off a mountain.
Ooh.
And I saw his wife recently and I was
like,
and I haven't seen her since he died.
And I was like,
just so you know,
I think about him a lot,
you know,
cause I think,
cause I went snowboarding.
When you go snowboarding in Switzerland,
it's above the tree line.
So like where's your definitely cleared?
Isn't it weird that you're allowed to do
some shit that kills people and nobody
bats an eye?
Yeah.
And everybody looks forward to it,
you know?
But if you,
if we were going skydiving,
you know,
and like there's,
or there's a place,
I went skiing in Aspen and uh,
I went to this place and I was like,
how many people die here and here?
This dude who lives there,
he goes at least one or two.
Every year I get one or two every year I
go,
what usually happens?
It goes trees.
They hit trees,
they flopped.
They fall off mountains,
they break their necks.
I go,
really?
He goes,
yeah,
one or two.
Every year I'm like,
Whoa,
there's a freak.
Everybody out there.
Like I guest skiing,
so fun.
They just go,
fuck it.
Yeah,
go think about scuba diving.
They fly off,
gone.
Hitting the tree is at least probably
really lights out really fast.
It was watching a video of a,
my friend Aubrey is a really good scare.
He gets skee,
skee,
look,
I can survive,
but he get,
I've only been skiing for four years,
but he could ski like he gets on his
keys.
He's like any human being who's using
skis these days can really ski like
everyone else.
Everyone my age just snowboarded.
But if you,
if you're a grown man and you're on
skis,
you know what the fuck you're doing.
That's not totally true.
I learned skiing.
I never snowboarded.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I learned skiing for years ago.
Like here's the Aubrey flying down this
hill.
Like look,
see,
like you could tell when you look at a
guy like that move,
like who can actually ski and skiing now
that I'm skinny when I'm doing this.
Yeah,
dude,
for sure you'll be doing a lot of
things.
It's like taking a weight vest off,
but when I'm looking at him scam,
like this is a motherfucker that skis so
smooth.
Like,
that's a guy's been skiing like a long
time and he really knows what he's
doing.
My skis are always further apart.
I look all goofy.
I'm not that like,
he's really good if you've talking
fucking polls is good.
And he's really good friends with that
Bodie Miller guy who was at world
champion cause interesting guy.
Fuck yeah.
Yeahs mean to.
I've a good buddy of mine who was on the
US Olympic ski team,
my friend Steve Graham from time we were
kids,
he was a,
he's my friend,
he's an ophthalmologist.
And when uh,
I was a kid,
I was like 15 or 16 I met him whenever
he,
this guy had at at the time maybe 10
surgeries on his knees,
10 like giant scars up and down his
knees where they used to have to open
them up like the old days when they do
surgery,
they would cut you open like a fish and
just stitch stuff together and hope it
hung on.
Fuck that.
But like skiing,
like getting really good like that.
Like how old were you when you were
learned?
45 shut up.
That's gotta be fucking have eaten shit
hard skiing before.
Well,
when I was a kid,
man,
I avoided anything that I thought could
possibly hurt my legs because I was
doing so much taekwondo cause I was,
you know,
so uh,
obsessed with martial arts.
Yeah.
I was like,
and it's so dangerous has it is I'm
like,
I'm not taking any extra dangerous.
Like I'm not going to break my leg
skiing or break my arm on a motorcycle
or get fucked up and that way,
like when I'm already doing this.
So I avoided all that stuff.
But Dad said that to me and we went to a
windy gap who's like a youth camp,
uh,
with Christian youth camp.
We yet to see Jesus by the end of the
week.
I saw him,
I met him.
What happened?
The shower.
Whoa.
I had to tell my story to the camp.
What happened?
They were like,
you haven't seen Jesus got burt.
Where's Jesus?
And I was like,
and I had just taken a shower that day
and I had like a cool moment.
They shower,
going like being,
feeling grateful for life.
I was 18 getting ready to go to Florida
state and there were like 18 in this.
I thought you were 11.
That's so funny.
Yeah,
I was 18
I could smoke cigarettes but you
couldn't smoke there.
And uh,
and they brought me up in front of camp
and I was like,
they're like,
have you seen Jesus?
And I was like,
I saw what was being real,
which is I think the PR,
the Predominant Times that I'm funny as
what I'm trying to be sincere.
And I said,
I saw,
I saw him in the shower today and the
fucking place fell apart and they're
like,
just sit down.
I was like,
I did have a cool moment in the shower
where I was grateful.
Why can't you find why Jesus
when you're naked?
Why does it Jesus has to come?
When you were in your tie with your
shoes tied,
you should be able to be aroused and see
why not.
You should be like about to come and you
see Jesus and you clamp down to your
Dick.
Like you're trying to choke it to death.
Stop the come from coming out.
So you don't want to be disrespectful,
right?
And then you go,
I love you Jesus.
And then he let it go.
What if Jesus said it's okay son,
you can come.
They'd be a big time believer when
people are angry.
Listen to,
was talking about this right now.
Angry cause you're not supposed to be
talking about Jesus and pleasure.
Yeah.
What if,
what if Jesus came to you in the middle
of a massage?
You're lying on your stomach.
No sexual organs are involved.
But when someone has like oil on your
end there on your back and they're
rubbing their elbow across the spine,
just loose and everything,
I'd be know that feels like,
ah,
arguably there's times where that feels
as good as coming,
right?
Arguably right?
Like,
but why is that okay?
Cause it's not sexual.
Like what weird rules do we have about
touching each other where you can lay
down on your stomach and some lady that
you don't know can rub her back on like
rubber elbow rather deep into your back.
And it feels amazing.
They're rubbing your feet incredible.
Someone rubs your feet.
Oh I feel so good.
But as long as it's not that good,
like Dick good.
Yeah.
Dot.
As long as it's not balls.
Good balls and Dick and balls and Dick,
hey,
hey.
Can you rub the ass?
The cheeks?
Yes.
Yeah.
And a dangerous massage.
They rubbed your cheeks.
Dangerous.
Oh,
they're just getting into the gluteus
maximus here.
Oh,
so I'm gonna say it's not my hip
flexors.
Don't touch my ass all it's right there.
Don't touch her so close.
Like,
like fucking danger
zone three not allowed to talk.
You know,
why can't they touch our dicks?
It doesn't,
because we grew up like big babies.
We had fucking ridiculous puritans who
got on rafts powered by the wind.
They floated over to some place they
weren't even sure existed.
They set up a bunch of stupid rules and
the echoes of that stupid rules,
fuck with our dicks and assholes today.
I think they,
you know,
that was the whole,
the whole product,
the whole thing about that.
Uh,
there was a fucking doctor who was
giving women orgasms and that was his,
his thing.
Yeah.
Do you know what I'm talking about?
I do.
Yeah.
There's been a couple stories like that
were doctors start fingering their
patients to like to get them out of a
hysterectomy is like,
well hysterical word,
hysterical comes like that's another
one.
The word hysterical had something to do
with like hysterectomies didn't it?
Isn't that like the origins of it is
that they used to,
some doctors used to actually manually
manipulate women to orgasm.
Yeah.
Back in the day there's an the day
before people get scared of vaginas.
There's a doctor in beverly hills called
Doctor squirts.
Whoa,
that's not a real doctor.
Stop right now.
Don't use your credit card.
Burn
fact that
that fucking guy decided to go with Dr
Squirts.
But that's what the women call him.
Oh my God.
So my wife said to me,
her friend Sandy,
or like they heard about doctor squirts
and they were talking to me.
They're like,
is that cheating if we went to doctor
Squirt,
cause he apparently gives you a massage
and then gives you an orgasm.
It's like the best orgasm you've ever
had.
That is so crazy that women are,
but it makes sense.
It's
like if a woman was a check with a,
a good job and she's busy working and we
have to corporate ladder just now.
Tom Tate assholes.
But she wants to get finger banged.
Yeah.
Why couldn't she just do that?
That's uh,
that's in that new movie.
Um,
where is it?
Yeah,
the,
there's the fuck.
It's a,
it's like the legal thriller that's out.
And she's the,
uh,
attorney and she has,
she hires guys to come on.
Yeah,
she's like busy,
busy,
busy.
What movies?
Um,
fuck.
What's her name?
The red head.
Uh,
I have to look it up,
man.
Miss Miss Sloane,
is that the name of a movie?
Oh yeah,
I know you're talking about,
I know it's not about,
it's about gun control.
She's alive.
She's a lobbyist or a lawyer
for a lobbyist.
And I'm Jessica chastain.
So she plays like this really,
you know,
high power.
Um,
she,
it's finger banged.
She goes,
she hires dudes to fucker in hotel
rooms.
What did she only has like and she hires
them for like an hour got in it because
she has all she has is like,
you know,
was very little free time.
But anyway,
Liam,
Liam was talking about Dr Squirts.
So do you think it's cheating?
Would you let your wife go to doctor
squirts guys
get paid to be able to bank checks like
that?
Yeah,
like that is in,
in society's eyes.
It's probably a way less looked down
upon then a girl pays for sex.
Like that guy is actually a stud.
Isn't that odd?
Is I like the guy,
if a guy gets paid to go and fuck a
girl,
you don't go out of that poor bastards
being exploited.
Right.
You Go,
what?
He's a stud.
Right.
But if,
uh,
if it was the reverse and it was a male
lawyer,
right.
With red hair.
Oh,
you didn't get sex.
Right?
Cause it the beautiful lawyer with red
hair.
Oddly enough,
if it's a woman,
yeah,
it's extra attractive.
And if it's,
if it's a man,
it's open season on jokes.
Right.
Ginger jokes.
I don't get it.
I don't know what the fuck's going on
with that red hair discrimination we
have in this country.
It's prevalent here.
Yeah,
it's a pretty strong,
but if a guy was a male lawyer with red
hair,
decided to get a prostitute,
we feel bad for the hooker.
Right.
This poor girl,
she's just gone down a pat road,
but meanwhile,
this dude with a leather belt around his
dick,
you know that's,
yeah.
Strolling into town.
He's just like,
yeah,
he's like a swinging Dick.
He's just a Dick slinger.
Yeah,
I know.
Weird.
And getting paid.
Paid.
How many of those are there?
I remember that was like American
Gigolo.
Richard Gere.
Fuck Outta here.
Yeah.
Magic Mike about Gigolos too.
Yeah,
there were.
There were strippers.
I don't know if they were fucking girls,
but I'm sure they were.
Then there was that Gigolos show.
There was a Gigolo show.
Wait,
what was the guy?
Yeah.
Yeah,
man was followed around.
Real ones.
Oh my God.
It's amazing.
You've never seen Gigolos.
No.
I always learned about awesome things
from you.
That's all he fucking does.
I thought about it last night.
I was like,
you know,
I'd never heard of Diane at word and
before him,
they're the best ob.
He was talking about Diane word when I
Ella was born like you were talking
about it in 2006.
It talks about what Shit Diane word.
You don't even have to send the member
then.
Oh yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Those guys are the shit.
I love that.
And you were like,
what is this?
And then I watched it and then became
obsessed with Yolanda foster.
Oh,
they're both amazing.
Gigolos
nick hawks in bag on the other end.
The far right.
The guy in the far right to rapper.
Who in bag know?
So Jay,
you know their names.
Oh my God.
Tommy buttons.
I mean there's brakes.
He's like the,
the paternal whore a of group.
And the students covered in tattoos.
Yeah.
He's like a really like sweats himself
hard.
Does he?
Yeah.
The guy in the left is like,
he connects with them like energy,
American Indian,
native American.
He's um,
he's Hawaiian,
half black,
half white.
The guy next to him.
Can he,
can he can give you like that brother
Dick that he would have the hog or the
group?
Like she would have the biggest,
oh he's got a hammer on them for sure.
But who's the Silver Fox on the
one?
Who's this?
The Guy I like.
How old's brace is like,
like as I said,
he's the,
he's kind of like,
that's actually their book or the guy to
his left.
He runs the hooker studio and then
that's a new hoe on the right.
A southern Whoa.
He's
like from Nashville or something.
So the older gentleman,
is he Hawaiian as well?
Yeah,
he's having to brace,
has been doing it the longest.
Um,
he's,
he's been like,
he's been at at like 25,
30 years.
He's just,
he's just been fucking and then got paid
cause he was realizing rob lowe a little
bit,
what it looks like Rob Lowe and his ice
in the eyes.
You definitely shouldn't work for one of
those police.
Okay.
This is what he sounded like.
This guy,
they just,
they just go,
what?
This guy's a good guy.
He's been on our podcast a couple of
times.
Fucking shitting me.
Are you shitting me
on your podcast?
But you had this fucking gun in your
pocket anytime when I was trying to
promote the spreadsheet.
You guys in that but you had a brace on.
We haven't bumped for brazed men who
years ago.
Oh,
okay.
But we haven't had a guest and jeers
birth doesn't have to be about you
buddy.
They are talking about this hooker.
Yeah,
he's a good guy.
I bet he is.
But it isn't it fast
that like a person who does that,
he's is,
he always goes out of his way.
It'd be like,
look dude,
I'm not a fucking $2 meet me in the
alleyway.
Whoa.
And I'm like,
I know,
but it's just fun to call a guy a.
So yeah,
he's kind of accept the fact,
you know what I was thinking that we
were talking about earlier about this a
Rhonda Rousey thing.
Why,
why people are so mean.
And I think there's a certain,
there's always going to be like a
certain backlash from someone who tries
to be extraordinary because it makes us
feel like weak and,
and,
and lazy and comparison and like not as
ambitious.
Like if someone wants to be the best
right at anything,
if someone's true claims,
they're the best.
Whether it's conor mcgregor or whether
it's Ronda Rousey like that,
that felt rushed to make it to number
one scares a lot of us.
Yeah.
Cause it makes you look at what your,
what extent you're willing to go to for
what you want to achieve.
And then it makes you go,
am I actually doing things like
fulfilling my own potential?
That's what those moments do.
And you won't be going to if it goes
wrong,
like way more than you want to punish
anyone else for anything else.
I've gone,
it goes wrong.
So then let's,
let's put this in perspective cause I
just,
by the way,
I've dumped talking about friends of
mine,
I'm not calling people out at all,
but like I saw Kevin Hart today on CNN
and it wasn't about comedy.
He was talking about how his job is now
to inspire people to be better and I was
like,
I was like,
that's odd that I would hear Kevin talk
like that because he is funny as shit
and that's what he's really good at is
being fucking hilarious.
But apparently is like a fist fitness
guru and like he's like a,
he's on a different level now and I
went,
wow,
is that the level where people start to
fucking like what they did with amy or
what the,
you know like,
or what they did with Dane is like you
see a comic get bigger than that and
then all of a sudden like slip up once
and we'll fucking eat your lunch.
For sure.
There's a lot of that and it,
you know,
it's like you want to celebrate the
people that take the risk to climb to
the highest mountains,
but you want a mock them if they meet
they fall,
but it's oftentimes not the same people
that are mocking them like we're all
experiencing.
Like,
obviously I have zero animosity towards
Ronda Rousey and a hundred percent
admiration for what she stands for as a
competitor,
like which she tried to do and what she
accomplished and the coming back thing.
So I don't experience it on the negative
side,
but the on the,
the people that do though,
the people that feel like they have a
free shot to go at,
there's,
there's enough of them that it makes a
difference.
So even if all the same people
appreciate you,
whether you win or lose the perspective
shifts because so many more people that
maybe you wouldn't normally narrowly be
in contact with who are negative are
mocking it and,
and,
and you know,
and really like being like absolutely
vicious about their,
the criticism and the way like trying to
knock you down when you're already down.
It's not just a matter of it being
accurate or funny,
which you're going to always have that
you're going to always have people that,
that crack jokes and make fun.
It's always gonna exist,
but it's,
there's this,
there's this viciousness of attacking
somebody when they're there,
there's some venom and everything.
And that's part of me wonders like I go
is that like cobb never been cool with
self promotion as well as made me feel
comfortable.
But I've seen people in our business
that are very cool with it.
Well,
you know,
Kevin Hart is a master at it,
but he,
he's,
he knows what he's doing and he's a
very,
very smart guy,
very smart guy.
He's very smart on many levels.
But at the,
at the ID I wonder,
I think Kevin would,
I dunno,
Kevin would not say he's,
he's aspiring to be a mogul.
He's aspiring to surpass not just being
an entertainer but,
but to being a culture,
culture,
culture influencer.
And he is,
he already was that hard to say Coleman.
Sure.
Influencer.
But he has me,
it really was about it.
Cool about him.
And now he's on the cover of fast
company and yeah,
I saw that.
I was reading the article and it's just,
um,
it's incredible the amount of things
he's gonna buy a studio,
like a big warehouse,
actually,
uh,
not far from here and wants to produce,
you know,
tv shows,
movies like online content.
All within there,
continue to do movies.
Obviously he has the standup,
he has,
he's an,
you know,
has endorsements from like an athlete.
What all these different skills shooting
APP.
Um,
I think he like just wizard.
Yeah.
It's like,
it's all right
everybody.
I mean,
if you want to be that guy,
you should follow his footsteps.
And by the way,
he's that guy.
That's the other thing about Kevin or at
least that I,
I don't,
I only know him from when we were kid.
Like when we're young starting from that
time.
I don't know him.
I haven't talked to him and
probably probably 10 years that did a b
e t show with him.
Did you?
Yeah,
he's the greatest guy in the world.
Here's The v Wade is fucking guy in the
world.
But he met him once.
He's very nice guy,
but he's a,
he,
I have a funny story about him.
I bought a pair of Jordan's one time at,
uh,
at the mall.
I was going to play basketball and I'd
bought Jordan's.
I didn't like,
I didn't know you didn't play basketball
and Jordans and uh,
they put them on.
No,
no.
That's the big thing in that light life
lesson here.
What are you talking about?
It's this when you're,
when you're black,
you black.
No,
no,
but this is the rule.
You don't win.
The Jordans are not meant for white
guys.
Tommy,
Tommy.
I'm drunk already.
So,
uh,
when you're,
when you're black,
you play basketball,
basketball,
shoes,
like shitty shoes.
But when you're in Jordans are meant for
like going out.
Jordan's wear like nice shoes.
You don't wear them on the basketball
court.
That's the rule.
I didn't know that.
I bought a pair of Jordan's thinking I'd
go play basketball.
They're the best basketball shoes.
That's not the rule.
So when you buy Jordans,
they come into Jordan bag that'll just
come in like a footlocker bag to coming
to Jordan bag.
Kevin Hart was in a mall and he saw me
and my buddy croix walking through the
mall and I had a Jordan bag and Kevin
came up and he grabbed my Jordan bag
from behind my back and he was give to
have Jordans.
And I turned around and all I saw was a
skin color.
I didn't see Kevin.
And I went and I screamed and Kevin's
saw the racism in my eyes.
I'm like,
oh,
Bert.
And I was like,
sorry,
Kevin,
I didn't know it was you.
I thought it was just some black kid.
He was like,
birds,
but use that racism or you'd being
robbed by someone who could probably run
faster than you.
Fuck how has that racism.
But anyway,
uh,
but I wasn't trying to say gimme them.
Jordan Jordan's,
he grabbed the bag and shook it and now
I freaked.
Dude,
I jolted like a shark in the water too.
If that was a Chinese guy,
he'd be shitting your pants.
Yeah.
If somebody else,
if they had been role reversed,
if he had done that to somebody,
there's a good chance that you'd gotten
punched or gone viral on Youtube.
That's a whole lot though.
Definitely punched somebody if they
don't expect it.
Like you know how sometimes you just
catch someone and they're already on
seven and you're like,
hey dude,
how'd you get to 70
let's go out.
Oh sorry man,
my fucking wife just fucking give me a
hug
it out.
And we've all been like,
you know,
have you ever been in a road rage
situation where someone cuts you off and
you just get so much more mad than you
normally would get to know what you
like,
you fucking cunt and you're like it.
Where did this come from?
Like I had to react.
Obviously this person's an idiot.
This is a bad move,
but why?
What is it that gets you to seven so
quickly?
Do you get that lesson where you live
versus Hollywood now?
You can get it everywhere.
When I drive out where you live or where
I live or where Tommy lives,
like this area,
it's a little chiller,
like it's not,
Hollywood is fucking too,
too much,
really aggressive just outside of
Hollywood,
Hollywood adjacent where they can't
quite live in Hollywood,
but they right to it and they worked
there
and they get,
ah,
yeah.
Studio city ish now.
Like Sherman Oaks Ish.
A lot of fucking crazy drivers out
there.
Yeah.
T gritters you've arrived somewhere at a
seven,
like yourself,
you know,
like checking into a hotel.
Yeah,
yeah,
I've done that.
Where I've,
um,
you know,
it's a bunch of shit led to me getting
there and then I have like an exchange
with somebody and then later I'll go
back and be like,
Hey,
I just want to tell you earlier when I
got here I felt like I was,
I'm a little short with you.
And they're like,
oh,
no problem.
You know,
they're always very much downplaying it,
but I'll feel bad about it.
You know,
I had a fight with a,
uh,
with a,
with a car driver that drove me from the
airport in front of my house.
Like not a fist fight,
but a verbal fucking,
because he was late.
He was like 30 minutes late to pick me
up.
And then when he did show up,
he was at the wrong terminal.
And then when he did get me,
he blamed it on me for not telling him
where I was landing.
And I was like,
that's not my job.
And then he got,
when I dropped,
when he dropped me off,
he got mad at me because I didn't speak
to him the whole ride home.
I'd headsets in and I fucking told you,
wait a minute,
he actually said,
he
said,
do you really want to get to know you?
I said to him,
I got out and I go,
I've got a balanced to the man that's
not the best service I've ever had.
And he goes,
well,
it was a little disrespectful.
You're not speaking to me.
And I was like,
what?
I think cause you didn't talk to me the
whole Rod.
That's,
that's disrespectful.
I went,
it's not my fucking job to entertain
you.
I go,
your job is to drive.
Do you think are hard for you to have a
conversation?
But I realized I'm having this fight
with this guy in front of my house.
I don't know anything about him.
And I was like,
and then I was like,
and I have,
by the way,
I was going to tip him in the middle of
like,
he's yelling at you.
And I said,
I had 20 bucks in my hand.
And he goes,
I go,
just so you know,
that wasn't the best experience I've had
or whatever.
And then I had the 20 bucks in my hand
and he was like sort of disrespectful
and then we sort of going back and
forth.
Then I was like,
fuck you,
I'm not giving this to you.
And then in a weird way I went bird give
it to him or he's going to come back and
murder your family.
And so I was like,
all right,
you know what?
Take it where even,
and then I had to come back and go,
I apologize.
I sh I and I,
and this is the weird part about my
brain,
that is what I started this whole
fucking talk about is,
is that I start going,
hey burt,
how important in this fucking spectrum
of life is it that this guy is throat?
How often have you been 30 minutes late?
Helps me to be 30 minutes late and then
maybe got an attitude because you were
defensive.
I don't know.
Maybe this guy was as a cuckold.
That's what I thought about today.
When you were late.
I was at least two minutes late.
I ran here to no fucking avail.
It was close.
I should,
Uber driver dropped me off in front of
[inaudible]
place.
You know what?
I'm mad at me.
I think the reality of people talking to
each other is we it comment exchanges
sometimes and things get started like
right away,
like something goes wrong with him and
he shows up late.
And so your interaction with him has
already unbalanced because you expect
him to be apologetic.
But how could he really apologize?
You know,
you fucked up.
You did.
So now I know who you are.
You're that guy who doesn't take his job
at seriously and you're gonna drive me.
I'm just going to put my headphone sets
in and he's mad at you that you do that.
Like there's a lot of things going on
there,
man.
And maybe if he showed up on time,
the same guy and you would have had a
great old time.
Maybe there was a where he's driving
and my headsets are in and they're
really good noise reduction headsets.
Their molds to your ear.
Maybe he was driving.
He's like,
hey man,
I'm really sorry I'm going through a lot
of shit speech and I just like this,
right?
I mean,
I dunno.
There's a lot of scenarios that could
have happened for sure.
I always got things out of assumptions.
You make assumptions always like,
eh,
but he looked like this and then the way
that he looked,
I know that guy's an asshole.
You don't know what he was like,
are you ready for the difference of what
you look like,
Tommy?
It looks different.
I mean I'm being serious when I say that
from the weight loss.
You look,
you look,
there was a,
there's a assuming this to you like when
I watched your last special mostly
stories mostly.
Is that the way you say supposed to hit
mostly stories like that Kansas City
improv this weekend.
But like there is like a real fucking
coolness to you.
Like a,
like a Carmel Coolness to you.
But now you look like a fucking like,
like,
and so when you meet people,
do you see people perceiving you
differently?
Mm,
not really not.
I mean there's,
so most people that you know would come
to my show are not those people.
Not that I'm talking about a starbucks.
Holy Shit.
Look at the difference in between you
and then hold.
Look at me.
Turn,
turn,
turn straight on.
Shit Tom.
Wow.
Crazy.
Tom fucking neck is bigger.
Your head's bigger.
This is bigger.
Your shoulder face is so much bigger,
so much bigger.
Everything is bigger fingers.
Is your ring looser?
Yes.
Do you feel like God's telling us we
should cheat?
Take it off.
You look good.
Tom and burt run trains on pitches.
Um,
yeah,
pull up police pull up.
Uh,
burt's eventually.
What's it called?
Sometimes I'm not,
I'm only 15 pounds lighter
in that for the special,
the Special Ed.
Shy.
Let's wait for the special.
Do you got,
oh no,
no,
no.
You want to,
you want to see a good one.
Here we go.
Pull up Ari.
Shaffir lying dildos.
You get that one right there.
That's not as good as flying dildos.
Go to flying Delta as this is when I was
off balance.
He's right.
Codeship fears flying dildos.
It's good.
It's on youtube.
Yes,
he is.
It just,
it just posted it today.
Go to a video and you'll see me.
Oh,
this is me.
Just obese.
What about that picture right there?
The one with the pole.
Very big.
Can't you be like,
can't you go full screen?
No it doesn't,
but yeah,
will definitely like,
oh my God.
Look Chinese.
You look a lot fatter.
You look so happy.
And we baked there.
What a beautiful scenery.
So fucked up.
Is that one?
It was Hong Kong suits are he got,
yeah.
What's up?
Beautiful God damn suit.
It's the waffles and the collar and
everything.
I got a couple of there too.
It's like a fun little experience to go
in Hong Kong and Hong Kong.
Yeah.
Wow.
That's the only thing that's changed is
this little fold right here.
Yeah.
I wanted to get rid of that.
They're like,
what?
Wait,
are you,
uh,
probably two 51.
Yeah,
dude,
you,
you look really different.
Well,
you dude,
you still lost 30 fucking pounds.
I mean you're,
you're kind of down on yourself a little
bit in this thing.
That's a giant accomplishment.
You know,
a few people have the willpower to lose
30 pounds like that in that quick of
amount of time.
And that was a Herculean effort.
You guys,
I don't understand.
I don't even even know if you understand
the impact that it has on people.
When someone does that and you see
people do it,
there's so many people out there right
now.
They didn't think that they had the
ability inside them to do it.
Yeah.
But they love you guys and they listen
to your podcast and they hang out with
you guys when you,
you know,
you do shows in their town.
They do.
They come to the show.
They know that you did it.
You just,
you did it and you didn't.
There's nothing like,
I know you're a person.
You did it.
I'm 30 pounds overweight.
I want to lose the weight.
I know burt did it.
I can do it too.
Now.
That's real.
Those are the coolest tweets.
We get a lot of really cool ones where
you go like,
Whoa,
hey man.
I like when they're,
they do it and there's a joke attached
to,
but like they go,
hey man,
this has been the coolest thing I've
ever seen.
Come out.
Bell.
Did you see his tweets come off?
That was like the,
I didn't think this will be as fun as it
is.
This is awesome.
I want to be a part of it.
Yeah.
He wanted to lose some weight.
I thought that was really cool.
Miles was such a fucking great,
I've had them on before.
He's a super nice guy.
Super Smart.
Yeah.
We're talking about doing another one.
That would be great if you wanted to do
that.
Who does he want to do it with?
I don't know.
Got to find a buddy lawrence.
Pick someone you hate.
That's what
it's gotta be.
Someone you love,
so it's good natured and it's fun and
it's encouraging.
You don't,
then people could do it too.
It could become like your own personal
roast battle.
You know there were shots fired back and
forth from between me and Tom.
That was what made it fun though,
man.
We played yesterday.
As a fan,
I would go,
I would have been like,
I like these guys.
This is what I'm fucking talking about.
Yeah.
Years called the Tommy.
Drink your vodka soda.
Just drink.
Hold on.
Ra responded on the end of his podcast.
He released today giving it play.
What?
He says,
I know what he says.
I know what he said.
Just play it.
I think it's better to play.
Let's play.
Talk Shit about them.
Know
that son of a ball.
Tommy drink some fucking bucket for
inviting me over to your place
to my favorite people ever did that took
place and what I didn't.
First of all,
there's no way in my mind I expected to
lose that bet.
One of them to be below a piece was fee.
I can beyond incomprehensible for both
of them.
It was a sure thing for me.
It was a sure thing.
I mean it turns a back of bets like we
do on punch drunk.
This one sporting event,
fucking golden.
I've got it in the bag.
Of course they're not both going to be
under obese and I guess they are.
I my,
I hope.
I'm hoping that that tomorrow they're
going to weigh in and they're going to
be a little bigger and maybe,
maybe Saguaro only be six feet tall if
he's six feet tall.
He's right on the border right now.
It will be so not bs.
It's at six one thing that gets them
under six feet,
he gains about a point and a half on his
BMI.
That's,
that's one of my only hopes that tape
measure.
If he's five [inaudible] 11 then I'm
good.
But it doesn't seem like people are
believing that.
But Segura said he was five 11 and now
I've got these people fucking
threatening me.
Patricia media.
I've got people threatening me and
telling me like,
uh,
the call me Welcher we haven't even had
the to weigh ins yet.
We're supposed to have three ways,
but fine for go.
The first one,
the first,
I'm assuming they did that one at home.
I rogan second,
third,
two days in a row.
They got a charm.
I haven't been efficient.
La Show.
I got people threatening me.
I don't feel safe.
They know what sitting,
they're 11 and then,
and then these are my friends.
My friends are coming at me.
I was like,
all right,
I'll off the off chance.
I lose what?
What?
Oh,
we all go to a dodger game.
That'd be fun.
You lost some weight.
Go.
No,
don't have,
don't have a dodger dog.
Don't have the extra large one.
Each barbecue fucking seven times a
week.
How in the world does he lose 15 pounds
30 how does that happen?
And then I got my friends set me up for
fucking,
they want first class tickets.
So Europe,
I don't know what to do.
I get fucking,
I'm,
I'm a,
I'm flustered.
I'm flustered for sure.
I'm,
I'm afraid
I can't be here with this.
I can't be here with them coming after
me like this.
The heaven even weighed in the second
day,
but it's going to happen.
I know what's going to happen tomorrow.
She'll throw each,
lose a pound
unless it's,
unless Tom's five 11 I mean that's a,
that's a chance.
If Tom's five 11 I got a chance.
That'll mean he'd win the bet for most
loss of weight,
but they wouldn't both be under obese.
So fucking burt would have to
you guys,
you,
you haven't dealt with this kind of like
backlash until you've dealt with it.
You haven't dealt with it.
That guy who killed the lion in Zimbabwe
or Zaire,
one of those places,
Africa
got on him for killing Chutney until you
find out,
oh,
there's 80 80 80 lions get killed every
year.
They've got to keep the population down
and they start killing babies,
human babies.
But nobody cares about that.
So this fucking dentist in Rhode Island
has to face death threats all the time.
You don't know what it's like to get a
fucking he rage against shoe and these
people are coming at me and my phone
calls my texts.
It's,
you know,
first of all,
I can't thread with a flip phone.
So every test comes in new.
They ask questions like,
what does that mean?
I have to delete my texts after awhile
because I have to make room for once.
So you've got some,
Laura's saying,
open up your wallet.
Do you have any fucking won the bet yet?
Football,
European football.
I can't,
I can't do this.
I can't deal with it.
Listen to me.
I'm fucking flustered.
It's very possible that he's,
that he's under height.
Barring that,
I don't know.
I can't be here for this.
I can't,
I can't be here with them coming after
me.
I gotta get Outta here.
Hilarious man.
I gotta get the Fuck Outta here.
And I got to get away from this until I
could figure out what to do.
I got it.
That's what I gotta do.
That's what I gotta I gotta get the fuck
away from this.
Yeah.
That's my answer.
Anybody wants to listen to the rest of
it or all of it?
Just fears.
Skeptic tanks.
One of my favorite podcasts,
I was doing it all the time.
It's awesome.
I recommend the Henry Rollins one,
which,
uh,
burt scoffed at the sky.
Hetero is different than I am.
Extremely dismissive of them.
Fuck off.
And it was insulting.
He's got a gang of them.
Dave Smith is a great one.
No,
no.
The best one.
The best ones running of the bulls.
Oh,
that's a great one to getting great.
One's got a lot of great ones already.
Has a really,
really good podcasts going to run off.
He's gonna run off the map right now for
awhile.
He was just good.
Good,
good.
He needs to,
I mean,
if he thinks he needs to,
he needs to.
And what,
what I love about what Ari's doing is
he's living his life 100% on his terms.
He's not doing it by anybody else's
standards and he does.
He's doing the exact what I think the
best thing at comic can do if you makes
it like once you make it like relax and
just just have fun and be yourself and
only do the things you want to do and
don't let him suck in and nonsense.
But you've been on both sides of that
fence.
Yeah,
for sure.
The fear factor was like post,
I'm talking about post rarely.
Pre family.
Yeah,
that too.
Oh yeah,
that's a different thing.
I mean if he had a family it would be
totally different thing,
but he or even if even considered having
one or even a girlfriend,
it'd be a different thing.
But he's been tied down the past and
right now what Ari's enjoying is like
creating stand up,
doing standup,
doing his podcast and just enjoying life
and enhancing his perspective and taking
it all in.
And these trips that he goes on,
he's,
he's like orchestrating them.
He wants to see things he wants to,
he wants to absorb experiences from
other parts of the world.
And it's all enhancing his standup too,
that it's very,
very accurate.
And I say this as I've said this from my
perspective,
um,
as probably an expert in world travel,
I would tell you our,
he does it better than anybody.
And I'm not even fucking around.
I've done it for seven years straight,
but Ari went to Switzerland and,
and had a different life experience than
I did and went now mine was
under production,
but like,
he really does it great.
I wanted to pitch a show so bad,
uh,
that were,
you know,
Ari's disappearing right now.
I wanted to pitch a show.
Go.
Can I find Ari?
Like,
can I find them?
Well,
you'll be able to find him.
It's social media.
Some time off the grid.
He's going off the fucking green.
Does that mean now he's going to go
where there's,
you know,
he's not bringing any laptop or anything
like that.
And he was disappearing for real.
Other people have phones.
It's true.
They'll say,
oh,
Ari's in Sweden,
Micronesia or some shit.
He's trying to go off path.
Stuff's to get malaria.
The pills.
I told him to take,
dude,
do not take the pills.
Malaria pills.
Cause we've talked about.
I thought I'd fucking,
and then you get the injections though.
I had a horrific experience on do
vaccinations,
vaccinations or just don't take them at
all.
You're probably not gonna get malaria.
Why?
I thought a lot of people get malaria.
No Africa they've talked to about to
about this on your podcast.
I took malaria pills.
I was puking.
I was younger.
That charts for awhile.
My friend Justin Wren got malaria three
times though.
Three times.
Fuck.
Malarial the Dang gay fevers.
One you don't want to get well,
malaria has killed half the people that
have ever lived.
He got the topic.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
In the book or half the people that have
ever died,
half the people that have ever died have
died from malaria.
You have it.
That's where before they had malaria.
But they don't take them though.
Do you understand the posture?
Snus
light that up one more time,
Tommy.
Let's get,
let's see how fucked up we can get.
Come on.
And Tommy,
come on.
Pretend you're big galleries texting,
tenure,
big Tommy,
just trooper happy that is rich friend
decided to step in and flip the bill.
Yeah.
Fuck yeah.
Hey Joe,
did you ever hear the ballot of Big
Tommy bonds?
That's pretty fun.
The song I wrote,
I'm not gonna let you play it here,
but like I wrote a song about Tom and
that was the greatest part of this whole
thing is I really had a song.
Oh yeah,
the ballot and played and sang.
I wrote,
played and sang a song called the ballad
of big tummy buns.
Oh,
how dare you.
And I was,
but my,
the one cool thing about this,
and this is esoteric.
Well,
I might as well hear this.
I don't think I've ever said anything.
It's esoteric,
but please continue.
You never said it way before you had to
join.
I'd never said this is esoteric.
This is so fucking high.
I think I exactly know what esoteric
meats.
I don't either,
Joe,
but it sounds good in a sentence.
Like,
what did it give me the exact definition
of esoteric.
Yeah.
Pull that up.
Okay.
What do you think esoteric mean?
It's a out there.
Yeah,
right.
Bizarre.
What would it,
what does it mean here?
Intended or likely to be understood by a
small number of people with specialized
knowledge?
This is esoteric.
So this one I'm about to say is that
Sotera intended or likely to be
understood by only a small number of
people with a specialized knowledge or
interest or an enlightened inner circle.
Joe Rogan.
This is esoteric when I'm about to say,
and you will get this more than anyone.
That's a lot of pressure
to hit that and then listen,
I think you'll get it.
Do you know how sometimes when you work
for a corporation and your paycheck is
dependent on that corporations approval?
Not right now.
I'm in the middle of an esoteric
statement.
Yes.
Okay.
And so,
and then you get out from under that
corporation and all of a sudden you are
the one that kind of,
uh,
you get,
you almost like feel your creativity
again.
You like,
you go like,
oh fuck,
I forgot.
I'm a really great standup.
I forgot that I'm passionate about
making video.
Like,
you know,
and you go,
oh,
I can be my own voice.
I have,
it's my own ship now.
I forgot that when I started this
business,
uh,
the goal wasn't to get under the
umbrella.
The goal was to be out there in the
fucking ocean by myself in sailing my
own ship and saying,
go take a left.
Fuck it.
Right.
Um,
this weight loss battle coincided with
my decision to stop being under contract
for travel channel.
And I was,
I was really lost.
And I was like,
I didn't know where I'd wear.
I didn't know if I should just take
another television deal and it,
or just do another deal with trial.
I didn't know what to do.
I really didn't know what to do.
And,
uh,
this weight loss battle happened around
that time and it,
and it,
and like bill burst says poetically.
I started taking on water and I felt
fucking crazy about it.
And then one morning I woke up and I
went,
oh tom is having a lot of fun with this.
Like he's having fun him and push her
having a lot of fun and I was like,
I'm going to write a song and I wrote a
song and I wrote this stupid song.
I thought I looked,
I was like,
I was,
but it was like I felt very creative and
I didn't feel like there was any
parameters on me anymore and I was like,
oh,
this is what my career is about.
My career is about doing everything I
like and everything I like and if you'd
like what I like,
come see me to stand up.
But if you don't like what I liked,
like fuck it,
this is what I like to do.
This is my,
this is my walk,
this is my walk through the woods.
And it was like,
and I know that,
I don't think Tommy can attest to that
as much as you can because being under a
fear factor,
I don't think you ever were like under
anyone's control,
but there's definitely a,
a corporate umbrella that you're under
where you're like,
oh,
I can't show,
hey,
you know,
how long did I not smoke pot on camera
again?
You know,
like long time.
Yeah.
And so as soon as that fucking happened,
all that happened,
I wrote that song and it was like,
it's one of those moments where you're
just like,
oh,
I get to do whatever the fuck I want to
do anymore.
Like I'm just a dude that likes for
comedy the same way our he is where he
goes,
I'm getting off the grid.
That freedom,
that freedom man being untethered.
Ari and I had a long podcast about being
untethered.
Being untethered is so cool.
As an artist,
you just get to do what you want to do.
You know?
It's why we love.
That's why we probably love guys like
Ron White,
Jim Jefferies,
these guys that are,
that are bill burr there just
untethered.
No,
sorry.
I get inspired by the way,
are he's living.
I really do.
I really,
I,
it's,
it gives me enthusiasm.
He's having fun.
These creatings doing stand up.
He's just,
he's making rational choices regardless
of like how much money it'll cost him.
And he's like,
this is what I want to do for my art.
This is what I want to do for my
standup.
I'm taking time off.
I'm just going to go and experience life
in.
Right.
And you know,
people are like,
what?
What are you doing?
Where are you going?
And he's like,
what I'm doing just stop.
I know what I'm stop.
He knows what he's doing and he's knows
what he's doing.
It's like for me,
having known him since he was an open
miker yeah,
there's a lot.
You've really seen it.
You've known him.
You've known him in a way that I don't
know him.
Like he,
when we were talking about you one time
in front of his apartment,
those are the best,
you know,
that we've had them too.
When you go to take someone home and you
drop him off front of their house,
but you sit and talk for 10 more
minutes,
you got one with bill burr that I,
I wish I had great.
But Ari dropped me off and he was like,
oh,
we're talking about,
we were just talking about intimacy
levels.
Like,
this is gonna sound silly and I'm not
going to call Ari galper.
I'll say,
this is what we're talking about.
We were talking about like how much we
were talking about you and then,
uh,
and I said something like,
well,
I texted him yesterday,
I feel bad.
Texted him again.
And he goes,
oh,
I don't want to text them too much
either.
And I said,
yeah,
but he's our friend.
We should be able to text them the way
we text each other.
And he goes,
I know,
but I don't want to like,
I don't want to bother him.
And I go,
yeah,
but he'd do it to us and went and we
were like,
yeah,
we're having this really kind of crazy
conversation.
And I realized Ari and I are like the,
the,
those moments in life are like so
precious.
But the F I don't know where the fuck
this story was going.
How come you guys are secured?
Text me.
We're just going to text like bill.
I do at the same bill.
The tax bill.
Yeah.
I'm scared of follow up.
Like I text bill,
I'll text him right now.
I'll text him right now and either he
replies and like a day and a day.
No,
no,
there's got the,
this is going to sound Tommy back me up
please.
Back up on I will.
But like,
but like,
like I text bill,
hey man,
you know,
are we doing this thing on Monday?
And then he doesn't get,
I don't get her piling up.
I'm not gonna fuck her mother room.
I did this because I know he's got a lot
of shit going on.
And I go and I,
and I,
I have shit going on too.
But trust me,
it like,
and you guys know like if you are you or
are your joey or bill or any of you guys
texted me,
these are my first reply.
Like yeah,
go.
Oh Yup.
Right on it.
Like you can see my bubble come up in
the bottom
before you're done typing.
Yeah.
It's a weird requirement,
right?
Like there's times where in more so
lately than ever that I've been just
putting my phone and like I'll put it in
the other room and I just leave it alone
for hours.
Yeah.
I think that that's,
that's not a bad thing to do,
man.
You know,
like everybody checks their phone during
podcasts and everybody checks their
phone during the movies.
How much?
Yeah.
Well,
I mean we should do,
we should do it at one.
Oh,
you don't wanna turn that beard yet.
We're going to do it.
You want to do it now?
You want to do it on the air,
I think.
Yeah.
No,
we're definitely doing it on the air.
Okay.
Do you want to trim his beard?
Definitely.
Yeah.
Okay.
But you got to sit sidesaddle on me.
That's the only gonna to take about 10
15 minutes.
So we'll wait til the end.
We'll wrap it up.
Wrap it up.
Yeah,
keep people here.
Tell you,
I'm wrapping up my daughters.
Did you see the videos my daughters did
on instagram?
No.
I go,
I said something.
uh,
hey,
give me a kiss on the cheek.
I wouldn't kiss me on the cheek.
She was just fucking mad dog me.
I'm like,
well,
I to give me a kiss on the cheek does
last cheek.
You might get a kiss of the beard.
And she goes,
it gives it to me.
She goes,
oh,
it's wet.
And then Georgia comes in and then goes
kiss on the cheek.
And then I go,
do you guys think I'm going to win
today?
And they went,
nope.
So you serious?
And they said,
nope.
And I was like,
are you ready guys ready to see me
without a beard?
And they're like,
nope.
They saw
it.
They pull out all wet at my wedding
album,
me and Leanne and started looking
through pictures and they're like,
oh,
we've got to get used to it.
You've got to give us some time.
Wow.
That's so weird.
You're,
you're defined by your facial hair in a
weird way of do you want to keep it?
No.
You let them keep no,
no.
Let him keep it.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I really,
well,
you got to let them off the hook.
Oh,
a hundred percent hold on.
I can't do that.
I'm not a wheelchair.
It's not watching.
If the guy lets you off the hook,
that would let you off doug,
if you want to keep it.
No,
I can't.
I,
I can't never mind by the way.
By the way.
It was definitely,
this is in Russia.
In Russia.
Where does it get this picture?
Is this one,
this machine thread?
This is,
this is in Russia.
Look,
I'm wearing an ato shirt.
Oh my God.
It's like the second picture that pops
up.
Are you fucking serious?
You're pushing the stomach out.
It's so small then.
Dude.
You're tiny.
You look like you weigh about two 10 by
the way,
Joe.
What am I rocking?
Lower that lower that Jamie.
Lower that a fucking fanny pack power.
All you motherfuckers that have seen me
do stand up and I said when I met Igor
and his door,
I was wearing a purple kelty fanny pack.
That's the fucking panty fanny pack.
And it's the small details that make a
story and that's a fucking bolts good in
my pocket.
It's not cool.
It's a what?
A Baltika.
That's their local beer in St
Petersburg.
Beard.
Your body.
Yeah,
that's,
is that purple or is that like a bluish
purple Kelsey fanny pack.
That was the best.
If I could go back,
if I could find that fanny pack,
I'd wear it everyday of my life.
It was the best fanny pack of her head.
Cause the way they made it was that it,
the top part was flat.
You know,
it's what went out like a solid three
inches.
So you rest your beer on that?
No,
no,
no.
So that when you opened it,
you were looking at like a portfolio of
your stuff.
It wasn't slid in like another pocket.
Ooh,
that was the great,
if anyone can find me that purple kelty
fanny pack.
See if,
see if a young Jamie,
how do you get a minor?
Hmm.
Okay.
Yo,
you savage [inaudible] you can find all
the pictures of the Russian mafia.
What is this from?
Is this like an article about your last
show time special for a New York Post
from a long time.
Oh,
so powerful.
That was when my book came out,
by the way,
by the way.
You want to hear what a dummy I am.
I posed for that picture having no clue.
It was the fucking cover van wilder.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
I had no fucking clue.
Yeah.
He was like,
and I was like,
so they asked you to dress like that and
you didn't know why they brought the
shit.
Did a photo shoot [inaudible] I had no
fucking clue.
That's weird.
Yeah.
Does he do the tongue party?
Did you ever see Van Wilder?
You ever see it?
No.
Uh,
I don't remember.
I really don't remember.
I may have you say hard to tell.
What's that?
You look up whether or not I've seen it
and it's one of those movies like,
hmm.
I've never seen it.
I watched a Christmas vacation the other
day,
so dude,
yeah.
That is a God damn funny movie still
shitters full.
That's a good movie,
man.
It's a great fucking movie.
Yeah.
I mean it is a great movie,
but they may be saying it.
I'm like,
it's like I really enjoyed it.
Would you like that one more time?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
Come on Tommy,
drink finish at [inaudible].
Tommy,
come on.
Bird going,
dee.
I love this feeling.
This could be an I.
If,
if,
if I,
yeah,
I um,
uh,
I've never seen been a wilder and I took
a meeting with their production company.
They brought me in to,
uh,
to do a sitcom and they're like,
do you know they had my book in front of
me and they go,
do you know who I am?
We are on when I was like,
no.
And like we produce van wilder,
big fan of your work,
wanting to do a sitcom.
And I was like,
okay,
and then I'll give you ever seen it?
And they're like,
no,
and this is what they said.
They said,
well,
we should get Ryan Reynolds to come on
your podcasts and watch it live with
you.
I was like,
Shit,
because it's his production company.
He's black horse.
I think production companies on that,
that taste like barbecue.
Is it why that last hit tasted like no.
Joe,
Tommy,
he's yours now.
Tommy's years.
Tommy,
it's yours.
Do you need me to hold you down until
you,
Tommy's good.
I'm totally reasonable.
And his approach.
Could we just cut off a fucking bender
bro?
You feel,
do you feel like you can release the
hounds now and dive back into the fold
with a vengeance simply with drugs and
alcohol for a little bit.
Yeah,
but like,
but not enough food.
I,
you know,
it's really crazy.
Is that,
um,
uh,
I had,
I don't know.
I'm sure you felt it too,
cause I watched you eat it.
But like the second pizza pizza didn't
work well with me.
Like my body was,
it was up in my throat and I was like,
Ooh.
And I was like,
I was too,
it's too much of everything at one time.
Did you feel the same way?
Um,
I,
yeah,
I don't feel good.
I watched you.
I watched it cause you,
cause you had to have the pizza.
Yeah.
But the vodcast flowing.
I have a business meeting I'm going to
do great.
You're going,
wait,
you're going to a meeting.
I got a business meeting at four.
Oh,
that's plenty of time.
My only be slightly buzzed.
I used to hear stories about chappelle
going into auditions.
Highest Fuck.
I wish I had that confidence.
You know,
part of me goes,
that's why he's so successful as he
didn't give a fuck.
Yeah.
Oh for sure.
Well Dave is another example of a guy
just does things the way he wants to do
them and he knows,
he,
he realized after a while,
I guess when you're a guy like him or a
guy like Ari that it doesn't benefit you
to have people influence you and tell
you what to do.
Just doesn't.
And all three of us are,
uh,
a great example of that.
Like,
the best stuff I think that we've done
is stuff that we've done online where
you just,
you're yourself.
Yeah.
You know,
like your podcast with your wife,
that that podcast is you guys being
super fucking silly together like you
always are.
And there's all this jeans,
mommy talk and it's fucking great.
And Dan would have never happened if
somebody,
you know,
had the reigns to it.
If there was a bunch of people that were
executive producers and comedy central
had like 10 people behind the scenes
getting this Jean's comment,
what's high and tight?
What's high and tight and what do you
mean when you're glassing?
When there's no reason for you to do it
other than it's funny to you.
That's it.
That's the only I tried to tell
people I get,
I'm sure you get asked a lot.
I get like
tons of emails.
Don't you get them from people go,
how should,
what should I do to start?
Oh yeah.
That's hilarious.
Did you ever do that?
[inaudible] told me one time.
Did you ever remember you're developing
a sitcom?
Yeah.
Did that ever happen or did it go away?
It went away.
Oh,
can you please tell everyone what the
premise was?
Uh,
I'm walking through Walmart and like
fucking Richmond,
Virginia and Tom Calls me,
we're talking about sit,
calm,
talk,
and he goes,
yeah,
I'm developing like real serious.
Really?
What's your character?
And he goes,
me,
I'm a doctor.
You're a doctor.
He goes,
yeah,
fuck it.
Lots of it.
I go,
you don't look like a doctor goes,
yeah,
I know.
But there was a twist to it
after they graduated last in medicine.
So he's like essentially a dumb doctor
Tom going scalpel.
Not how it went.
I,
the idea of being a doctor was the best
prep is I've ever heard of a sitcom
ever.
My fucking last doctor.
I could be a straight comedy,
but the look on your face,
you don't know what's going on over.
I don't think I've ever,
how long did I laugh on the phone?
Really long and really hard to where I
was like,
I didn't know what I'd done.
Yeah.
Oh,
you've probably made me laugh harder
than anyone person that I know.
Really.
100% I do feel like everything has to be
a contest.
Well,
I feel,
yeah,
I feel like number one,
you know,
when we do even the burt stuff,
we do it to make you laugh.
I feel like there's a part of me that
wants to make you laugh all the time.
Seriously.
There's parts,
I wish I could share them on this
podcast,
but there's times times the,
my favorite parts of Tom is when he is
like,
he's like this,
this the side liner that says the thing
like,
or is affected by something like a,
the only one I can think of it as a
very,
a very applicable as
we and Tom did,
uh,
did when I shaved his tits,
we were in Honolulu doing Pearl Harbor.
And uh,
the two things,
the two things they said to us that were
recollect,
we're like,
we remember don't make fun of the
Hawaiian people and if it's brown and it
moves,
kill it.
Yeah.
That was what they said.
These are the,
if it's Brown and moves,
kill it and don't make fun of the wine
people.
So Tom goes up,
his first joke was,
hey man,
I life here is slow.
That's what they told me.
I didn't know they were talking about
the Hawaiians metabolisms.
Holy Shit.
Fucking huge laugh.
But immediately it's
off the like,
it's not,
you're not allowed to say that gets
done.
A set kills comes back to me.
Russell Peters goes on stage and you can
hear the murmur in the crop and Tom does
dislike snidely wit lash,
like giggling and he goes,
he's pretty,
he's thinking about killing and Russell
Peters does it set mediocre?
I would say at best and rustled murders
but,
but it's because he's Brown.
And at that time they're saying it,
but Brad has been brown and they moved
kill it.
It's true.
And then we had the number,
the,
the show organizer was like,
you guys fucked this up bad.
You remember?
Oh yes.
And then he was like,
he was like,
I told you not to fucking make fun of
the local people.
I told you not to.
I tell you to pg 13.
You know what that means.
I was not pg 13.
Uh,
I told you,
he's like,
there's children and there's wives of
admirals here.
It the rundown of like how we had
fucked,
don't know everything.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Russell Peters is the coolest fucking
guy to his testament.
He like,
he was like,
whatever,
and just let people get to fuck.
Russell have a fuck in his gas tank.
That's also completely empty.
He really,
he does whatever he wants for sure.
Yeah,
he's awesome.
He's the best I would be.
I would be like,
I need to have some Fox in my gas tank.
Do you remember,
you don't think you've been connected to
this idea that you need to for so long?
If I didn't have fucks with my gas,
I got
Gibson,
Mel Gibson and his fucking Melbourne
house to a fucking fucking pop round
plate.
Do you remember the girl that was on the
tour of Pearl Harbor that wasn't like
with us necessarily?
You're talking about?
Yeah,
and so we were talking about Debra Lee.
Yeah.
Russell Peters was dating the dumbest
human being I've ever met.
Mike Russell,
I'll call him right now.
He knows.
Definitely not.
He knows it that he,
no,
he knows that.
And we've talked to me and Russel talked
about this,
all my podcasts,
so it's fine.
Trust me.
Okay.
First thing before we even go on the
tour,
I,
she had a russell in front of,
it's just me,
Tommy and push leann and me and Russell
and kimberly,
kimberly and I say,
and then Russell's brother Clayton,
who might be my favorite human being in
the world comes down.
So I'm,
I love his brother comes in and sits
down and I go,
oh,
hey,
have you guys ever seen that Indian porn
star?
I don't know.
What's her name,
what's her name?
And all of a sudden everyone's faces
shot.
And she's like,
are you talking about Syria?
They,
it was a shot.
And then you're like,
she's so fucking hot.
She's the whole fucking hall kept
talking about how great this one,
I've never been attracted to anyone.
And this is the one that switched my
button.
And Russell and Clayton are going like
this.
Like they're laughing so hard.
And then she goes,
he dated her and Sierra Leone is her
name that you're right.
Yeah.
And then,
then the next day we went on the cruise,
the Pearl Harbor.
Go ahead.
Tom were on this cruise and it's a very
kind of somber and serious and then he
goes in right now he's giving us the
tourist and Admiral Rear Admiral and
he's like,
we're on the approach here of where I
guess it's the Arizona,
isn't that right?
That's underneath.
Yeah.
And um,
and he goes,
the Arizona is up here on the right and
then Denver Legos.
Are we going to go under
and um,
we're in an open boat.
Like on the
tour.
It's a boat.
Yeah.
It's just about like where are,
you can see the sky and stuff.
He thought it might turn into a
submarine.
Yes.
That,
that just like an open air marine.
Like we were just going to get under
right now.
Right.
I'm going to press the button.
And then by the way,
the best group of people to witness that
statement with his Russell Peters is has
his arm around her and he,
you watch his eyes go like leave it off.
And then comedy push are sitting right
next to her and pushes,
like stomping her feet going,
Ooh,
she's serious.
And then Tom's going,
imagine someone thinking that technology
has reached a point where you could,
uh,
be in a boat and all of sudden they
press a button on the roof,
comes over this boat and you dive
underwater.
Look out the window.
Now the window that far off that you
think you're on a submarine because
they're all boats or submarines,
right?
Yeah,
they all go.
Why wouldn't you just go under the water
if you could?
By the way,
it was her first boat ever to get in the
fucking submarine.
How about,
can you been to one?
No.
Oh,
dude and Disneyland.
Hanoch there's such close quarters.
Fucking oh man.
Tell it.
Talk to me,
Dude.
First of all,
Susie,
close the door.
What did you do?
Where was it went down?
Uh,
109?
No.
Oh,
not too far,
but must have been a hundred feet.
Hawaii went down.
What was it for?
I was just floating in submarine for TV.
You're getting the submarine.
The submarine.
Was it?
Uh,
I don't know man.
I'm,
I'm not good at details.
So it was like a submarine.
Yeah.
You get more submarines.
No,
I'm sure it was touristy.
Like Oh really?
Yeah.
But once you get in,
it was in a boat that turned into it or
was it just a submarine?
Wow.
Holy Shit.
But getting in there is very
claustrophobic.
Same high.
I'd imagine being into a like an f 14 or
something.
It'd be claustrophobic.
Same Shit.
And uh,
you started going down and then you
realize like,
oh fuck,
if something goes wrong,
everyone dies immediately.
Okay.
There's no,
there's no like,
there's no like exits.
There's no,
they don't give you a speech at the
beginning and they just go,
everyone sit down.
Let's hope we do this.
You know,
it would be the craziest community in
the world.
What if you could build an underwater
under ocean city?
They got one.
I think like,
uh,
like a submarine city where you
literally build it into like you take a
train through the ocean.
Yeah.
To the center of the ocean where you
have a city where you know you can't
survive if anything goes wrong and you
all live in this little thing where you
have to keep that train path though.
But because that's where the food and
air comes from.
That's the only way other than that here
in the denial,
supercharged life would be nice people
and be be freaking out.
It's true as a genius fucking idea
sitting in the ocean thinking about the
fact that at any moment this could fuck
ups with this constant checks on all of
the tolerances of all the joints of the
ball for glass.
I love the Shin and you're just sitting
there just being nice to each other,
having Martinis,
Hey,
hi,
I'm going to go to sleep.
You think you could sleep?
I don't know.
What about you every day he's like that.
No,
and there's always enough air.
There's always enough fair and there's
always enough food as long as you keep
that train open.
But if anybody's unhappy,
they just put a suicide vest on and go
running in the middle of that fucking
train.
Oh,
that would happen.
How quickly the people,
how long would it last?
No,
no,
no dues was close off the blockage.
Big guys like fucking do.
We're just close off the boxes and go.
All right,
there's a tariff being paid.
That's how it works.
Yeah.
Yeah Dude,
I did.
Is it,
but would that work today?
Would that word today?
Cause it used to work but it used to
work without communication.
I think the kind of communication that
everybody has today with a smart phone,
you know,
I don't know if it would work the same
way.
I don't think you'd be able to do that
the way you can a hundred years ago or
200 years ago.
You would have to have like a super
supportive community.
There's yelling and everybody would have
to be like treated equally.
Otherwise,
if there's any disparity whatsoever.
Also wanted to have to do is pluck and
point a gun at the wall and it would,
it wouldn't last.
Yes,
I'm
you.
I mean,
you wouldn't be,
I saw that.
I saw it in my,
in my imagination.
Some guys,
when you can see a joke over and over
your head,
you go,
oh,
I saw a guy with a wife beater on and a
fucking Clint Eastwood Magnum put it on
a wall.
The joke I saw my head,
it could never get out,
is we were on Catalina one night.
We're moved my sisters and we're all
smoking pot.
And they said,
and there's buffalo that roam around
there.
And so I said,
why is there a buffalo here?
And then my buddy Chris Gillen goes,
oh,
uh,
back in the 30s,
the 20s,
the owner of the cubs owned them own
this island.
So he used to have spring training out
here.
So he brought the buffalo out and my
sister goes for a scrimmage and I saw
the owner coming out in a seer sucker
shoots seeing buffalo on one side and
the cubs working out.
He goes,
yeah,
I met the fucking deem like,
and I could not stop laughing at that
image of him going out like with a cigar
like,
but like when you can visualize it and
to the best,
oh,
hilarious.
Tommy,
let's kill this vodka.
Come on,
You're going,
oh,
I'm going hard for Tommy.
Congratulations Buddy.
Thanks.
Listen,
listen.
I gotta be honest with you.
I,
I feel personally,
I can't enter a bet.
No,
I didn't go home.
I didn't go soft today.
Now I went hard today I went really hard
on the treadmill and go hard and not to
shave your beard.
Yeah.
Really?
I mean it's here.
It's like,
I was like,
that's the moment.
That's the moment.
I Dunno.
I can't leave here without a beard.
I feel very guilty.
I feel like,
I feel like everyone that tuned in,
everyone that watched goes like,
goes like a man doesn't really matter to
me.
But then part of me goes,
I don't know.
I'll leave it up to you guys.
Oh,
you're switching that now?
No,
no,
no.
I'm putting in your hands.
I don't you mean that you're not own it.
You're not saying no.
You can share my beard.
I don't give a fuck.
No,
but you just said I'm putting it in your
hands now and that and then like I feel
guilty.
I,
my,
my boss,
my book is,
I got to shave this beard in your book.
But I'm saying cause I would've said I
would've definitely shape yours.
Okay.
I wouldn't,
I wouldn't have let you out.
Okay.
Tommy,
how do you feel about this?
No,
it's just interesting that he just had
a,
it feels like a change of the way he
feels about it all together because
about an hour ago,
what did I say?
Oh,
you don't even remember
how fucked up our,
we thank you for saying,
I mean I'm loading.
I'm Tommy,
let's kill this drink.
Let's just get a big sip.
Come home.
You're the only one that's fucked up.
Tommy is not,
oh yeah,
I forgot.
Come on man.
We're on a wait a minute.
But you,
you,
you know about the extreme change that
just happened,
right?
I don't know.
Well,
there's a little bit of hedging,
hedging going on.
I told you a while ago that you would
let me keep my beard.
I said,
if you want and you go,
oh,
absolutely not.
I think I'm definitely losing it.
But then now you brought it up as if to
say,
I won't decide.
You decide.
No,
no,
no doubts about that.
What if we give you one of them crazy Fu
Manchu type motherfuckers all the way
down to the jowls.
We'll still get rid of the beard.
Well,
let's give you some crazy.
I thought it was Hitler.
We talked about that.
No,
no,
no.
Let's get
loose dash.
Let's give him some Wyatt earp type
shit.
What about like a Puerto Rican beard?
I'm real thin.
Real thin.
That would almost be worse than shaving
it all off.
Far Worse.
Viewing that on the way she gave you a
prince.
I bet this kid,
this kid Carter,
we have read a season ramps tickets with
Carter Carter,
Carter,
Carter grooves.
I should say.
It's 510 he's kid I was talking about
hangovers with the other day.
Okay.
So he bet me some stupid fucking bet.
And it was like if he,
if,
if he won,
I had to give him 200 bucks,
but if I want I get to cut his hair.
And so he was like,
oh,
I'll take it done.
Cause he thought he was gonna was about,
I think it's the Rams Seattle game and I
won.
And so I got to cut his hair and I was
like,
I'm fucking your hair up and this is
part of Man Shit.
He's 10 years old.
So I immediately,
I cut it to like fucking dumb and dumber
bangs,
right?
Everyone starts laughing and his dad
starts going,
you look like simple Jack.
But then in a weird way he changes,
like he goes,
he starts getting embarrassed and then
the mom start coming in.
This is all boys out right now.
And then the mom said,
hey,
don't worry.
It looks good.
And I go,
that's not the fucking bet.
The bet isn't it?
It looks good.
The bed is,
it looks horrible.
That's why I didn't cut his hair.
I'm not going to cut his hair to give
them a free haircut,
but then as the part of the human part
of me goes,
I'm not going to fuck up a kid.
I don't want to fucking burn him at 10 I
want to do the Puerto Rican beard.
I'm going to fuck you.
Shave it off
breads.
Tiles is here.
Beards.
Is that what that says?
Here's Macomeda beard when I do comedy
or this year.
Beard.
Shit's funny.
Oh,
fucking poor guy.
the prince is beautiful and that's what
people just listening have no idea why
we were laughing.
This is fucking,
if you google,
what is the,
give me the black and white one.
Jamie.
That profile one.
It's from the cover of what happened.
W A T.
Ah,
it's bad.
Super sculpted and it's got like this
like almost like a race track curve to
it.
It's really weird.
It's the weirdest foot run the show.
But can we do like Puerto Rican Guy
Beard?
It's just a line Puerto Rican guy.
Beard.
Yeah.
He must hurt it said Puerto Rican facial
hair.
You're getting that.
This is my new favorite thing.
Google black being black
talkies.
It's a tiger.
He has a tiger print,
print beer.
It's very thin.
Oh my God.
It's golden.
Blacks is amazing.
Yeah.
This dude has his hair bleached blonde
and died in the shape of leopards.
Get on his beard.
That was the closest I came to blacking
out.
I was laughing so hard I couldn't
breathe.
Is that the guy bring backstreet boys
that like might've been the hardest.
That's pretty close,
but I want to give you that moment.
Even the hardest physically have ever
laid.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
MTV Tattoo on his neck.
That is bonus.
Who is that?
He was in the backseat.
That guy.
That guy riff raff was really good on
hot wings.
Did you see that Jamie?
He was a hotlink is a show where they
eat wings.
Played on that.
Did it right on it.
Joey Diaz is coming up on it.
Thank you.
Do you want to do it?
Yeah,
I would do it.
Yeah.
The,
okay.
I'll just talk to sean.
Sean Evans is the guy that does it,
so you just go on to get fucked up by
hot wings like an interview.
Yeah,
they ask you some questions
progressively more interesting question.
It's one of the questions to ask me.
The hottest wing was,
have you ever talked shit about comics?
And I was so fucking out of it.
I was like,
yeah,
I talked shit about Tj Miller and Pete
Holmes
and they were like,
really?
And I was like,
yeah,
I think I shit on crystal Leah,
but I didn't mean to.
And he's just like,
he's sweating,
you're sweating.
And they're like,
really?
And I was like,
yeah,
next question ma'am.
Your body goes into like,
it's a really great show.
Jodie is coming up.
So how much worse is dehydrating then?
Eating the hot wings for me are a little
bit euphoric.
I get it.
I get into a place where I,
I,
my brain shuts down and you start
becoming primal about it and I fucking
love it.
You started posting,
what do you mean really?
You're the reason I put book
Jalapenos with every meal and Jalapenos
is one thing though.
But I consider Jalapenos to be fairly
mild.
Dude.
Honestly,
like there's,
there's some stuff that I,
these to be a place in Burbank,
not in Burbank and Cno called Chili my
soul.
Did you ever go there?
No,
no baby.
I did.
Ari and I've talked about it.
We,
it's one of those things we over,
it's always made plans to go there but
we didn't go and then by the time we
wanted to go,
the guy had died and it was a specialty
Chili shop where they only sold Chili
and they sold extreme temperature.
Chile like insanity Chile where you
would have like a very mild Chili,
which is really enjoyable,
a little spicy.
And there was a whole taste grid from
like one to 10 and I had tried like a
seven and it was insane how hot it was.
And they would give you these little
scoops like uh,
like uh,
you know like if you would get like a
personal size little paper Cup and you
pump the fucking ketchup in it at the
Burger shop,
you know those little paper Cup things,
they give you one of those with the
Chili and a tiny baby spoon and you put
it in your mouth and the fucking
temperature from like a nine would make
you immediately start hiccuping.
Snot flying out of your nose.
I mean flying.
But imagine if Bri yet,
imagine people talking to you during
that and you having to answer questions.
That's why the show is brilliant is
cause it that you are the most
vulnerable and you're like,
I dunno.
Fuck man,
whatever.
It's so good.
Why don't you do it?
Fuck that.
Come on.
No Man.
Great on Joe.
I,
I'd rather know you don't want,
sure.
You don't want to go to Paris with this.
Definitely don't want to go to Paris
with you definitely know what if we
change the location of Paris where you
want to go?
That's what I'm saying.
Toronto and we'll get a cabin for a
weekend.
Go hunting something weird.
No,
no.
Go hunting.
I've always wanted to kill someone for
real.
Yeah,
Dude.
I've talked to Bailey for the,
I want to know the,
uh,
crime more than the time traveler's
wife.
But yeah,
I think I would like when you talk,
I heard the podcast where you talked
about this kill.
No,
probably more like that one.
That was the first one.
No,
no,
no.
It's the one that didn't have the scruff
off his hair.
Oh,
but that one died like that.
Yeah.
But no,
but no,
it's not that,
but it was that he didn't have the
scruff of his hair yet.
Really upset.
Scuff off his hair.
They grow new antlers every year.
I know,
but regardless,
I heard that as a Newbie,
I heard you guys talk about it like it
was like a baby and my baby and I got
really emotional.
I was like,
oh.
oh no.
That's a big ass dear.
Yeah.
I didn't know they grew them new every
year.
I actually brought that up a lot.
Most giant of giant deer.
They,
their antlers fall off every year.
Even if it's like a nine year old deer.
What's like an impossibly old deer?
Every year their antlers fall off and
those antlers are actually bone,
which is really crazy.
I dude,
I didn't know until it really recently
decided to all these facts to random
people.
They grow new bone every year and then
it falls off and they grow that stuff in
their head just so that they can fight
to the death over pussy.
That's real.
That's really why they grow it.
They,
they kill each other all the time.
We stumbled across a,
an elk that had been killed.
My Friend Cam stumble across one this
year and another friend of Mine,
a stumble across one last year in
California.
They had been killed by another one.
They just stab each other in the body
and like puncture each other's lungs and
Shaman.
They go to war.
I'm a fuck now.
That's what then that's exactly what
happened.
That's why they grow those things.
Tom is one of the biggest ones always
dominate because they can stab you from
a further distance.
Like it's a benefit of having these
gigantic summary Norman,
so what's the benefit?
What's the benefit of,
of like when people go,
I've got a 10 point dear.
Does that mean,
is that late in the season?
No,
no,
no.
It means it's an old,
mature,
smart,
dominant male that's probably been
dominating the area.
If you get a big deer with a lot of
Antler,
those are the ones that have the bigger
deers and those are the ones that are
most dominant in terms of like spreading
their genes.
Yeah.
Let's go hunting.
Tom,
let's go on.
A lot of times the,
the,
the idea behind the conservation angle
is that if you hunt an animal like that,
you're hunting an animal that's already
long spread its genetics,
so it's,
there's no danger of losing its
genetics.
Its genetics have been spread and it's
actually better for the biodiversity of
the environment.
If you let the younger bucks start
breeding now as well.
That's super highly debated though
because a,
some key conservationists feel like
you're,
you're better off leaving them in there
as long as they survive.
It's,
it's,
it's a very controversial,
hunters tend to think that the idea is
that if the,
you,
uh,
can,
get them out of the food chain,
the younger bucks,
we'll have a chance to rise up,
become dominant.
I don't want to do it.
I don't want to go,
what is it?
Tense?
I just don't want to,
I don't want to do something you enjoy.
I want to do something that
Cameron Hanes ultra marathon now that
don't want to do that furthest in.
Cameron Hanes is ultra marathon.
That's what you want to try and meet you
and Ari.
Oh my God.
He's got knee surgery.
He's not going to do that.
He's not stupid.
Okay,
let's do it.
Let's,
let's,
what's our next contest?
We have to another kind of art,
but art is integrity on this contest
because he's definitely a marathon is
what makes it the funniest.
Yeah.
If it was real spinning out,
I would agree with you.
It's obviously for comedic effect.
I know Ari very well
and honestly,
in terms of like the fairness of the
competition,
I benefited from this thing more than
anybody.
I didn't have to lose any weight.
I had two awesome podcasts with you
guys.
By all rights.
I should pay for it.
This has been a fun.
So let's figure out what to do.
What do you guys want to do?
You still want to go to Paris?
I could do whatever.
I could do something else.
Whatever you want to do.
Let's figure out what you want to do.
What you want to do and let's do it.
Okay?
Nobody,
we need to get on this right now and put
it in stone right now.
Yeah.
Why does it have to be bad?
Like wine?
I've had a lot of girls say they want to
go home with me and then went to go
stand by the door.
They're not there anymore.
Okay.
We gotta do this.
Me,
you,
me,
Joe.
And is not going to make you take them
on a trip.
Who Do rd.
I mean,
where are you?
I'm saying anybody like,
you know what I'm saying?
Like what?
Why do you,
why do you think,
do you have to lock it down?
I want to find something.
I want to,
I want to continue this bet continued.
Oh,
you want to take it to another point?
If you're doing next level.
Oh,
I see.
It's not going to be,
no,
not even a day off,
bro.
Right back.
What do you mean?
Because you know what man,
it gives you,
it gives you focus and you're right.
It does,
it does.
It gives you focus and I enjoy it gives
you something to look forward to.
Like taking the girls to London.
Like I was really bummed out about
Christmas.
And then Christmas Eve I went how by
assault trip just to night.
Like we're too comfortable with a lack
of competition and aren't we?
Yeah.
Like you guys get sharpened by this
experience.
I think so.
I'm a better Bert.
Bert Better Bert.
Got The name of my tour
tours.
I never named a fucking tour.
Talk to old.
No teeth,
no fucking access.
Ah,
by
the way,
by the way,
you goes.
Last night I did a,
Joey was a Nosha oh.
For the podcast.
So I was hoping he would kind of put
some weight on you until he was,
I saw him,
I saw him on his podcast and he was so
high that,
you know,
we very seldomly when,
when Joey's high,
when he starts doing stuff like this
and he'd just swallow.
He goes,
he just caught a rat in his hand at
eight o'clock.
I was like,
he's not making it.
Yeah.
O and P it was,
uh,
it was,
it was a great podcast.
Joey's Parkinson's was great last night,
but I watched it live and I was like,
he's not coming over.
So I was like,
Leon,
let's do a box.
He did.
So he did a podcast with Leanne last
night and,
uh,
halfway through she goes,
I had to edit it out.
She goes,
oh,
is this,
is this good?
And I was like,
I don't know podcasts with guys and
girls,
like a comedian and his wife has aren't
never funny.
And then she goes,
what about Tom?
I push,
I go,
it's fucking different.
And they shoot it,
edit it out,
and she goes,
oh,
it's fucking different.
Huh?
I'm like,
wow,
but she's pushes a comic.
It's different power from birth.
You're thrown his wife under the bus.
That's what it sounds like.
You're totally in and the boss.
Oh,
it's fantastic.
Isn't that right guys?
You are amazing.
You probably won't have time for a one,
two,
three,
three waters.
Oh my God.
Two of those three bottles of water to
have those gigantic two oh,
coconut cans.
I've had half this handle and I've had,
I've had a drinking.
Wow.
Two of these.
I shouldn't even care man.
I tell you what,
it really would kind of made me
appreciate water.
I know.
I really appreciate water.
Like meaning like,
like I was like,
you know you said that water damn shit.
And I was like,
I never got it.
Really.
I was like,
oh yeah,
water tip.
Like I was like,
I didn't,
I didn't find him to get a competition
for us.
No,
but now
let's do the volunteer jam and that's
not fair.
Giant leg up
for what I love you.
Okay,
let's take a big step.
What topic?
He goes out of his debit card.
About time.
This could be a co a show that's a
contest between youtube every month.
Could be the greatest show the world has
ever known.
I would pick a pitch up beat.
Did you should someone has to develop it
for online.
That's what it should be.
Yeah,
it should be online because that's what
we could do it.
Yeah,
forget all this nonsense.
Trying to explain it to people that give
you money and put cameras on it.
You don't have to do that anymore.
And not,
not that you've ever had bad
relationships with any of those people,
but you won't be able to smoke pot.
You won't be able to be honest.
You won't be able to talk.
You won't be able to swear.
You do it online.
You could just be you.
That's why podcasts are so fucking good.
But it is why podcasts are so good and
that's why people really know who you
are.
You know what I mean?
People know you from the travel channel
and they love you from standup,
but until you see you do you,
you,
you have the shots.
The thing was joint in.
We're all having fun.
You use to kind of dial back a little
bit.
This is that like,
and this was the defining turning me
where I'm at today was like all my
friends that you,
I'll just say I'll,
I would say specifically you,
Bill Burr and Tommy were all like a
drop.
So it was great.
But like you better stand
up in your bedroom and you're better at
like being you.
And it was like one of those things
where you go,
oh yeah,
maybe I am a better,
like maybe it,
that's the cool thing about the internet
is that I don't want to be like,
hi guys,
welcome.
I'm Bert Kreischer.
Like I don't mind doing that for money.
But like,
well I'll tell you from someone who did
it for five years.
And so I did it alongside while you were
doing it too.
I know it's a really great job and your
jobs better than mine in terms of like
the fun event,
like the places you got to go rather
than a fear factor,
which is,
you know,
most of it was local.
Occasionally we traveled,
it's gotta be fun.
It was fun.
Crazy show.
No,
no doubt about it.
It was definitely a fun game,
but the difference between that and
standup is giant and if you don't,
if you don't give stand up,
the fucking respect it deserves,
it becomes dog shit.
It just does.
It's,
it's just too hard to not,
it's too hard to not happen.
Yeah.
You got to do it all the time to it all
the time.
You got to do it all the time and if
you're doing a gang of other shit on top
of it where it's where you can't do
standup for months at a time,
like you were doing your like to do it.
You're too funny though.
Right?
Rolling.
18 weeks straight on the road.
That's where it comes from.
We haven't named the tour technically
because I don't,
I've never named a tour,
but how about that?
I have never named a tour.
I've never named tour Bert Kreischer.
I have never named it to our perfect,
that's a great,
you can do one every year.
I've never named a tour to.
I've never named a tour.
Three I really like about Alberto.
The first one I ever saw that someone
named one was a jen Kirkman and she
named a tour and I was like,
oh,
fucking Badass.
I saw that and I was like,
the first one you ever saw it stay
offline.
Did you have a head injury?
The I ended up paying the text.
We've never seen it before.
I've never seen a person.
I take that back to punish your tour.
Punisher tour.
What was the punisher door?
Kazia punished her tour was the first
one I heard that everyone like was
talking about the punisher.
Punisher.
Well Griffin named his tours back in the
fucking 90 [inaudible].
What's up with Eddie Griffin?
I don't know.
I think he's doing that.
A tour with a,
who is it?
Like George Lopez,
George Lopez.
Eddie Griffith.
Cedric.
And who else is one other person?
Tell you something man.
I tell everybody there's been a few
sets.
Does it fit a few sets that I've seen
where you know there's people that catch
genius in a bottle man,
they just catch genius and it might be
only for a short amount of time in their
life.
It might be for a moment.
And I'm Oh Eddie,
Charlie Murphy's on it to dl Hughley
cedric the entertainer.
The JB smoove.
No Man,
this Charlie,
Charlie Murphy's on the pitch.
So it's called the comedy get down,
but they catch,
they catch lightening in a bottle that
they nail it.
And for Eddie Griffin there was a,
um,
what was that hbo suppose it Def Comedy
Jam.
Yes.
It was a def comedy jam special that
Eddie Griffin did and I,
I'm pretty sure he was wearing shorts.
You're right,
he was,
he,
I know I,
which one you're talking about?
He came out and he was so ex below sieve
with the way he just,
every punchline,
he was involved in a semi shirtless too,
wasn't it?
Like there was something going on.
Something was picking up a picture of
Jamie.
He was so,
it was like the way he was moving there
was so much energy.
This is not it.
No,
no.
It was another one that we said it's a
half hour special.
Yeah.
Is that what it was?
That might've been,
I think you're right.
It was an hbo.
I think he did this and then he did
that.
Yeah.
Well anyway,
when he did that special,
whatever that special was,
when I watched parts of it,
I don't even know if I had,
I think I'd started doing stand up.
I was just like an open at time,
just Kinda just getting going.
And I remember thinking,
Holy Shit.
Like that guy just tapped into that
weird rare spot where you could never
imagine yourself doing it.
I don't,
I don't know if that's it either,
man.
Is that what it says it is?
It might be it.
The colors look off,
but maybe it's just my memory.
He did food.
Who Child too?
I'm going off.
That was before this or no,
no,
no.
I'm pretty sure that was a later one.
But he's,
someone always had seen live.
Oh,
he's making Katt Williams.
Eddie.
So crazy.
He's a real nice guy though.
But I'm just saying like,
I wish I had,
I had been at the store when they were
at the store.
Bomag Eddie Griffin.
I've always got along with that guy.
He's a super nice guy about cat.
I don't know him.
I don't know.
I'm a big fan though because that's a
big fan of what he does.
Can you do curiosity?
Do you not reach out to them to be on
your podcast?
No.
If I run into them,
I would love to love to see Kat Williams
and Eddie Griffin on your podcast.
But you know what man,
I would too if they were around like
it's,
it's a matter of like,
I don't want to bug anybody,
you know?
Especially nobody that I like cat.
I don't even know.
And Eddie,
I've known forever,
like if he's around,
he ever wants to do it.
If I see him at the store or something
like that.
What about,
what about Chappelle?
I would love to do with Dave and we've
talked about it,
but we just never did it.
And it's one of those things were
awesome.
Dave is another guy,
like you don't want to,
you don't tell them time,
time,
damage.
I texted him,
we talk,
but he's a,
he's a super unusual guy,
man.
He's just doing his own thing and if he
wanted to do it,
he would ask me and then he'd come and
do it and we never got,
hey joe,
let's do it.
I'll be like,
fuck it.
Come on.
He's the only person.
He's,
he's the only person in the world that I
consider it the great white shark.
Meaning when he walks in a room as a
comic,
there's a weird energy where you're
like,
I should have stayed sprawl.
Like,
yeah,
but that's for me,
me and Tom,
probably same age,
but like he walked into the room when I
was getting paid date in one night,
just walked into the room,
you don't what?
You can get your check.
It's like closed.
And he walked into the room and I just
added my car was like,
oh.
I was like,
oh my God.
And I'm do not get uncomfortable around
famous people.
But I was fucking shaking and I was like
doing like shit.
You're embarrassed about where your
posted up a little bit outside the realm
of him going like where's everyone going
on it?
Yeah.
But like,
did you know what was the headliner?
I'm just burt.
I was was like,
but he's one of those uh,
guys talk.
I never spoke to him.
Yeah.
And he lives around there.
Right.
And dates silver.
Rhea is that it's workout club where he
goes to fuck around anymore.
But they said he used to stop it.
Stop it all the time to do it anymore.
I don't think so.
He had to good to all the like
Cincinnati area places too.
You know what he does,
man?
He'll just fly into a city with no plan.
Yeah.
Like in like when I was in Denver,
I go,
why are you here man?
He goes,
I just decided to fly in.
He's like,
they were going to,
uh,
the Canelo Alvarez fight.
Who's Canelo?
Alvarez fighting was the light skinned?
What?
Mexican dude?
Who Do you fight recently?
It's out of the fight was,
it was some fight in Vegas.
Hey Dave,
I'll be at the Wilbur Theater January
21st,
2010 I'll fucking party with you and I'd
love to party with Chappelle.
My point was he just showed up out of
nowhere.
He just flew into Denver.
I saw that picture that got like fucking
something like 249,000 likes.
What was the,
uh,
the video was hilarious.
What's right?
What's that?
Can Emir Khan fight?
Is that what it is?
Oh hmm.
Could be.
Okay.
So does he roll solo?
Liam Smith?
Who the fuck knows what fight it was
then?
Maybe I'm,
maybe I'm wrong.
Maybe it's the manny Pacquiao fight
pack.
Y'All fight recently.
Yeah,
he did.
Right?
He's gone to see him fight a few times.
What fight was,
it was,
it wasn't that long ago.
It was when I was in Denver.
When he goes to watch fights,
just flies in watching some boxing
matches.
He loves boxing.
Dave Chappelle loves boxing.
Really?
I got a buddy of his,
it's like a a boxer and does like boxing
training and shit.
Yeah,
Jesse Vargas.
Then November 5th weekend.
I think that was it.
Oh,
maybe that was it.
Yeah,
it was probably yet.
But uh,
he just,
again,
he's like a version of Ra does whatever
the fuck he wants.
Definitely flies into places.
Yeah.
Comes and hangs out.
That's Rad.
I know he's done the,
that club that's like his favorite place
and that Denver and they said that,
um,
he's just been like land had been like,
hey,
is anyone booked tonight?
I do the show and then we'll just add
nights if he feels like saying that's so
crazy.
It's so awesome though.
Yeah.
What's the most important,
I'll say it from the other side of you
too.
Chapelle is that,
I can't imagine what it's like for him
to go there,
like in and be like,
how are ticket sales?
Like,
you know what I mean?
Like there's no such thing.
Yeah,
that's what I'm saying.
That at a club,
what do you think he says that?
No,
not really.
I'll never,
never really,
I mean not in 10 plus years for sure.
Have you,
when was the last time you were like how
are ticket sales for like a club for
anything?
I know I have counts sent to me when
things are sold out or not sold out,
so I can decide whether or not I should
tweet it again or put it up on instagram
or something.
Yeah.
I just look at like,
I wonder what it's like to be Chappelle
and go,
I'll
do this.
And then four minutes,
everyone that city would want to come
and see me.
Daniel tosh put up a tweet and in a
tweet he sold out like a whole tour in
the date.
Yeah.
Within like less than an hour.
The whole tour was sold out.
Unreal,
man.
You did a show with them,
right?
Yeah.
It was so fun.
I've,
I've worked with them.
It's a fucking best.
He's a dude stole water in it.
Yeah.
He's crushing and it doesn't give a
fuck.
It doesn't another guy.
That's exactly why I'm doing interviews.
Yeah.
Doesn't want to do anything stupid.
He's like,
I don't care.
Tell one from the guy who gives a fuck a
hundred percent I'm like,
Oh,
do everything you need to do out with
them.
Soak it in.
He dangled Taj is a smart dude.
Yeah.
But he's,
he's untethered to also like how,
so he's,
I mean,
it's very easy to go.
I'm not doing any press.
When you have the number one show on
comedy central for what,
10 years to,
he's saying it's very easily tethered,
meaning not controlled that you,
if it was like whatever,
top three or something,
you know,
like not the leading thing,
you'd still see him being very much
cause he,
oh,
he's still,
yeah.
I,
I remember we did a show together in
Miami and there's a heckler in the front
row and like,
I was featuring form and I came off,
this is the two weeks after Georgia was
born,
almost 1213 years ago.
And I said,
uh,
and he goes,
that's one way to do it.
He's like,
oh,
go,
what would you have done?
And he goes,
I would have kicked him out.
You'll see.
He goes,
go watch.
And I ran around to the back of the club
in Miami,
the old Miami Improv.
And Daniel Tosh literally folded his
fucking arms.
He goes,
I will not start the show until he's La.
He's kicked out.
He didn't know,
knew him.
No one knew any of his jokes folded.
His arms goes,
I will not start the show until he gets
kicked out.
And I was like,
in my head,
I was like,
can't you can't believe you're going to
fucking throw this show for one dude in
my head.
And by the way,
you know,
you knew me at the time.
Yeah.
And everyone starts booing and he's
like,
no.
He goes,
no,
kick them out.
Kick them out right now.
Arms folded.
Kick 'em out right now.
What does the people booing at Daniel
Tosh at the whole idea,
because I'd worked through it like I
had,
I'd worked through it and that's why was
the original heckle?
Like what happened?
It was a dick.
He was a redneck with a mullet branding
with a mullet.
You want to say it was Patrick swayze in
my head,
the guy was shirtless.
I'm sure it wasn't,
but I remember him being short story
every show you like,
this piece of shit was shirtless.
And he was like,
he literally,
the guy was like,
okay,
here's how it goes.
No.
So,
uh,
so I'm in the back and I'm watching this
and then toss gets into it with the guy
and the guy starts calling fuck you and
talk.
She goes,
no,
fuck you.
You're not over.
Goodnight.
Have a good night.
You know,
in a very touch way I'm not doing it
right,
but I have a good night,
have a good night.
And then the guy goes,
I hope you die.
And then Tosh as the guys getting walked
out the door,
it goes,
I hope you get aids.
This is 1990 90 2004 and everyone groans
and then toss it,
looks at the audience in a moment goes
the good kind of aids,
like Magic Johnson a.
It's where he started opening movie
theaters.
The place goes fucking nuts.
And his first joke,
and this is old joke for toss,
so I'll say it,
his first joke is now it's by Vr or very
urban club.
He goes,
Koby Bryant,
so good at basketball.
He should be allowed to rape women.
And the place goes fucking.
But he goes,
if I was his,
this is his attorney,
I would simply put in a highlight reel
and go,
ladies and gentlemen,
the jury,
it's one white check a year.
And,
and I fucking sat in the back of the
room.
I was like,
this is my new favorite comic.
I walked into the agreement and waited
for him to come out and I was like,
dude,
you're fucking amazing.
It's a funny dude,
man.
He's a good guy too.
And he's a very good guy.
Like he talked to him,
he's right there.
He really is.
There's no weird fake shit going on
weeks ago and melrose.
And he said,
how's the weight thing going?
Should I go tweet,
tweet parties,
fat please people?
And he goes,
he goes and just walk.
Yeah,
yeah,
for sure.
Absolutely.
I saw him in Hollywood and he arrived at
the store.
Him and Judd apatow bumped me and he,
and I was like,
it was,
my father didn't bug first side of the
store ever as a paid regular and I was
44 44 years old and I'm in touch.
She's like,
hi,
I'm sorry about this.
And you know,
very cool.
And then I say,
how's everything you use?
Good.
How's everything with you?
I said,
good.
And he goes,
I go,
how's Malibu?
He goes,
perfect.
Yoga,
meditation,
paddleboarding.
How the kids.
Okay.
Vacation.
Fucking love that guy.
Yeah,
it's good dude.
Yeah.
To get it Puerto Rican beard.
I mean we can do a five hour podcasts
and just keep drinking.
I'm don't mind.
It's up to you dude.
But what's about,
uh,
two 15.
What time did we start this pitch?
1130.
Yeah.
We get a dirty,
you really bring a barber's minutes.
I got a little tweezer thing or a little
over right there.
You ready to do this shit,
Tommy?
Hold on Tommy.
Tommy's just decided this is happening
and the whole show are you going to go
with,
is a bunch of attachments to that jammy
depending on how close and if you want a
sculptor or contour or anything along
those lines,
but are you going to try to do the
prints?
You think Tommy?
Um,
here's what I want to do.
I want to,
I want to bring all this out.
Bring that bottom out.
Okay.
Right,
right.
I'm putting a nice line.
Okay.
You're going to sculpt it?
Yeah.
This is going to be a pro job.
Okay.
Um,
what about the stash?
That's what I was saying.
I want to bring,
oh my God.
I might have to be this,
but if you do that,
he's just going to shave that off.
Oh my God.
Fucking pictures.
Pictures,
pictures.
A dude's beards.
It's so ridiculous.
It's a better,
there's nothing better than the Jaguar
guy though.
Or the Leopard guy was unbelievable.
Pretty guys off the charts.
I gotta put this on my phone too,
because I don't want to show my daughter
and hold it.
Hold on.
No,
no,
no.
Hold on.
I'll jamie
wide angle so I can move over there.
Oh yeah,
yeah.
Okay.
I'm gonna move over here.
You guys with a beard?
Is My on it?
Total gut health and uh,
uh,
Shit.
You're ready?
Oh,
really?
Can I put it?
I should put it in like a,
a ramp.
Want me to hold it?
No,
I'll give it laugh.
Uh,
yeah,
but I want you to be a part of it.
I don't want you to know I'm right here
though.
I know,
but I don't want you to have to focus on
me on you're holding it and give me that
fucking thing.
Shut up.
I'm right here.
I'm just going to rest it right here.
Drive.
Am I getting heroin on me right now?
Tom,
you're going to get a little bit of hair
on you.
Hold on.
Let's,
let's tighten this up.
Oh,
you got your passwords hun?
it's a four four eight seven 77 right.
Good luck finding my phone.
Wow.
How long it became a challenge.
Just like the weight loss challenge,
so fine.
And shows the Internet.
I bunch of sizzle is Dex.
Okay.
Hold on,
hold on to every one.
Okay.
Don't fuck with my hair.
Like my actually hair.
Hold on.
No,
no,
no.
Give me more true to a landscape in
which the landscape landscape.
Put it this way and now I'm going to
have to do the fucking anything on this.
Okay.
Hit Stop Record.
I hit record.
Okay,
we're recording right now.
Okay.
Hold on.
I'm putting this here.
I'm going to take a,
uh,
Bert Kreischer please explain to the
people it's about to happen and why
my beard is getting shaved because I
challenged Tommy bonds on a beer
challenge on who lost the most weight
and he lost a collective like six pounds
more than me.
I failed.
Go ahead.
But you did succeed in losing a ton of
weight.
I lost.
I lost 35 pounds.
I think so I,
I,
I'm happy that at least I'm not as fat
as I am.
Just start.
What if you look better before we do
this?
I will not want to feel better.
What if you decide like,
I liked the new birth?
Maybe the new Bert,
I a new bird doesn't,
doesn't sabotage.
Thanks.
Maybe they knew Berk with this new film,
Rdo uncomfortable with this.
Can we go?
So Tommy buns insisted in shaving a
beautiful pattern of worked so hard in
that area.
You worked on.
What did you do?
I just grew it out and I sculpted it.
All sculpted area vulnerability.
How's it scope?
What I do is I,
I went to a black barbershop and I told
them that the people might cut my beard.
He taught them.
I ask them,
ask them,
what do you love?
Where's the microphone on these things?
I might've had my fucking finger over
the microphone.
And your cell phone is okay.
I hope.
I don't know.
I don't,
I feel from the podcast and it seems
like going really hard.
No,
no,
look good.
So you're sculpting.
You're not entirely shaving it off.
Tommy,
talking to the microphone please.
I mean so far Tommy,
why we decided to go high?
That's one of the art as I am a jawline.
Tommy,
why did you decide to sculpt it and not
completely shaved it off?
This is a guy where like I see so much
potential and I just want it.
I want it to maximize like,
oh,
where are you going to work?
Your phone is exploding with text
messages.
While I'm holding this up,
I could barely look at it because the
screen keeps filled it up with maslow.
He's giving you a Hitler Son.
Oh my God,
this is so stupid.
What's wrong with us?
We're all adults.
What the fuck is wrong with us?
Oh my God.
Very.
Can I please see it?
Oh my God.
So you're doing the prince.
Oh my God,
I can't breathe.
Oh.
Oh,
Ooh.
Is this the first time you saved another
man?
Oh yeah.
Oh,
but I've thought about it a lot.
I still feel the same right now.
I'm going home on home.
What are you doing?
Someone's hair.
My mom gave me.
What about,
what are we doing when we do it?
You can't drink right down,
son.
You're in labor.
Oh,
you've given birth to the new bird.
Oh.
Oh,
I'm a rash.
this is hilarious.
Hm.
Tommy,
you an artist,
uh,
you know,
used to do Tommy.
He shouldn't once a year.
[inaudible] sculpt a fan's beard.
You're a god damn artists,
dude.
Good job.
It looks amazing.
Really.
He shouldn't be the new thing that
people do.
Go back to like sculpting beards.
That could be a show.
That's all the fluid I have on my body.
This can be a show you do on the travel
channel where a y'all get fucked up and
get someone and you shave their beard.
He's going to be very right there.
Oh Shit.
Don't go too hard on high
vulnerability.
Oh,
you look really good at.
They're really,
yeah.
Yeah.
You're gonna like this.
This might be the greatest,
greatest.
Tom,
are we good?
We're pretty quick.
Yeah.
All right.
So for people just listening,
what Tom has done is sculpt birds,
beard,
and what could best be described as a
fencer from the 16 hundreds in France.
A fence her.
Yeah.
You look like either that or uh,
or someone who would lie about being
Puerto Rican.
Cause they're really from like
somewhere that no one's ever heard of.
And they're tired of people saying,
where the fuck is that?
And they go,
it's,
yeah,
I'm just Puerto Rican.
He looks very Spanish Mike.
But New York City fly,
you might stick with it yet.
You might.
Oh,
Brill.
He's a Goddamn Maurice.
Imagine if it turns out the Tommy Buns
is the premiere beard artists in North
America.
I mean,
we're watching this then.
What's the way and really how many
people are watching this or thousands.
That's so ridiculous.
I feel like you might really be happy
with it.
You didn't really go from there.
Okay.
Are you going to keep this or are you
going to turn?
Turn me please.
Huh?
That's actually not bad and I'm not
bullshitting.
I'm not bullshitting at all.
I don't want to be surprised.
Let me see.
That's not bull.
I'm not bullshitting.
You look good dude.
Here's the thing,
man.
Look at you.
Sorry.
Go on.
I look like I work at blue.
The apes.
I look at it.
Fuck no,
no,
this is not.
Look,
he doesn't look good.
Look at all the hair on me.
You get an earring on each year.
A big hoop like a pirate,
but I look like,
I feel like you rent.
You Rent Jet Skis for sure.
Through like what are you good idea
to fucking Shane who hearings?
Barry.
Take your phone buddy.
Oh my God.
It looks pretty good.
Yeah.
Oh,
Holy Shit.
Can you see yourself performing like
that?
Fuck Ya.
Yeah,
of course you have to for a while,
right?
No dummy.
Shave it off tonight?
No,
no,
no.
You should definitely go on stage for
the audience.
The people that are going to appreciate,
they want to see you knowing exactly
what happened.
He's going to fix it.
It's not done.
You know?
That's what weird.
We never really determined when he's
done so tom can like step back,
look at it and decide to do some
changes.
Oh my God.
He found the rash.
Yeah,
man.
Sometimes we have rashes.
Ladies and gentlemen,
it's not your fault.
I know you feel like you did something
naughty that the Lord punished you with
a rash,
but that's just superstitious.
She was in fact a really bacterial
infections on the surface of your
scandals,
so we're definitely better now.
I recommend defense soap.
Let me see.
I said just a mustache.
Fuck all that squirrely little bottom
here.
If you want to make them keep it for
awhile.
Yeah,
we'll keep it for a while.
I'm a grown man.
I'll go.
Let me shave.
None of them.
Mustache.
How about this?
We get rid of all this crazy shit.
Now I know what it looks like.
Give you a goddamn police.
Things.
Mustache man,
you actually look like I looked like a
monkey for real.
Let me see you.
You looked like you look like a top
notch bowler from Wisconsin.
You're a dude is on like world series of
bowling and everybody fears you like the
Bill Murray character.
Can you imagine making out with me in
the dark and you're like,
what is that on the top?
Oh,
it would be covered in the beard.
What was that movie?
Fucking great kingpin was that movie
good?
Starts flirting with a girl and he goes,
not you.
Yeah.
Oh Man.
Remember when,
uh,
we had to have sex with his landlord and
order to pay for the rent.
Nothing like that to loosen up at shit,
throw it up.
Benches,
toilet.
You remember that?
He,
uh,
he has the planned like robbery with the
guy and then,
uh,
sorry in my face in it.
Then he,
uh,
he throws hot coffee in that guy's face
because he has to act like that.
It wasn't a scam,
you know,
like,
like the landlord comes and he's like,
what?
You're here.
And he just takes the hot coffee and
splashed in the guy fucking screens for
his life to Jesus Christ.
This feels so weird.
This looks good.
I can only imagine.
It feels weird so I didn't know.
My face will be this close to my bones.
Well,
do do you guys view,
just don't do it like this,
like this craziness,
but just keep going healthy style.
You know what I mean?
We've got to figure out a way to get you
guys to not,
I mean,
let's be honest,
if you're not,
there's no way to do it.
If you,
if you,
if there is a target weight,
you're going to dehydrate yourself,
right?
Yeah,
of course.
You're going to,
you never know what very seldom does
someone go.
I'll get below that.
You Post that picture of me to talk to
me right out.
We're going to get totally used to it,
but I do suggest you keep the mustache.
I think it's a wonderful [inaudible] to
your face.
It helps you party man image and again
you'll clear curling champion from
Saskatchewan.
You look like a duck hunting guide.
Ailes had told me that a person should
do head shots while
you lived at a guy who teaches people
how to fly fish
because it knows the difference between
a Mallard duck.
Exactly.
Less a diver duck.
Oh,
it was a totally different kind of meat.
You look like you definitely live in
your hometown
and you got to pennzoil tattoos,
bought a mustache.
How's it look good?
He looks really good.
Really?
Yeah.
You should see it closer.
Let me see your instagram.
I do think there's something to be said
for bringing back mustache.
There's a few people who do it and it's
a strong look.
No,
it looks good.
It looks like they look yourself up
there.
Oh,
oh,
oh.
I need to get my teeth cleaned.
Jesus.
This just looks sad.
Oh,
it looks like it.
Yes.
It looks like a guy who lost a fuck ton
of weight.
[inaudible]
to win a competition and I got a
mustache.
You rock this look and you go back up to
two 56,
that would be,
that would be an interesting,
so let me ask you guys this because
we're probably nearing the end of this
experience.
Yeah.
Um,
how are you guys going to go forth like
this?
Most of this was healthy for you,
Tom.
I think the majority of it was healthy
except for the last couple of days.
Yeah.
The actual trying to make the weight.
And Burt at the very least like you
curbed some of your insanity,
you know,
he curved it to the point where you lost
a tremendous amount of weight.
You know what I mean?
You got to feel lighter and better.
Right.
So how do you,
how do you move forward now?
Do you,
uh,
go back to life as usual or do you start
another contest?
Uh,
we can start another contest.
I'm totally comfortable with that.
It seems like burt wants to start none
of the content.
I want to start another contest.
I want already to be involved too.
Cause I like Orange Ball Chin,
Don,
Don.
So we got to get him in like ours.
We should do this online.
But the challenge doesn't have to be
weighed at the time.
It can be something.
No,
it be,
what could it be?
Um,
can be anything,
man.
That's the crazy thing about the
internet.
We can do whatever the fuck we want.
Whatever we come up with,
we could just do,
yeah,
no shit.
Right.
You guys can compete and stuff.
That doesn't even suck.
Right?
Like it doesn't have to be something
that sucks.
Like trying to drain your body and
personal go around the world the
fastest.
That sounds like a bird thing.
No,
no.
I'm just trying to think.
I'm just trying to ballpark your guns
but a bunch of data.
But the idea is like a competition show,
which mean to you guys would be amazing.
Yeah.
Cause it would be in the best spirits
too.
Like here's the thing about competition.
Like this right.
There was,
there was never any animosity.
So after it's over,
we're all laughing.
Yeah.
Whereas like if you have a fight for
instance,
and uh,
two people don't like each other in
particular.
Yeah.
There's always animosity before and
after.
People are pissed.
Oh,
it's always chaos.
She get our wives involved.
Dude,
you're trying to,
you're trying to get this personal sun.
No,
our wives.
That's cause that's what the untapped,
we're both happy this is over.
No,
I think I I liked this.
I,
I'm telling you I'm not adverse to doing
another competition at all and I think
it should be something crazy.
Well here we are in January,
right?
Okay.
This is the beginning first couple of
days of January,
2017 why don't we knock it around for a
few months and we'll figure out how to
finance some other competition.
This is like,
yeah,
so instead of a,
well let's just figure out like what
would be a fun thing to do and a
difficult thing to do.
Like write two things,
two parts.
A key fact.
Yeah.
Like will it be a fun thing to do but
also a difficult thing to do?
Will you guys could do it as a
competition.
It would be a big deal for you to the
point where winning it would be
valuable.
You'd want to like really work hard
towards it.
It'd be worth your dedication.
Did we can even bring like sponsors
involved?
I guarantee you it'd be like,
it takes like five minutes to figure out
what sponsors would be interested in
whatever kind of competition we figured
out
we could do something really fun.
We could do something really fun.
Yeah.
Like what would you guys want to do?
Like what seems like a fun competition?
Like want to go to the adventure?
What do you want to do there?
I don't know.
I just want to go there.
Oh really?
Yeah,
I think Racing Raisa that's fun.
Let's see what the core first person to
get across the United States.
The first,
was that a sentence?
Um,
yeah,
you could definitely do that.
Um,
what you do like a cannonball run type
thing.
I wouldn't say that one of you or you do
a lot of crossfit and you do a lot of
exercise one.
Neither one of you has like any immense
physical advantages.
Like if you started in a physical
competition right now,
right?
Like if you guys wanted to do some
great,
we don't,
you know those crazy marine things they
do with,
they climb over fucking poles who let's
go to seal training.
Listen to me,
don't do that.
Just listen to me.
That's worse than,
no,
I'm talking about some crazy like one of
those obstacle courses we have to like
swing from the monkey bars and climb on
the pole and all that jazz and climb up
the net though the rope net race each
other doing something like that and make
a big deal out of that.
That would be fun.
You guys didn't have to getting sick
shape.
Fireman Training Department Training
Ninja,
American Ninja.
Matt Iseman is on that,
but the problem is like,
do you really think you could even
complete that?
I could get halfway through it,
man.
I'm telling you I'm not that cocky
mental gene.
It for sure.
I moved my body pretty good and I
watched that on TV and I go out.
I think I'd probably fall off one of
those things called Matt.
Matt Iseman.
Right now he can get us on the course
and you were telling me what they'll get
halfway through and fall down.
I can definitely,
that is alphabet starts.
I can definitely get halfway through.
Well,
what do you think you'd be able to do?
I've already done the training.
No,
no,
I'm saying him.
Sorry.
Oh,
definitely more than half,
but I think we could also find,
I can get past on lily pads.
I think the whole thing.
Why don't we find it a course that is
like what you're saying,
difficult wipe out,
wipe out.
They don't do anymore.
Unfortunately.
That would be an easy one to set up
because Mac units was one of the
executive.
Bruce is a fear factor.
Oh.
Oh really?
Yeah.
That was his show.
The people who created wipe out and made
wipe out in America.
They were,
most of them were friends of mine,
but I could like a triathlon mom,
like something triathlon would be a
motherfucker.
Dude,
if you really wanted to do that,
that's your man.
Serious commitment,
man.
Man.
Might come in and sponsor us,
then we start to go to the death to the
next level.
Now that you have him over the ropes,
wants to go,
he wants to drown you in the ocean.
He wants,
he wants the possibility that he'll be
swimming away and he looks back and a
shark takes you could have the iron man.
Yeah.
What's the,
uh,
what is the,
it's like a short race.
It's a fucking marathon.
You've got to run a hundred miles a
marathon and you get to ride a hundred
miles on a bike and you get to swim a
couple miles.
Right.
I know the guy at Spartan race,
the guys,
what exactly are the parameters?
Like what clothes?
Anything.
What is this Jayman battle frog thing
they show on espn.
Sometimes it's like teams really racist,
but they could probably do it.
Oh,
we can do battle frog.
I'll look at this.
You'd have to run up this thing.
It's like a navy seal obstacle course.
Basically.
It's like saying what's really
fascinating about you guys is that you
both love each other and you're both
interesting combination of impulse and
discipline.
Re ridiculous,
fanatical,
like scramble sprint to catch up versus
slow steady marathon pace and it's
really funny man.
And laughing hard the whole way.
The tip of the spear.
Who made those graphics?
You don't make the tip of the spear and
make it a neon green.
You fuck.
That's not scary.
Tip of the spear out there.
Jabbing at the enemy with a cartoon
colors.
Is that going to be our thing?
Then we're going to find a course.
No.
What we should do is turn this TV show
into like ultimate fighter competition
thing where we beat both have teams of
losers like us.
Let's do that.
Yeah,
let's bounce around a bunch of ideas and
not commit to any of them.
Let's try to figure out like what would
be the best idea to have a fun
competition between you guys that would
benefit you because you guys both
benefited in a huge way harder.
You both look amazing.
Like dude,
I showed your video to my wife of you.
I'm joking around about the work was
already done,
that your work was already done and she
was like,
Holy Shit.
They just went,
Like they look you,
your skin looks healthy.
Yeah,
your face looks thinner.
I was like,
then you look vibrant.
You look like your body had more energy
to it.
Thanks man.
I definitely do.
I mean it's,
you know,
it's a lot of weight to he then you
always think about like,
man,
I was walking around with that every
day.
It's
too crazy and we talked about it
yesterday and sometimes people think
we're insensitive when we talk about
this,
like the subject of fat shaming,
whether or not fat shaming is a good
thing.
Look,
it's never a good thing to be mean to
people,
but it might not be the worst thing in
the world to feel uncomfortable about
the current state you're in.
If you know that states unhealthy and
attaching all these like magic words to
it,
like fat shaming,
you decide and it's certain actions can
never take place so you certain
acknowledgements of someone's issue with
their wade can never be discussed
because it hurts people's feelings.
It doesn't necessarily always do that
person a service.
Like we'd all be better off if we were
healthy.
It feels great to eat fucking Krispy
Kreme doughnuts,
but you know,
it feels better.
It's he krispy Kreme donuts after he
lost 40 pounds and you know that
tomorrow you're going to get back on the
fucking treadmill.
Yeah.
You know,
and you're going to start eating healthy
again.
Give yourself a reward days,
but don't let it control your goddamn
life and don't wrap it up and wrap that
criticism of protect yourself from that
criticism and a blanket of these fucking
stupid rules like don't ever talk about
someone being fat or don't ever discuss
it or don't.
Don't make them feel uncomfortable about
you're supposed to be on feel
uncomfortable.
It's something that you can change,
but if you don't,
it's going to kill you and if you do,
it's going to make you feel way better.
That's encouragement.
It's all,
it's the only way to encourage people
about certain things that are
uncomfortable is to make them
uncomfortable.
It's just no way around it.
It's no way someone's going to find out
they're overweight and not have it feel
bad.
I think the uncomfortable feeling is
probably like the biggest catalyst.
Like that's what makes you do stuff.
I think so too,
man.
I know.
You know it's an uncomfortable thing.
It's like someone being blue,
brutally honest with you about something
that you don't like about yourself and
then you act on it.
Yeah,
dude,
I,
I just think that we,
we definitely could use more nice people
in the world.
We could definitely use each other being
kinder and the world for sure,
but when you,
when you're dealing with certain
situations,
like at the very least,
you have to be stern with people over
certain issues.
Like if someone was a drug problem,
someone has a weight problem.
Yeah.
I'm not looking at you,
Bert.
You're fine.
You're doing great.
The cure a partier.
There's a difference between someone
who's got a problem,
who's life goes to shit and a guy like
you worked constantly and also just lost
30 pounds.
As a matter of fact,
you might be like the perfect drawing
line in the sand.
Like here's the productive guy that's
enthusiastic about as partnering,
partying,
but he's also a great family man.
A great fucking podcasts are a great
fucking comedian.
You're,
you're having fun,
you're being very productive.
You're doing various TV shows and on top
of that you're partying.
Yeah,
I can.
This is the line that you get.
Like when is it bad for you?
When is it destructive to you?
Well,
when it's good for your life and you're
having a good time as well,
like you've managed to correctly,
I think the,
uh,
so far can I go?
So I was,
I hadn't been that you're the highest
functioning party guy.
Yeah.
Hair all over me.
That's what it is.
For sure.
I am the highest functioning party guy
probably,
but I think also just lost 30 fucking
pounds.
Like an animal dude.
Yeah.
There's still in hard
man.
You ran 24 fucking miles in a day or 22
miles in a day.
Yeah.
That's hardcore.
That is hardcore,
man.
That's not something,
someone who's like,
oh fuck you tommy bb.
No,
I'm going to feel depressed.
Like eat.
Both of you guys are savages.
You buys both Doug,
you're fucking heels into the ground and
actually did it.
Yeah.
What you did is super hard to do.
You lost almost 50 fucking pounds,
dude.
Yeah.
It's a lot,
Tommy.
It's insane.
I know you will lost like a good solid
kettlebell.
A good one of those big asks and 15
Honestly,
we want to see that picture of mostly
stories again,
because that doesn't look like the same
human being.
Dude,
if you,
if your whole world is going to be a
different thing,
you're going to be going through life
lighter.
You'll have better ability to move
through life.
Like literally like if you,
if I,
if someone told me,
hey man,
from how on your jaw?
Oh,
it's crazy.
Yeah.
If someone told me,
hey man,
I'm from here on out,
you're going to be healthy.
Everything's gonna be great.
You know,
you're not gonna have to worry about
diseases,
but you're going to have to wear a 50
pound vest everywhere you go.
I'd be like,
Shit.
And then I'd start thinking about the
pressure that's going to put in my lower
back and on my knees and on my ankles.
And it's exactly what you see from
overweight people.
It's exactly the issue.
Yeah.
If you've got to live life with all that
extra shit,
it requires too much resources,
but you guys did one of the hardest
things that a person can do.
You stopped your pattern in its tracks
and you fucking turn the battleship.
You used your will and your discipline.
You turn the battleship in a competition
between friends and you both got
healthier because of it maybe
temporarily unhealthy and the last
couple of days does the dehydration,
but other than that,
the weight loss.
How much diet changed since we started
like consuming me?
It'd be two 27
but on that much,
100% no Cli mine because I don't want to
lose the bet to Hari.
No,
no,
no.
You're going to wait that it's over man.
You already wait.
Didn't we already removed Ari from the
equation anywhere you have a drink in
your hand though?
I've got an idea for it.
Oh,
Jamie's got an idea how much that's the
way it is.
Two 27
you.
How dare you?
I definitely have put on
and it's water weight man.
Yeah.
It's bizarre when you wouldn't see what
you are.
Water weight is,
I mean,
each one of these things,
as we said,
is a pound.
Right?
That's not that bad.
How much?
About
nine pounds
in water weight.
That's insane.
Now here's the thing.
How bad do you feel?
Have a seat for a second.
Like,
do you feel bad?
you know,
I feel great,
right?
You got to go on a foot race right now.
Do you think you'd be okay dude,
I'm a monster right now.
Okay.
Really?
I'm being dead serious.
The Best I've ever felt physically in my
entire life,
but be,
but even though you just lost all this
weight,
dehydrated
yourself,
they didn't.
I'm,
what I'm asking is like how much have
you recovered from the way you felt when
you came in to weigh in because he felt
like shit.
Right?
I feel so much better since we weighed
in 100% but do you feel like you could
go run?
Not right now.
I've loaded with pizza and vodka.
Okay.
But if you weren't like,
if you it like you feel like physically
you feel beside just hydrated that I
think,
I think a lot of times what you're
talking about fat shaming is that people
don't understand what it feels like to
be on the other side of that.
You get more vodka?
No,
it's a,
it's water yesterday.
Okay,
great.
Is that I bought a whole case of it.
Couldn't find it in the stores.
I think you can get it online.
Where'd you get it online?
I did on Amazon.
It's Stevia flavored soda,
but it's good.
Zero sugar in it just in Stevia is like
a natural plant based sweetener so that
doesn't fuck with your blood sugar
levels.
Yeah,
it tastes good.
I still don't have to pee.
That's an amazing,
that's it for bottled water too.
It's amazing.
You guys are awesome.
Well you are the water champ though.
I'm going to take a picture of that
before we leave because it is quite
preposterous because you've had a drink
too.
Yeah.
So Tommy's consent to these biggest
commissions,
just kill it like a grownup.
No,
that's a sip.
Like are those 16 ounce cans?
How many ounces are in those cans of c
two o coconut water?
These are 17.5 Jesus Christ,
he killed two of those and then for 16
ounce waters.
Yeah,
I'm on number five by the way,
if you're one of those people that's
like,
oh,
coconut water tastes like toilet water.
No,
it tastes like jazz and it's delicious.
Hey is a coconut.
You're allowed to just steal that and
put that in an ad.
If you want to get the right coconut
water,
you got to get it from Thai,
Thai coconuts.
The best one.
That's a very sweet.
Yeah.
If you ever had the Tiki ones that are
Mocha that have caffeine in them,
those are really good too.
Like yeah,
those are good too,
but those have a lot of sugar in them,
unfortunately.
I mean,
they're really Yummy,
but they do have a lot of sugar in them.
You know what really is the bass like
there's a company that has it or it's
fresh coconut water.
Is that the one that,
yeah,
it's a harmless harvest
coconut water and you drink it.
It's just like it.
Your whole body's just going to make a
coffee flavored one.
They have a copy of flavor that's a
different one.
That's different one.
But yeah,
and the coconut waters.
Unbelievable.
People get mad if you start talking
about coconut water or Kale.
You're the person that introduced me to
coconut water yesterday.
It looks good and I'm actually already
used to it.
I'm used to it already too.
It's all bullshit,
man.
All right guys.
Listen man.
When I was scared,
shaved my head,
I was,
before I shaved my head,
I was thinking about it for like a
couple of days.
I was like,
should I do this?
Should I shaved my fucking head?
Cause it was just getting more and more
Janky looking up there.
It was just giving out.
I was,
I was you in five years and I was like,
it's almost over.
I just got to give in.
And then when I finally fucking changed
it,
I was like,
God damn it.
What was I,
why did I shave it a long time ago?
This is way better.
It's way easier.
He had just looked different,
right?
Like,
and people are,
everyone's,
we're all afraid of looking different
for some weird reason.
Yeah.
Down there.
Yeah,
it's different.
It's better,
you know.
But I do,
look,
I feel like I work at deadwood,
but on the south side this will be
great.
Here's one that actually the big things
about how this,
it turned out because you've lost so
much weight.
The impact is not like if you had been
full two 50 [inaudible] oh my goodness.
It would look worse.
But you lost 30 some pounds,
so it actually,
you know,
did she keep it?
I think that mustache looks good.
I think the mustache at the very least
should stay at chin hair.
But kind of what I'm,
I really want to it.
I really want to use a razor raised on
like 12 years.
They've been going go get a real shave.
Ooh.
Yeah.
Go to a barber and you know,
sit in the chair.
And you already said one time black
barber.
I went to a black barber,
but he's just trimmed my beard.
Well go there again and you'll trim your
beard.
Get up real shave.
Yeah.
Do you guys feel better after this is
all over or do you feel physically
drained today?
I'm really tired,
man.
But we also stood dehydration.
Right.
But that was row that I like that.
What the drugs and alcohol.
Oh yeah,
that's your favorite part.
But I mean like up until then,
um,
you rehydrate it a little bit before you
start boozing.
Right?
Didn't you correct a lot.
But,
uh,
I feel fantastic right now.
I feel really good cause I feel like
I've earned a lot of stuff.
Like today I had two pieces of pizza.
This is the way my brain's working right
now,
but I already know that I've burned,
um,
all my fitbit or just a,
no,
it's not.
I've burned a 3,200 calories already.
Damn.
Dude,
this morning.
Wow,
that's amazing.
So,
um,
my,
I,
I'm excited for like,
uh,
to make,
I get these,
the,
these styrofoam cups he started to,
and I'm deciding to make a big ice water
and sit.
Why don't you guys have a Jujitsu match?
Why don't you guys train for three
months and have a Jujitsu match?
When did that.
Oh Man,
I'll do that.
That's what I'm talking about.
But we need coaches though.
Oh,
we can get you those.
Okay.
Okay,
that's good.
Wait,
but,
but I like hundred and 50 grand on the
line.
We might be able to get that.
Okay.
Is there a second place?
A second place?
What are some of the second place kid?
You start play scared.
It was the loser was the loser.
Get nothing does a winner.
When I get something to lose,
he gets dog shit.
They get nothing.
Zero.
I Dunno.
It seems usually how it works.
It seems exploitative.
Oh really?
Yeah.
I think the winter should get more.
The should get less,
but the losers,
the losers should be compensated just
for competing.
Yeah.
I got you.
What if a,
the loser gets the loser gets to go on
the trip and this,
well,
this is the case.
Like it's not like you guys are betting
150,000 hours.
This is that Ari is the,
the,
the WHO's the,
what's it my friend and I must protect
him from his tendencies.
So I will assume the fiduciary aspects
of this negotiation from here on out.
Thank you.
Uh,
it's the,
what's,
what was John,
what was John Travolta in the,
in that movie get shorty?
He was the vig parties.
The vig.
Okay.
John Travolta was in g get shorty.
He was a,
he was a bookie.
I don't remember that movie at all.
Why?
I remember that niche shows and movie
came out and was up to me.
He's like,
I want to be a Hollywood producer.
And he wrote a script.
God,
Dad,
why am I having such a hard time
remembering that movie where he has or
he has the script?
He's like,
he's like,
I'm the producer of this.
A few of those movies that you fucking
loved when they came out like a bronx
tale.
Yeah.
Fantastic.
And then you watch it on TV.
Like why is this completely gone from my
memory dude?
And this House Hackman is so fucking
funny in this movie.
I got to see that movie.
Or He's so 90,
what was it?
95.
Wow.
You remember that Gene Hackman scene
with the,
uh,
the guy that died?
Um,
who cop the former cop plays that he
plays that Miami gangster in this movie
and he flies out to get his money from
him.
From Gene Hackman.
Look at how good the man,
I don't remember this fucking movie at
all.
It is a high possibility that I'd never
saw.
Oh No.
I saw this movie.
I remember that violence is equal to
various,
that's the Guy Dennis for isn't it fast?
He's so fucking funny in that.
Oh,
he's funny and everything that he died
recently.
Delroy Lindo is my favorite black and
yellow fever.
Jamesy that they'd beat him up.
Oh Jesus Christ.
I should watch that again.
Yes,
that's great.
We should do a fight companion.
We watch it.
We should watch.
Yeah,
let's watch.
Get shorty into beer,
man.
He'd have a couple of drinks.
Get Baked and watch.
Get Shorty and talk shit.
We'll tell people to sync it up.
Let's do one.
Hey,
let's fucking do that for real.
I haven't seen this movie and forever.
Let's do it.
I barely remember anything in this
movie.
Like I might've seen this movie when it
came out and completely forgot about it.
Since then.
I've never seen it since.
So it'll be a total surprise if Jamie
kills these previous calibrator.
Yes.
Let's do one with Ryan Reynolds for a
van wilder.
Do you want to do that?
Yeah,
I is that going to be weird because you
haven't seen it.
Have you seen it?
No,
I've never seen it.
You never saw the movie that was based
on a story about your life in college?
That seems crazy to me too,
if we're going to be honest about it.
Yeah.
You know,
I never could.
I never had the validation that I had
now in my life where his company,
he says that that's what it was based
on.
So I'd take it say it on radio and so I
didn't want to ever watch it,
so I felt like I was lying.
Did they pay,
you know number?
That could be fun.
Awkward moment.
No,
but I think Ryan Reynolds is into it.
I mean it's company says he's into it.
I think he'd be into it,
into watching it live with us.
We all get baked and have a few drinks.
I don't remember.
I don't know Ryan.
I'm not sure.
I don't know him either.
I don't know why he'd invite them.
You don't even know him.
I like the assumption that he'd be like
into it.
Well they said they do loves gets baked
on the Internet.
They said he's a regular guest.
They said he'd do it on my podcast and I
was like,
I do it.
Definitely do that.
Who in who like took your story and
brought over there and profited from it?
Oh,
some writer and there's,
there was never an issue because it
wasn't really you as based on you or
stories about you that they added a
bunch of 'em.
The option was made by a company,
by an agency,
a literary agency and they uh,
took it and they sold it with me and the
writer of the article attached.
So the are the movie had to be about a
journalist writing an article about a
party animal.
That was the caveat.
So then I got,
I discovered by will smith and that deal
fell apart and the oliver stone deal
fall apart.
And then one of the producers are one of
the writers who had submitted scripts or
send a script in and it was moving
forward and they thought that was gonna
be the one when it fell apart,
he just took it and sold it.
The Van Monitor or to national lampoon
and they made a van mater.
Wow.
Yeah.
So I didn't really have any attachment
to any of it.
I never got paid for any of it and I
didn't make any of it.
But at the same time,
like my best friend in college,
his name's in the movie and so like,
like so weird.
Yeah.
But I don't,
I have no bitterness towards it.
I don't care.
I don't give a fuck.
Well,
that's good.
So it's a little sidebar to your,
to your life.
We put,
don't stop putting on shit.
I gotta get going.
No.
Why?
Where we've got a podcast today.
Yeah.
What?
You did one yesterday?
I'm not doing one.
What do you have to go?
Where are you going?
Uh,
I'm just ready to go.
Why do you do that?
I would never do that.
Why?
PODCASTS is ain't no result.
Yeah,
man.
What,
what,
what time are we at right now?
It's,
um,
we're about three hours in.
How many minutes?
10.
Three 17 three.
Well,
we gotta do another 12 minutes at least
to ramp it up to the,
at the top of the hour.
Top of the top of the hour.
Okay.
Well how do you get like that?
That's just how I am.
Wow.
You guys are funny.
This is like impulsive versus
discipline.
This is slow,
steady marathon versus sprint.
I love your drunk.
Yeah.
Not both are virtuous.
Does virtue in both?
Yeah.
Both of our strategies will pay
dividends.
They both will bear fruit.
We should do a tour together when I get
famous,
because you guys just show,
uh,
you guys are so opposite ends of this
spectrum.
When do you get famous?
You guys should do a tour together.
No,
you don't think your family,
you don't think people would know who
you are.
You just told me about the rams game
where some guy yelled out the
[inaudible] pull.
People didn't stop doing it.
I my,
I wore my name on the back of my chair.
Right.
Uh,
no.
I know you're a good level of fame dude.
Fuck fame.
I like,
uh,
I'm being dead serious when I say this.
I love the way people that don't know
that I'm friends with Tom.
I love the way they talking about stand
up.
Like
when we were there,
like there's,
I'll say something about you.
And they'll go,
oh,
you don't have top scorer.
Oh my God.
Like his standup's fuck.
I just,
my favorite,
it's my favorite special ever.
Most of the stories,
my favorite special ever.
I love that.
That's what I like.
Yeah.
It's always nice when you can tap into a
bunch of people that kind of feel about
somebody the way you feel about them.
Yep.
Bill Berman has been my favorite person
because we all can agree he's maybe our
favorite guy doing stand up right now.
But Man,
uh,
I love him.
Tommy just gave the end,
met some med sand he's mate.
Yeah,
he's definitely in this like rare group
of people that I seek out to watch to
stand up.
This is tremendous man and I think
there's also like,
it's a really good thing like just like
you guys were talking about the
competition of a,
the weight loss and the fun inspiring
you.
There's at least some sort of a
unconscious competition when you're
surrounded by people that are really
funny.
Yeah,
and like where we're at store.
man.
Right where we're at right now,
today in la in 2017 is a really rare
time where this is like we're surrounded
by killers,
you know,
and guys,
people don't even know like Owen Smith,
you ever see Owen Smith,
the comedy store?
It's been a while.
Fucking hilarious.
Santinello you've seen sandy.
We talked about him yesterday.
I want to hear Marius.
There's a gang of these kids and men and
women and know a bunch of people coming
up.
There's a bunch of people coming up that
are really fucking funny.
Yeah,
it's a,
it's an awesome time,
man.
I worked with a bunch of dudes that are
super funny that come with me now.
Uh,
Josh Potter.
Have you done with him yet?
But he stinks.
I just like,
I know for what it's like to be Josh
Potter right now and hear your name
brought up on a podcast and go and then
go,
oh,
what would they shit on me?
No,
I won't charge.
You haven't seen him in forever.
He's with me in a West Palm.
Can you take a trial with you?
I love that guy.
Take full charge a bunch.
Full Chatham House is a good man.
You've had Jeff Haden,
right?
Nope.
You've never had a one?
Never had a job aid on.
Nope.
Yup.
Yeah.
Great.
There's a lot of good ones.
Um,
I took drawn Horton with me to a,
the comedy works in Denver.
How was that?
Fucking great.
He's a funny dude,
man.
And it was also funny dude,
Josh Martin.
Josh is fucking hilarious.
Hilarious dude.
He says my funny shit.
I was like,
Hey,
you should do the road more.
And he's like,
why can't get off Thursdays or Sundays?
And I was like,
well,
that's the row.
Like I was like,
we were just bullshitting.
I was like,
well,
that's the part of the time I beat you.
The nights,
I don't want to do it either.
Right.
Carlos Valencia,
you know him.
Yeah.
Super Funny.
Super Fun.
Like the,
the 2017 roster,
like the people that are coming up right
now that people are just starting to get
to know him.
Yeah.
They're the most educated in all of like
the young group of comics that are
coming up because all of them,
you know,
all these young men and women that are
getting into stand up now,
they've,
they've experienced the whole internet
boom during their adolescence.
You know,
like the big grew up with it,
but the comedy fans,
comedy fans
and the Internet boom is allowed them to
have access to everything.
I was,
when we were kids,
we'd have to go find a bill cosby album.
Yeah.
You know,
we used to have to find a kinison
cassette or a dice cassette.
We had to go find a Richard Pryor CD,
you know?
Yeah.
It was hard.
You had to go seek it out.
Like now it's instantly the moment you
get it in your head that I would like to
see some comedy.
Almost everyone has some kind of a
computer today to remember when you said
that when I used to open for Bert and
like really early on,
uh,
see how it hard he would kill like he
kills so much harder than most people
can understand and I would try to mimic
some version of what he was doing,
you know what I mean?
Cause like hit such this energy energy
and his the way he is.
So I'll go up there and I do my act but
I'd be like,
Ugh,
like,
like he does.
And like I had a friend who was like,
hey man,
you look real crazy up there right now.
He told me afterwards it's good.
Trying to be like best the best.
Maybe my favorite time in my friendship
with he is when uh,
when you bombed in Sacramento.
I've never enjoyed like,
you know,
like it's a real bad bomb too.
It was like what started it?
Not a rape joke,
but
it was good,
at least tasteful,
well it was,
I wasn't like endorsing it.
I was making it.
It was,
it was,
uh,
you remember Hurricane Katrina
happened and there were stories that,
that I think that and this,
all the chaos people were getting raped
and I opened with something like
something like,
you know,
there's nothing like a floating corpse
to get me in the mood to fuck somebody.
Right.
Then I would elaborate on the story and
have joked that it would started there
and it was the early show Friday and I
mean that now I did that and I get a
laugh and I'm telling you it's a full
house.
I got no laughs for the next 22 and a
half minutes and I know it was 22 and a
half minutes because I was supposed to
do 25 by the way.
Tom had his hair,
his hair was long at the time it was
like a comb over.
And what would happen is slowly as he
worked,
it would flatten onto his hat on his
head,
on his face,
and just be wet.
And I'm sweating a lot,
man.
And then when I got upstaged the lady
goes,
I thought you were supposed to be funny.
And I was like,
ah,
you know,
cause you're just like so vulnerable.
You're like,
where's The lady?
The booker and you've managed it.
And uh,
did you do any other sets there that
week?
Oh wait,
there's a 10 o'clock show,
10 o'clock show.
I opened the same way and I bombed just
as hard back to back 25 minute sets just
as hard.
And then I remember the host goes,
I've never seen a feature bomb like
that.
Like he was,
he was,
and he was the MC.
And then I really was like,
you know,
like having to lie to myself at the
hotel.
I was like,
I don't what the fuck I'm doing.
But I was like,
no,
it's definitely,
you know,
what you're doing.
And it unlike,
it was,
it was a shaky thing.
And then the next day burt goes,
uh,
hey,
can I tell you just one thing?
And I go,
yeah,
what?
He goes,
just open on a different joke.
Just open a different joke.
Do exactly everything else just opened
on different joke and I go,
okay,
I go out there,
I do what he said.
I have to that point,
probably the best that I've ever had.
And then I go to the manager who's
behind the curtain and the kitchen and I
go,
well,
and she goes,
well what did you do your set?
And I go,
you definitely just heard what happened.
There was like,
there's 300 people out there.
And she was like,
did it go well or was it just like last
night I was like fuck.
And then I went back and the same thing,
I did the same thing,
the second show just open differently
and I was like,
ah,
thanks burt.
It was the best advice I ever got.
Wow.
So through that,
it's hard if people don't know who you
are.
If you jump out there and alienating him
with a fucked up joke and then they tell
me later,
they're like,
well,
you know that first group there was like
a 90 Mormons that just wanted to share
baseball.
Mormon.
Yeah.
What in the fuck is that?
That's what they used to do.
They just sell,
sell out the place for church.
And then you didn't know you were
performing for.
It'd be fine if they get drank.
I like Mormons,
but I mean at a comedy show those like
crazy.
I know they do.
Yeah.
I know that the party with a bunch in
Tibet,
you have,
they're allowed to,
pills aren't in their doctrine.
No pills.
They can do pills do.
You can do monster energy drinks too,
but they can't drink coffee and load up
on those fucking gigantic know those
fucking huge cans of red bull that you
look at them and go,
no,
don't think that
they have all sorts of polls.
Even Monster Energy.
Never.
Never there.
Awesome.
If you want to stay away,
what do you like on coke?
I'm like,
I try to blow,
you know like,
cause I know you partied really much
harder than I've ever partied,
but you'd see so even Keel when you get
high,
I go to,
you're not even fucked up fucking
minute.
You really think that Tommy has partied
much harder than you've ever partied.
I know that.
I know.
He knows that.
Do you think that's true?
100%.
Making reference to one occasion.
I've never overdosed.
Yeah,
that's true.
So he's overdosed.
Overdose on.
I took a
wait.
I drank too much ghb and then I,
I took some ecstasy and then I had like
12,
13 screwdrivers.
Oh my God.
Oh Shit.
I was a freshman in college.
Oh my God.
I had my shit and control.
That's amazing.
I haven't been,
um,
I,
she won't come to the hospital.
Yeah.
Strapped down tubes down my throat.
Wow.
Pumping
was top of the hour.
I'm gonna wrap this up.
So it was a no,
it was really bad,
man.
He was really bad.
Wow.
Yeah.
You told this before though,
right?
I told him her show there's a,
it's a Tom Segura overdoses.
I didn't hear that story.
Yeah,
it's,
um,
two w w what happened when they said,
what did you take?
What did you write down?
They gave me,
so I'm strapped down.
They,
what they do when you,
oh,
D and the catch you at,
at that stage,
because I passed out is uh,
this starts to swell.
So they thought about giving me a
tracheotomy and they put tubes down
there.
They are strapped down so that you don't
pull the tubes out when you come to.
So when I did like your,
your hands are really restricted and
then they,
um,
they're trying to get figured out what's
going on that see if you can help them
know what's in your system.
So they gave me,
I'm lefthanded for,
for writing and they gave him the pen in
my right hand and strapped.
So they write like,
or they ask me,
um,
what did you take?
And I wrote a heroin and they were all
like,
are you serious?
Just kidding.
Oh yeah.
And then I had to like write out what
it,
and then they found,
you know,
they,
they give you that.
Why didn't you write out I'm lefthanded
it seems like
they found out the toxicology report.
They go,
you have everything in your system.
Oh my God.
It was like,
you have,
you know,
our bitch with you of uppers.
You have downers.
You have,
uh,
you have opiates because the GSP was
spiked with stuff on my heel.
Light took with spike was style.
He's like,
that's the thing.
He goes and you have so much in you,
like it would have killed a lot of
people.
Like that's amazing that you're alive.
And I go,
why am I alive?
And he goes,
honestly,
cause you're pretty big boy.
Basically.
He was like,
you're fat and that's what saved your
life.
That your 250 pounds at the time.
Wow.
Yeah.
Did that change the way you partied?
Oh my God.
Dude.
Yeah,
of course.
Yeah.
Even keeled now.
Like even still like when we went into
New York
two glasses of wine,
I just am not,
uh,
it's not from that.
I just,
um,
mean I'm not just a,
I'm just not a big or you love jumping
up and down.
Yeah.
You love the sprint.
I do.
He do.
You love the,
we're doing it.
We're,
if I could do it best is when,
when I,
there's too many times where I've been
at his place and he's like,
just taking it easy.
And if I go like all you have to do,
it's like you just,
you plant the seed and you go,
hey,
you want to have a beer?
Here's what we drink.
What did you get so excited?
She the level of excite your house.
You've done it before.
I've done it before,
but your kid's birthday party,
you were like,
fuck that beer.
And I was like,
yeah,
every time he,
you never go like not right now.
No.
That's not who I am.
Somebody suggests you're on board.
That's one of the most
fun things.
You're,
you're all about it.
Yeah.
I like it.
I like the rush of it.
Like imagine when I have you in a
fucking triangle and I'm about,
is this going to happen?
Can I get a Eddie Bravo?
Well,
what the fuck?
He knows Eddie Bravo to.
Okay,
Eddie,
pick your teams.
You get,
Jack says,
how does that work?
She had eddie yet.
What a better team.
You just do it at Ebi or something like
that.
Yeah,
we definitely want Dvi.
Looking for my fucking teammate.
We can definitely do to the Ebi.
Maybe it's not fair.
Since Eddie knows both of you.
Maybe it's not fair that either one of
you gets trained by Ed.
I'll take shawn,
shawn,
Shawn Shock.
I'll take it.
That's fine.
I'll take John Shock.
I'll just take some Brazilian.
Yeah.
Anyone who wants to,
anyone due to bone.
Yeah.
One of those dudes from the Gigolo show.
Absolutely.
And he's like,
I'm Brazilian.
And be like,
I trust you.
Let's do this.
Hey,
I teach you triangle.
But at first I'd be right back.
I got to slim the Dick.
Okay.
This has been a great fucking podcast.
What would you do if you did do a
Jujitsu match?
What'd you do?
Like how long you think it would be like
a five minute match?
10 12 no,
buddy.
I don't know.
I've never done,
I've never seen once a long time.
I think we do,
man.
I mean it would have to be one round and
see who can,
yeah.
Yeah.
If you guys really want to do it,
what bounce around it.
I don't think there's no need to,
uh,
there's no,
there's not a need to come up with a,
a definite contest right now.
You guys are eyeballing each other cause
I'm thinking about cross country skiing
where they had the rifles to,
we can do that.
Okay,
I'll look that up.
My biathlon she had to buy I thought
line shit.
Like are we going with that?
Something called the total archery
challenge,
which like you run around the woods and
hit targets.
Oh,
I mean I'll kill that.
Listen,
just,
we could,
you guys could do a bunch of shit.
It really should be a show though.
Yeah.
We should definitely do it.
If you keep it along the path that it's
been on for this sort of competition,
this is like a super beneficial
competition for both of you guys.
Yeah.
He lost and insane amount of weight.
You really did it.
Seriously.
That's the one that really like freaked
out.
My,
my,
my sisters have never watched this
podcast.
They've heard it before that ever
watched it.
They watched it with my wife and my
daughters yesterday and I came home.
They were like,
Tommy's lost a lot of weight.
I was like,
Hey,
your dad has two and they're like,
I know what Tommy has lost a lot of
weight,
but they see your daily,
they see me daily,
but they were like,
Tommy is also a lot of weight.
That is a problem though.
When people are around you all the time,
they get used to a certain look and even
if it shifts radically over the course
of six months,
you don't notice it.
This one's going to take a while for the
family with the failed the mustache.
I'm going to trim it up a tad bit before
I go home,
but yes,
I think the bottom part is a little tad
bit uneven and it looks good.
Agree to disagree.
If you want to trim it up,
that's all fine and dandy to trim it up
a tad bit.
I think the most I should stay and I'm
very happy you made that decision.
Yeah,
that's good.
I think the mustache freak the fuck out.
They're going to laugh.
They're going to be fine.
We're happy to see you.
They're going to be like this eating
dinner when we just odd.
I have a business meeting.
Yeah.
We're going to be laid for that for
sure.
Nope.
Nope,
nope.
I'm good.
I'm good cushion.
That cushion is very important.
But Jamie,
do we have to leave?
Cause Tom's moving around like he has to
leave,
but I don't think he has to know.
I don't have to leave.
I don't have to leave either.
Tommy,
this is one of the things you get off a
waffle state.
No one's your waffle date.
I don't have the time.
There's no time.
No time decision.
We're going to go.
It's a good move.
Yeah.
Waffles are like pure enjoyment.
There's no illusion of nutrition,
especially when the crispy on the
outside and you could just tell us all
into something.
I just,
I go fucking whole hog.
Really butter.
I just kill that thing with butter to
chapter.
The souffle I talked about.
Same thing.
You're just making a decision to
indulge.
Yeah.
Just hardy.
Go deep.
Ever had a caviar.
Yeah.
Uh,
uh,
Rod Stewart Daughter's party.
My first weekend I'll name drop out and
I had caviar so much I couldn't,
I couldn't take it away.
I don't number five,
they took it away.
They took the caviar away from you if
you're eating too much.
Eating so much.
Cause I'd never had it before.
They actually moved to the whole plate
of all the seafood and pulled it out of
the table.
Oh my God.
Nicole [inaudible],
Nicole Richie.
What's her name?
How drunk were you?
Kimberly Stewart.
Sober.
Still sober.
I just never had caviar.
So you were going at it so hard.
They decided this guy's going to eat it
all and it's selfish.
Gluttonous rampage of caviar
consumption.
My Buddy Eddie was like,
if you're at caviar before,
and I was like,
no.
And he's like,
dude,
you should try it.
So I tried it with like a cracker.
I was like,
dude,
you should try it.
So I'm in hall.
I was dipping into it like a guacamole.
I was
murdering it and they came out and
remove the whole plate.
It was like a like literally as you're
scooping or three people,
three foot plate.
They were moved it back to the kitchen
and I was like,
where did that go?
Isn't that funny?
Like they'll put food out,
but only if you eat a certain amount of,
they see one person's enjoying it too
much.
They will move in.
We passed me another piece of Pepperoni
please.
Yeah.
This whole,
this one's,
this one's done.
Oh,
for real.
What was this event that you were out?
This is the one with mushrooms.
Do you want to know more chatham quote
that I party?
What was the,
um,
I party.
What was the event that you were at?
A,
uh,
I might,
I was at ICM at the time.
Dad was at ICM.
Malaria.
So they were trying to preserve the
food.
They tried to get me fatter.
We enter new competence.
I'm terrible sliced.
You son,
he gave you two slices and made a
sandwich
pizza though,
right?
Mm hmm dude.
Take that to the meeting.
Take the double pizza into the meeting.
Yeah.
No,
just take the thought of the double
pizza.
The fact that you,
uh,
you came in silver in the weight loss
challenge.
I was gold and silver.
It's not bad.
Yeah.
No big deal,
man.
Powerful political contest between you
two guys,
like every few months.
I think that's the sort of still fun.
It's still fun.
Yeah.
Figure out a perfectly ideas surf
competition.
Like I can't stop at all.
I used to surf when I was kid,
but now I feel like I can,
cause I skidded yesterday.
I've told it.
Best case scenario,
someone stands for three seconds and
then gets a concussion.
Best case scenario.
Fuck it.
Surfing man.
Surfing is incredible.
But I dunno if you guys really want to
get into that competition.
How do you even judge that?
How do you judge it?
Amount of time that you're standing up?
How do you judge it coach later?
No,
Kelly Slater.
Judge.
It wouldn't get them on the couch.
He would probably judge it.
Or are you shopping?
That'd be fun.
Yeah.
We've talked about it a few times.
What's up dog?
He,
he,
he uh,
texted me some ridiculous videos.
Sebastian inlet
things.
No,
I mean he would the,
I never even saw him,
but it was apparently a bunch of good
surfers would do the Sebastian inlet,
which is not far mauser whole.
Yeah,
no,
that's true.
But especially with like,
yeah,
that's a totally different type of human
to get on a board and ride it on top of
the ocean.
It looks so fucking cool when you see
the high,
the high level guys do it and they have
the Gopros on.
Have you seen his new Surf Pool?
No,
I too.
I put her on my facebook the other day.
It's called a Oh shit.
We put it up on here one time.
Did you?
Is it the one with the perfect glassy
lake?
It's like the perfect way.
Oh,
it's so beautiful.
Can you play it real quick?
It's the most beautiful thing you've
ever seen.
That strong word telling you.
Well,
I dunno,
they just go into the detail right here.
The water champ has down five bottles of
water and to coconut water.
How deep am I on this?
This is insane.
Can I actually get another one?
Yeah.
Really?
Oh,
you have a child and I haven't peed.
This is amazing.
The water champions just breaking into
his bottle of water.
Look at this.
Tell me this doesn't reek gorgeous to
you.
Yeah,
just hold on.
Hold on.
It's an amazing fucking ability that
these people have riding these girls
like this.
Let's look at this.
This is incredible art,
Tommy.
I'm having Deja Vu right now.
Yeah,
the rail,
right?
Well,
he built that pool.
That's his pool.
That's a pool.
It's not the ocean.
Oh,
really?
Yeah.
That's what's amazing about this.
Oh my God.
So you could learn how to surf on this.
Yes.
Oh my God.
No sharks.
Look at her.
That's a pro surfer going.
Thank you God.
How do you know what she's saying?
What did I knew of her?
She's just laying down Lakey Peterson.
I've interviewed her.
You have?
Yeah,
I know.
All these people power from her crush or
pool.
100% it's a pool.
Oh my God.
Where is it?
It's I,
they won't tell you because they're
trying to sell it.
The,
the,
you can see the hints of the posts in
the corner,
man.
Oh,
that is that what that is in the back?
Yeah.
And there's sides on it.
You can see the sides.
That's crazy.
That's pool.
That pool is this stuff,
man.
It's massive.
I want to say,
where do you do like a manmade lake?
It's not really,
I wouldn't call it,
where is it?
I think somewhere in Malaysia and stuff
like the big,
like a wave generator pull like a
waterpark.
They just have the biggest,
best version of that.
Wow.
This is crazy.
And this is,
you said Malaysia?
I don't know.
They don't tell you.
I think they also are going to make
slices.
They can sell them wherever.
They could pick a ticket somewhere.
Ah.
All right boys.
Um,
should we wrap this up?
Hey for real.
Thank you for hosting it though.
My pleasure,
man.
My pleasure.
I'm honored for real and the oil shrunk
from my mouse will hold on.
I'm sorry.
Yeah,
I mean it really was fun.
I'm glad that you,
when you were like,
I'm gonna do the MC the way it was.
It was really a fun time,
man.
Oh Man.
For me it's even more awesome.
You know,
I love both of you guys.
You're both hilarious and to have you
come in and do this in here,
it's fun.
And I really mean what I said that what
you guys did,
whenever someone does something like
that where they just decide to make
contest and the the results,
that contest is,
you could radically improve your life
over a short period of time.
Radically improve your health.
I mean,
I can't imagine what it would be like to
walk around with 57 less pounds.
I mean,
it's incredible.
What,
how much did you lose total?
Was it,
I guess 51 51 51 pounds removed from
your body is an incredible
accomplishment.
I like 11 pounds of water at this point.
Yeah,
but it doesn't matter.
It's still incredible.
Even if it's only 40 like actual solid
fat weight.
Yeah,
it's amazing.
He's amazing from man.
You do look different.
Thanks Ben.
And you show a little bit different too
different,
man,
everybody can do this.
You know?
And there's a lot of reasons why people
make excuses.
You'll feel you'll feel so much better.
You really will.
Yeah.
Instead of coming up with reasons why
you can't do it.
Try to figure out a way that you can,
and it might not be today and it might
not be tomorrow,
but there's gotta be a way to improve
things and to always concentrate on the
reasons why he can't.
You've got to keep winding up and
patterns and sometimes like a little
competition like you guys did in fun and
fairness and friendship.
It,
it's a good thing because it shows
people that everybody want out of that.
You know,
even though you had to shave your beard,
you still lost 30 fucking pounds,
man.
I mean what happened was awesome.
So it's all,
it's great for everybody.
It's great for me too.
I love seeing people do that.
I love seeing people get their shit
together.
I think it's,
it's been a blast.
I'm glad you got involved because I
think I stepped it up to the next level
and made it,
it made it more fun for both of us cause
we started getting bigger and bigger and
bigger and uh,
I don't know,
man.
I'm ready for the next contest.
I know you are.
You fucking crazy bastard.
That's up.
Tom and I had discussed before I go,
you know,
it's just,
you got to deal with burt's crazy.
Yeah,
he's,
he's got that thing and I'm in Jiu
Jitsu.
I moved to Brazil and move into a
favela.
Want to go to present?
Just talking shit.
It's plenty of places to learn right
here in southern California.
Luckily a lot of like super high level
per shot.
He downed it again.
Oh my God.
This is the six bottle water.
I was barely Russell Vodka,
you know Russell Peters.
He's been training with John.
John.
I met that guy.
Really?
Yeah.
Russell Peters came on the show we did
together.
So Jack,
he's the best.
He's awesome.
I love that guy.
All right folks.
That's it.
This bitch is over.
Thanks guys.
I'll praise bank of Bert Kreischer and
Thompson Gora.
Uh,
burt cast,
uh,
your mom's house.
Uh,
you get a checkout bird special on
showtime,
showtime online.
Right now I'm on demand.
Showtime on demand.
Thompson girl of course has to Netflix
specials out a next dates that you're
doing.
Kansas City Oxnard,
and then a big theater tour.
It's all at Thompson to that new place
in Oxnard.
I'm doing that place in heard.
It's awesome.
I'm doing the club there.
Yeah,
me too.
I'm doing that a let me live.
Is that what it is?
Or stand up live?
Which lot?
Bert Kreischer.
Where you at next?
Uh,
I'm a stress factory this week.
American comedy company.
Wilbur theater.
Helium Buffalo.
Excuse me.
In January.
All right.
You go to their websites for further
details.
Thanks everybody for tuning in.
This was a lot of fun for us.
Glad it was a lot of fun for you.
And uh,
it's 2017 let's get this shit together.
Bitches coming over.